[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
battle lines were drawn as players dug
in and squared off for day two of the
american cup in saint louis three
clashes were over in regulation granting
the victor's entrance to the winner's
bracket with sam sevien crossing the
2700 rating threshold on his way to
sending top seed wesley sowe to the
elimination bracket the rest of the
field went to tie breaks with five
surviving to claim the remaining spots
in the top tier some heavy hitters went
down early who will be this year's
phoenix and rise from the ashes to claim
the ultimate redemption
round three of can't miss chess coming
up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody to day three of the
american cup a new and enterprising
chess event hosted by the saint louis
chess club we start a day in front of
the enterprise center home of the saint
louis blues 2019 national champions well
we have a lot of chess national
champions competing for the title in the
american cup let's go to the studio and
start this exciting day with yasher and
alejandro
welcome everybody to another beautiful
day here in the central west end in the
heart of saint louis we're here at the
st louis chess club to bring you the
action of the american cup 2022 i am
grand master alejandra ramirez joining
the legend himself grandmaster yasser
sarah juan in an incredible event yes
sir alejandro as always a great pleasure
to be calling the action with you we've
had an intense event players here it's a
double elimination they get two lives
many of them are down to their last
life and we'll be saying goodbye to four
players today absolutely hello everyone
and welcome to today's show thank you
for joining us and sharing your day
yesterday was simply great entertainment
boy did we have a lot of fun and a lot
of blood on the board let's take a look
at who won and who lost let's take a
look at our brackets we have
in the champions section the champions
bracket these are the players that still
have two lives to learn names we have
levon aronian who passed over ray robson
and lanier dominguez who passed over sam
shanklin both of them in tie breaks
meanwhile in the lower half of this
bracket we have sam savion who took care
of wesley so without needing those
playoffs they went straight out of the
classical chess brilliant game there by
sam with the black pieces he defeats the
us champion and now gets to face fabiano
caruana this is going to be an
absolutely great match savion is the
upcoming player in america he just
crossed 2700 karata let's face it looked
shaky yesterday he did this is going to
be a great match up meanwhile in the
elimination bracket these are the
players that today are fighting for
survival they'll be playing a faster
time control than the players in the
champions bracket they play 25 plus 10
today and we have the matchups of ray
robson against sam shanklin and wesley
so against geoffrey xiaomi these are
heavy hitters but two of these players
go home today absolutely big shout out
for ray for for forcing the play off
yesterday but he couldn't quite get
across the finish line in his matchup
against lavon and in the ladies bracket
in the ladies section in the upper half
we see two players that just went on
cruise control to the second round irina
crush passed easily over ryu yang yan
meanwhile gulrock back in tokyo had
absolutely no problems against kathy and
himself they will be facing each other
today meanwhile in the other brac in the
other section of the bracket we have
alice lee that
passed over stability
of abrahamian will be facing her in the
elimination bracket we have riyang yan
playing against kateri and emsa one of
these two players will go home and also
a surprising elimination today one of
stavrolla tolaquiro and anna satonski
deserve the two and three seeds of the
tournament one of these two players will
go home and you can see starula there uh
chatting up before her round she's
actually a very chatty player right
and enjoying the company of course a lot
of these players are friends and she is
here with one of her friend caterina so
both of these players in good moods but
they know they have to bring the fire
today because otherwise they'll be going
back home and uh
our format for today alejandro
absolutely we have two different
brackets today in the champions bracket
we continue business as usual we have
our classical time control a fast one
because there is no second time control
we have game 90 plus 30 and that's it
but we also have the first matches of
elimination two rapid games per match 25
plus 10 being played today if those
matches end in a draw one to one then we
will play ten plus five and that will be
today as well this is the last chance
for some of these players to remain in
the tournament they must pick up the
gauntlet today is a big day yasir will
be saying bye to some great players we
will indeed and christian drill down on
some of the matches today
thank you yes sir what a day of
relentless entertainment we had
yesterday with both the championship
brackets as well as the playoffs and of
course it all started with those two
comeback wins the one of ray robson in
that english as well as tatev abrahamian
who won a must-win situation against
anna zatonski to force play-offs also
she won both of her playoff games won
three in a row and today she's in great
shape to potentially even win this match
as well but the highlight of yesterday
was in my opinion the armageddon between
fabiano caruana and jeffrey shong and
jeffrey sean with the black pieces had
to make a draw he only had three seconds
at that point knight takes h6 bishop
takes h7 all he has to do is make three
more moves e4 e3 and king to c3 and that
is going to complete 60 moves and he
will start getting two extra seconds
increment he did not manage to do that
hesitated playing king to c3 and
unfortunately flagged fabiano caruana
moves on and remains in the championship
bracket jeffrey sean moves on to the
elimination bracket and only has one
life left but let's see what the
matchups of today are we're going to
start with the championship bracket that
is fabiano caruana big match against sam
savion the newly minted 2700 american
player and we see their lifetime matchup
one win one loss and two draws this is a
very even matchup i'm definitely having
my eyes on this one but another big
clash is the clash between the newcomer
in american chess leveronian facing
linear dominguez these players don't
have as much information about each
other as the previous matchup because of
course we know that aronian just came
into the american chess scene we see
their lifetime match up three wins for
for aronian one loss and a lot of draws
and look at aronian he seems quite
relaxed speaking with chris bird our
international arbiter here at the saint
louis chess club and in the latest
section well we have some mouth-watering
clashes that is the one between
eight-time national champion irena crush
facing tohir genova lifetime matchup
between these two ladies zero wins zero
losses and one draw in the u.s
championship 20 uh 2021 last october
the second matchup in the ladies section
is the one between the youngest
competitor in the event alice lee only
12 years of age but we saw how much
experience this lady has against tatev
abrahamian there are no previous
matchups between these ladies this is
going to be an exciting one to follow
guys what do you think
well at 12 years old it's just a great
pleasure to be in such an illustrious
field as we see the ladies coming up
into the st louis chess club they're
playing on two floors above us
it's a beautiful chess club
and there's a wall of
fame there with all of these past
champions that have won
national titles here in saint louis so
there you have
alice lee getting ready for her big
matchup and alejandro if this if this
tournament is not enough chess for you
we also have a blitz tournament coming
up on april 29th we might have the
playoff for the american cup determining
with how it ends in the champions
bracket but we definitely will have a
blitz tournament nine round event blitz
of three plus two great prize fun we'll
have 40 grand masters participating it
will be the players that got eliminated
from this event it'll be the players
that join from around the area you might
think local players yeah yeah local 26
hundreds and there's a bunch of them we
have missouri university down the block
we have st louis university coming here
we have webster university that will all
be joining the freight it's going to be
a super super fun event lots of uh
specialists in that one for the blitz
section let's take a look at the prize
fund for this tournament we have a 200
000 price run for the open group 50 000
goes to first place twenty thirty five
per second and twenty five for third
very handsome the player that goes
through in the classical in the
champions bracket uh through goes to an
extra ten thousand dollars as a bonus
and in the ladies group the latest group
has a hundred thousand dollar prize fund
first place will be 25 second is 18 and
third is 12 and the player that goes
through in the classical in that section
gets an extra five thousand dollars wow
not bad very very nice as there you see
the players all taking their seats well
with one
exception
exception as we're getting ready for the
second match in this the initial
of the american cup absolutely we have
one side of the playing hall that is
going to be the elimination matches
that's on on your left if you go up
through the stairs at the club the west
wing the west wing yes and on the east
we have the classical chess so we'll
have a little bit of a faster time
control here on the left 25 plus 10
actually considerably faster while these
players on the right will be playing
their classical chess very nice
and i have to tell you this match up
lavon aronian versus lanier dominguez
this is like the olympia
clash because these two players are for
sure going to be on the u.s olympic
squad so
not just a lot of
money at stake but also uh
well
fighting for position in the team it's
an interesting match because erroneous
somehow has not that i remember played
too much against lanier linear
it's remarkable really milanis have been
a top player since forever exactly and
levon has been the number two player in
the world in many many many lists
exactly and here we off go to off the
races i'm curious about this one and
it's e2 e4 and i was too i was about to
say lavone has been playing the english
as you saw with ray robson but he threw
out one e2 e4 today christian what do
you got to say watching that up
switching it up
we know that leveronian uh three four
years ago was only playing d4 and c4
maybe some knight f3 recorders as well
e4 not so much and recently he started
touching the e pawn as well on first
move and it does seem like that created
an immediate instantaneous surprise for
lanier because right now he's already in
deep in thought what is he going to play
is he going to choose c5 is he going to
go with e5 a more solid approach of
course i do believe that leveronian is
expecting uh linear to choose e5 and go
for a more solid approach nevertheless
did play c5 yesterday
and
he yes he's going for e4 e5 uh he's a
berlin player but he's also an
anti-martial player
okay very nice we're so knight but no
petrov uh
there you go
there you go
right there you were supposed to snap
right back with no well he's not known
as a petrol player but remember that he
did work for fabiano caruana alongside
christian and i uh for the 2018 world
championship match so he learned a lot
about this opening we learned a lot
about the petrov i'm
very sick of it but we checked a lot of
the petrov yes exactly knight to c3
yes a very aggressive probably the most
aggressive approach against the petrov i
want to say it's the modern approach
isn't it the knight c3 it used to be it
used to be up to the last couple of
years i think i think it's giving way to
d4 and move three right and knight takes
e5 uh on move three as well with the
ideas of quick d4 knight c3 somehow gave
way to the other variations chess
fashion right there you go it just comes
in in and out of fashion also the
chinese players
were
taking the black side of this knight c3
and really instilling
uh the lines and it's very important to
see how black is going to approach this
position is he going to go with a more
aggressive approach with long castle or
is he going to play a more peaceful
approach with bishop to e7 then short
castle that's probably going to face
an attack on the king side coming from
white side white is going to go knight
to d4 bishop to e3 as we see queen to d2
followed by long castle and at some
point i'm going to start pushing my
pawns on the keen side let's see how
lanier approaches this one even though
he played the move bishop e7 he can
still continue with bishop to e6 knight
to c6 queen to the second and long
castle instead of short castle let's see
what he chooses though it will be very
weird to start with bishop b7 it does
those lines usually start with the moon
knight c6 exactly here usually as black
the more fashionable line and since it's
been fashionable since 2018 is to short
castle and go a very quick knight d7 f6
is what was featured in the world
championship match between fabi as we
said in magnus i was a very simple draw
actually a lot simpler than we were
expecting
in in that particular game so we'll
we'll see what ideas lev one comes up
with because fabi himself has played
this with white
famously destroying john christophe duda
in
one of our gct events exactly
the other big matchup of course is fabi
versus our newly minted 2700
sam savion uh
it is
a great accomplishment across the 2700
uh
just amazing yeah yeah and it just goes
to show uh how deep uh american chess is
that we have uh sam and
jeffrey
at that level as well uh i mean it's
embarrassment of riches as far as our
olympic teams are concerned because it's
like we could we could easily uh i mean
this is the two olympia this is the
biggest argument for bringing the
olympia to america we need two teams we
need two teams in the olympia of course
the whole country of the olympia gets
two or three teams depending on whether
it's even or odd pairings exactly uh but
they get at least two and we have an
amazing let's call it b team yes of
course we have our superstars levon
dominguez but we can make a b team of
shanklin sevi
[Laughter]
what kind of b team is that exactly
that's an 18 for others
let's just take a quick uh look at how
the players achieve this d4 by fabi
going into a nimzo indian
and i have the feeling that this was
alice lee's game
uh it was it was similar but not exactly
right because then they're the knights
in f3 no it was on
it was the queen c2 and bishop b2
remember yeah the knights on f3
was the knight on f3
okay yeah uh queen c7 and bishop a2 and
well right the knight was 92 because
they could go to c1 at some point
exactly that was where it got trapped
yeah that's right that's right very good
points yeah the double attack um
what's going on is this certainly the
the new fashion christian this is very
important to uh a note and that is
sam savion played this in the first
round against wesley so this exact same
position and in that game he decided to
go bishop to d6 and we remember the
complications after c takes d5 e takes
d5 queen to c2 bishop d2 long castle and
that crazy game that ensued probably the
game of the tournament with f3 h4 and
all that madness instead of that today
he decides to take on c3 take a much
more tame approach to the position much
more of a strategical wrinkle b takes e3
d takes c4 b takes c4
92 queen c7 bishop to a2 and this is
exactly
a very similar game to what we've seen
yesterday in the game that you were
mentioning between alice lee and
stavroula we see ideas potentially a4
get this bishop out to a3 or the move
that you were puzzled by uh back in your
hey they should be
that was uh the
strategical move we're going to have to
wait and see but it does seem like both
of the players are quite well prepared
uh let's see if sam seven anticipated
this from fabiano caruana because we
know fabi plays e4 d4 c4 he plays
everything pretty much so this one is
definitely going to be one to follow of
course we have still this position as we
were anticipating lanier decided to
castle short and that's going to invite
an attack by white on the king side h4
immediately played at some point you're
going to have to meet that with
potentially h6 when i get my pawn to h5
you cannot allow the pawn to go to h6
that's going to create too many
imbalances on that side
and i will
take it to you guys for the ladies
section what do we have there
exactly okay i'll jump over
uh
a little bit of slower play in both but
let's start with the irena crush against
a begging tokyo
ninja indian you know what the funny
thing about chess fashion is it's
unpredictable and it goes
in in a fury i remember there was a
period of maybe five to ten years i saw
zero names of indians no neonames theory
nothing new happened everybody was
playing knight f3 or move three queens
and queens
catalans queen's gambit declines knight
after d5 knight c3s
no nimzos right and you see this
tournament all nimbles everywhere every
single d4 is a nimzo that's crazy and in
the game of arena crush we could imagine
that arena has played knight's e3 she
likes the classical variations with
queen c2 which she doesn't doesn't play
for this particular game mixing it up
with knight f3 c5 and speaking of
fashion too there was a moment there
when gary kasparov really started
employing the roman nation variation in
his world championship matches and then
everybody played it and then everybody
forgot how to play it
i always felt that this was one of
irena's strengths as a chess player is
that she was very versatile when it
comes to
choosing nimzo indian lines right uh she
didn't stick only to queen c2 or only to
g3 or only to bishop d2 is she seems to
employ almost all of them right and it's
very annoying to prepare against because
you feel that every time you prepare
against arena you have to uh review your
entire nimso indian file and of course
you only have like two hours before the
game right you can't do it exactly
now
talking about fashion one of the one of
the variations
that black employed against this
particular line of the nimso indian we
called it the hubner variation hubner
defense i should say and myself
and a lot of my colleagues really
started to play this variation as black
capturing on c3 unprovoked in order to
get a very solid uh setup in the center
so we'll but uh begum didn't go for that
she went for quick castles
uh christian
breaking news guys we already have a
decisive advantage what what and the
game between wesley saw and jeffrey
shang they're playing rapid let's not
forget about that 25 minutes plus 10
second increments so they have to be
fast they have a fast
but we did not expect a decisive
advantage out of the gates in the first
five minutes of the round let's see what
happened d4 knight to f6 c4 g6 very
enterprising chess by wes uh by jeffrey
we know that he also plays the groomfire
so maybe he was trying to go into some
sort of grunfeld set up c6 bishop to g2
g5 this is some sort of a hybrid between
a slav structure as well as this
fianchetto that resembles a grunfeld c
takes d5 uh c takes d5 knight c3 bishop
to g7 knight to f3 castle knight to e5
this is a very intriguing idea very
intriguing setup delaying the short
castle we're going to see why this is
important because right now it puts
immediate pressure on black's pawn
structure bishop to f5 bishop to f4
knight to e4 and now queen to b3
attacking both the opponent b7 as well
as the pawn on d5 how are you going to
defend both well you don't have a way to
defend both you have to find a way to
create some sort of counter chances
let's see how uh jeffrey decided to try
for that knight to c6 24 minutes at this
point for jeffrey does seem he was still
within his theoretical knowledge and
there are a few games being played in
this particular position queen takes d5
but wesley out of the gates he's putting
a lot of pressure on his opponent he's
already a pawn up and he says okay show
me where's the compensation after queen
takes d5 and immediately
jeffrey erz with the move knight takes
d4 inexplicably allowing bishop takes e4
what is this
what are you going to do next you're
going to probably take on d5 i'm going
to take back not with the knight because
that allows bishop takes e4 bishop takes
of course you're going to be able to
give a check on c2 but then i just
simply go up you take this guy and now
i'm going to go g4 i'm not going to
allow you to go g5 i'm not going to
immediately take this knight because
after g5 black's position is uh quite
okay because you're going to have to
take on g5 i'm going to capture on e5 is
going to be an imbalance but it does
seem like black is uh coming out uh not
on top but quite okay a very balanced
position very balanced situation but
white does have this inter mezzo attack
not only attacking the bishop on f5 but
also creating a retreating space for the
bishop so whenever black is going to try
to go with the move g5 to destabilize
the bishop on f4 the defender of the
knight on e5 i'm just simply going to be
able to drop back to g3 keep the
position as it is and i'm looking at
this game right now knight xd4 is on the
board wesley is wondering what am i
missing
did i miss something in my preparation
why is he playing so fast and why did he
take on d4 allowing me to get pretty
much a decisive advantage at this point
unless you unless jeffrey had a blind
spot over the move g3 g4 and this sure
looks like
a winning position a materially winning
position
he's a specialist of this variation i
know that because i've played this
variation of knight c3 e5 against
jeffrey myself in a classical game he
actually replied with the move b6 in
that position right one of the many ways
to handle it so i know that he's looked
at this for years wow and i am shocked
that
look at wesley he's just
looking around and wondering what am i
missing right so sometimes you think to
yourself
did i forget something and then you look
at your opponent and
uh jeffrey is suddenly uh very telling
body posture by jeffrey he's hiding his
face exactly he realizes that bishop
takes c4 is just probably something he
missed exactly but what is strange and
there's no choice right right it's kind
of sad when you force your opponent to
make good moves there was no other move
but bishop takes c4
he's playing quickly
all right
and now the moment of truth here comes
g3 g4 g4 maybe not the only move either
but yeah i was speaking
at the engine normally i don't use it
but i was peeking at this line and it
said that knight d3 was also winning
which also makes sense
just stopping
c2 yeah
and
g4 but g4 crashes yeah no g4 so
it's so nice that's that that makes it
very simple yeah
uh 93 is also instinctive right right
very instinctive your knight is not on
pre anymore right nothing's stopping
nothing nothing it just doesn't take a
lot to calculate it yeah and we're just
uh from a material point of view we're
just thinking that
two pieces two minor pieces for rook
black doesn't even have a pawn white has
great development for his bishops as
well that's why we're just thinking that
the position is
winning
uh for uh
uh wesley in this case i think g3 g4
though just
jeffrey knows it because he left the
board yeah he cannot stay there he
cannot give any uh clues to his opponent
as to what he thinks about this position
he played fast so he's definitely
mimicking
his knowledge let's see he's bluffing
his lover
uh we didn't complete our trip around
the stage as there is the match between
alice lee and tatev uh we were just
gonna get to it when we got that
breaking alert about
um
a decisive advantage for wesley in the
the match-up we have uh the knight f3
talking about no nims no nimzo but
knight f3 queens gambit declined now
this move is a rather rare
guess e2 e3 everybody likes to get their
bishop on c1 develop to the g5 square
before locking it in but e3's
yeah it's not the kali system yet but
this whole queenside fianchetto is very
common these days and takes on d5 for
the night caught up with the players
after knight takes d5
i don't know i'm not very familiar with
such an early cd5 there's usually no
reason for white to release the tension
yeah in the center you can go back to b2
you can go knight d2 these are very
common moves bishop b2 knight d2 waiting
for right waiting for your opponent to
release the tension is more common like
you say
c4 takes d5
not so well known knight takes d5 and
well i am assuming
bishop b2 is alice's idea she wants to
bring her bishop to the long diagonal
putting some pressure on g7 we'll
certainly keep an eye out
for that game that'll be a long
strategical game exactly
in the other elimination uh games do you
have something for us
hopefully not a decisive advantage after
uh for
after four minutes sorry i was actually
looking at the championship bracket and
going through those games uh but did did
you guys look at this one no we haven't
no i had this one is quite uh
interesting so this is uh another well
we don't this is a catalan we have a
catalan on the board knight to f3 d5 and
now g3 we know the catalan sometimes
black plays move bishop to e7 d takes c4
immediately is uh an option as well but
he decided to go bishop to b4 bishop to
d2 and now bishop to b7 dropping up like
this now this bishop usually goes to f4
doesn't have the extra option
potentially of going b3 bishop to b2 if
you ever want to do so bishop to g2
castle castle knight bd7 queen to c2
c6 bishop to f4 b6 this game drew my
attention because it's quite similar
structurally uh to the game between
wesley so and jeffrey shong after c
takes d5 c takes d5 now we see the same
symmetrical structure of course we don't
have the bishop fianchetto on
g7 we have this bishop on e7 so it's a
bit different yes this bishop is
probably going to develop on this side
instead of this diagonal so let's see
where that took us rook to c1 bishop to
b7 bishop to c7 forcing the queen to
either go to e8 or c8 you don't want to
go to c8 because after that i'm just
simply going to sidestep with this queen
also you don't have a good way to
continue your development you would love
to put one of the rooks on c8 if you
take that square away with the queen
well it doesn't make a lot of sense so
he played the move queen to e8
queen to b3 knight to e4 knight to c3
offering the knight exchange of course
take
rook takes it and this is the position
after rook takes c3 i'm going to follow
it up with doubling up on the c file and
we see
raised down 15 minutes on the clock
right now
26 minutes 55 seconds for sam shankland
this is not surprising of course we know
sam is a territician but ray robson with
only nine minutes to go
well this is going to be a very very
difficult defense a very unpleasant
position to defend because you simply
don't have moves you're going to get
squeezed slowly but surely and white's
moves are very very easy i'm just going
to double up maybe even triple up on the
c file put my pieces in the center i
mean i don't like this situation for
black
one bit
one quick question for you though the
bishop on c7 miss seems misplaced so if
rey weres to continue knight f6 for
example yes rook c1 if you wanted knight
e4 uh rook has to go back and if i play
a move like f7 f6 it's like you would
like your bishop on c7 to be somewhere
else so that you could play rook c7
uh according to the engine this is
already almost oh boy
that is because once you put the queen
on the seventh round yeah then i'm going
to drop with the bishop and then invade
on c7 i'm ready to invade even if you
challenge me on the c flat so you need
the rook on ca to already be ready to
exchange one pair of rooks and then
double up and exchange the second pair
of rooks with the other rook to c8
you're not in that position i'm putting
immediate pressure on your pawn
structure it's in my opinion doesn't
look good now
with that being said right the computer
doesn't give white a huge advantage by
any means
not an objective let's say advantage
dominant advantage but a practical
advantage
that is the way i understand this
position how about you guys yeah i was
like
but i don't think it's overwhelming i
always felt that i played this with
white i got a nice position and then
immediately it was a draw
like you couldn't do anything
where's the advantage go black is very
solid right and the most difficult thing
is to find a square of penetration
because you can see that white has all
this control over the c file but what do
you do with it even invading on d8 is
difficult the moment you put a rook
there the bishop d8 kind of forces you
out rooks he had played but as christian
was saying
that's all theoretical yeah the clock is
a real problem here for ray his position
is also not so pleasant to play i mean i
think roo kc1 gets banged out without
too much of a thought because you cannot
go knight c5 i was about to say that
once again uh rook c8 seems wrong
because after the move rook c1 you're
inviting white to play a move like queen
a4 right and gift me the pawn on a7 i
don't like rook c no i don't either it
just doesn't feel uh right by the way
just on the before the move rook c8 i'd
like to go one more look because uh
strangely enough i've had
the dutch can you believe it i had the
dutch in my repertoire once uh 94 then
then i became a good player
that i understood yeah
g-5
a completely different approach again
i'm i'm trying to play against the silly
uh
and
one day maybe not immediately but one
day this f5 uh
it's a dutch defense where the open c
file definitely does favor white but
it's not all one goal however after the
move
rook ca which i don't like at all i
don't like that move at all then it's
very easy for white whites playing play
uh comes
rook c1 is very natural and already
queen a4 seems more or less like a
serious threat exactly a7 right and uh
putting pressure but what happened in
the wesley uh jeffrey zhang game knight
d3 wesley played 93 which we said it was
one of those
choices uh easy move to make as a human
being you're just covering up the d file
it's very solid right the knight of d3
is very solid you're also cutting off
the action this knight is never escaping
via seat well it does actually escape
via c2 like this but hey you had g5
remember i have a g4 as well that's
going to destabilize your uh defender
the bishop on f5 you're going to have to
move away i'm going to pick up the
knight that's going to be all she wrote
now one thing i don't understand and
something is wrong with jeffrey because
let's not forget yesterday
he got two completely losing positions
out of the opening he blitzed losing
positions out of the opening in the
armageddon and in the playoff against
fabiano caruana and fabi was bamboozled
about that whole situation like why is
he giving me this right now
jeffrey right now with a night to
prepare and a change he comes out he
blitzes another losing position out of
the opening
and right now he's getting punished
right for it yeah i can't argue with
that uh no argument either and it was it
was quite strange in that game with fabi
uh yesterday where i could say blitz his
way into this losing position it was
almost like
he said yeah i don't care like like i
don't care what the computer says i
don't care what you guys think
i i i can play this kind of chess and
something strange about that that was
very very peculiar indeed i just wanted
to turn quickly to the game of fabiano
versus sam savion because we do have a
number of moves and a very different
approach by sam versus the ladies
matchup where we we had seen
e6 uh
yeah rook d8 e6 e5
um in that previous game instead what
sam has done is said hey look you know
this knight on e2
you know what if i put my bishop on a6 i
can fight for the control of the c4
square this dia diagonal this this is a
very good idea let me do go in this
direction b7 b6
castles bishop a6 with a little bit of
annoying pin as mentioned rookie one get
out of the way rook
d8 by sam knight g3 and we can see from
white's point of view on a good day we
want to play bishop b2 e4 and use our
extra pawn in the center
knight c6
rook b1
that wasn't bishop b2
there's many ways to handle this
position right for me there's many ways
to handle this position i think one is
relatively logical uh we were told it's
a novelty but it's a very well known
idea rook b1 at some point you go a4
instead of putting the bishop on b2 the
bishop will probably go to a3 eventually
why does brazilian themselves
keep
uh the pawn on e3 you keep the pawn on
e3 for a while just to keep
this guy under
really good
protection
on a good day you force black to take on
d4 and like a great day you force black
to take on d4 almost never does black
take on d4 because you take back with
the c pawn helps the bishops uh for
white
so white plays slowly they go a4 bishop
a3 the queen moves somewhere sometimes
it's f3 sometimes it's e2 when the
bishop was not on a6 right
and then slowly one day you will play e4
right for me my approach is black is
like hey your advantage is the two
bishops
i really want to trade those light
squared bishops i'll fight for the
control of the c4 square i'm looking as
black
with the the maneuver knight a5 and
bishop c4 in mind i'm thinking
yeah i can play c5 takes
d4 when i got control of c4 and this is
one of the things where little details
about the position matter a great deal
at this level this maneuver 929 g3 is
done very specifically because brakes as
e5
lose some of their power because you do
not want to allow this knight on g3 to
jump to f5
but when the knight is on g3 it can't go
to e5 itself notice that when you play
the move knight a5 which is very normal
yeah in the other variations of the news
on f3 it immediately jumps to the e5
square covering c4 exactly so you can
see the little details of the position
little subtleties change the plans here
the move knight a5 is more appropriate
than the move e5 uh it's probably going
to be seen here on a later move rook aca
for example it's also a very logical
move in this position but i would not be
surprised that this move knight a5 comes
on the board pretty soon yeah i'm
well if rook b1 is a novelty it's uh
it's a little bit of a surprise because
like you say it it's normal in these
types of positions uh christian what do
you have i was uh looking through the
variations in uh this one actually
knight to a5 and this whole idea doesn't
work you have to get ready for it first
because once you play knight a5
uh i will play simply e4 and this is
another reason why the knight is already
on g3 i'm going to open up completely
change the character of the position i'm
going to open up this bishop ready to
jump to g5 put a lot of pressure on the
knight on f6 you don't have a defender
for this knight on f6 if you try to
double up on the d file well that's
going to take away one of the squares
from your knight so after bishop to g5
you're going to be in trouble after e4
it's a very awkward position for a black
and my attack is coming very swiftly
with a move bishop to g5 so you have to
get ready for that you have to
understand that once you release the
tension on this pawn on d4 with the move
knight to a5 which is very logical and
it's the way you usually want to play
take advantage of the light squares c4
specifically and potentially exchange as
you were mentioning yasser the light
square bishop that's your strategical
dream in this position leave me with
this bad bishop especially when the pawn
is still on e3 but unfortunately that
doesn't work so what you have to do is
play it slow
potentially h6 this has a clear plan
later on after you play e4 bishop to g5
no longer in the position
and a very interesting
and this might be something that uh the
neural network engines have found maybe
fabiano has done some preparation with
them a very interesting plan is actually
to go rook to b2
rook to b2 followed by f4
and then potentially rook to f2 and even
try to open up with f5 some crazy
maneuvers like this one and after d1
rook to f2
black has to wait
they cannot it does seem like white's
position and white's piece placement is
very awkward right but i do have this
very nice control in the center with
this pawn structure right c3 e3 you
cannot play e5 because that opens up the
f file you could potentially play five
but i have a feeling some sacrifices
with rook takes f6 are going to come on
the board for example if you try to do
something like this boom
rook takes f6
knight h5 thank you very much i can even
play slowly bishop to d2 rook to f1 you
don't have any breaks in the center
because i'm very very stable with this
uh spear pawn on a d4 and he
he played it
rook to c8 was played instantaneously
replied by fabiano caruana one hour and
34 minutes left on the clock rook to b2
i'm telling you guys
these players are preparing with some
engines that we don't even know about
i remember these old games of michael
boddinik where he played the a3 nimzo
indian the sameish
so you think okay that's really a bad
idea and his idea was that he would go
rook on a1 a2 and then the rook would
come all the way across the board to the
king's side
and he'd crush his opponent he'd go like
how did he do that that was like just
remarkable it's funny that you mentioned
that because
all these old ideas tend to make this
comeback maybe in a different manner
because you can see that the engines are
now recommending this rook b2 rook f2 in
this variation i myself looked at those
games that you were mentioning
yeah i was preparing as the grand master
and i played exactly that idea rook a2
looked to the other side and i won nice
and and and you can it's really
rewarding to study all of these old
games because all these ideas they make
a comeback exactly and you can see it
right now i love this movie rook b2 i
love the preparation fabiano is bringing
this is exactly what you want to see
from a player of this caliber absolutely
let's just jump into that game of wesley
so by the way because the players have
been playing lots and lots of moves when
we left it we left it at the point
knight d3 and we were all but just
saying the last rights for jeffrey let's
see how the game continued e5 bishop
takes e5 christian predicted as
predicted
too and now cam's this really nasty uh
reply g4 knight
b4 takes and at the end of all of this
we're going to have two knights
for
a rook and and i think we've just caught
up with the players after that
and he's just played the move king
king e3 i think g1 e3 yeah king e3 i
have six but i mean this is resigns
exactly i was about to say that uh i'd
love to throw in this move rook g one
check just to make sure that king
has to go into the corner and yeah it's
just uh
two
two knights versus uh a rook and
well
uh it will just be uh
uh i mean a material advantage by the
way after
if jeffrey loses it's just to why did
everybody win jeffrey yeah uh
when jeffrey loses this then uh he will
have one last chance
to stay in the tournament he will be in
a must-win situation in the second rapid
game which will be coming right up how
the tables turn in these events it's
incredible that jeffy was this close one
second one second a way of defeating
fabiano caruana in the champions exactly
and now he's just busted out of the
opening as wesley must win with white oh
man rescheduling his flight home i mean
like what that's crazy that is really
really crazy indeed uh let's just see
what else uh
uh the ray robson game we have been
critical of uh ray's play no but also
the time manager also the time
management has been terrible for ray uh
knight b8 to a6
and
well
what can i say other than it's a good
thing he's still in the game and uh
so maybe he's maybe a little position so
what happens here you go knights you
have to go knight c6 right to do
something i assume you want to tickle
the pawn on a7 and like you say you want
to do something promising
i don't want to
move my a7 pawn and lose the b6 pawn i
have only one defense queen to d7 but
sometimes one defense is that's all i
need right uh pretty good
and now if you don't have something
immediate yeah i'm gonna play bishop b7
next move on against queen a4 i can
still play bishop b7 precisely yeah uh
bishop be
uh bishop b7 so instead of that sam has
played the move e3
but boy this doesn't feel like he's
really that much better yeah that whole
knight b8 a6 did not get punished
in the way i more or less expected so
here we here we were we did not look at
the move knight b8 because we just kind
of uh assumed that uh white is doing
very good
uh
surprising i i mean one thing i might
have asked uh black to prove if you if
the intent was something like this
uh the knight on a6 is not a great
shakes but okay 95
knight a6
and actually the moon knight e5
surprises me a little bit because
it traps its own bishop right right like
if you go back before this yeah
96 is not a humongous threat i can
always move my bishop back right i'm
assuming he was afraid of knight c6
maybe
okay okay i mean something maybe to be
said just for you know just
play on
i mean i was wondering if i can get away
i do withdrawal yeah you have the nice
file i was thinking just play e3 play
direct chass
yes i understand my bishop on f4 might
get trapped but it's not getting trapped
right g5 is not
right and the idea is that i can now
play bishop f1 to b5
right exactly
and maybe this is a little
this is a lot more pressing actually
yeah because we're not essentially
we're not impressed with what sam has
achieved we kind of thought his position
uh offered more than it does i i don't
know that's played night season he's
played um
b3 bishop b7 e3 bishop b7 and then
bishop f1 e3 bishop b7 and bishop f1 on
the board
but
it's also about the clock right and
bishop takes e5 by rey after some
thought and he again he did start to uh
pick things up
a little bit well otherwise he loses on
time
queen b8
a very nice uh
move as ray is preparing the move rook
c8 in order to uh
trade off the activity but about one
what what where is sam's advantage here
no it's it it's anticipated
it's not in the position completely
dissipated as christian's saying yeah
it's not on the it's not on the board
it's just on the clock
yeah it's written away you can try to go
something along the lines of queen to a3
and try to invade on the long uh
a3f8 diagonal but we need three already
have to calculate because e5 is hanging
yes yes so we're going to have calculate
like queen a3 queen takes c5 maybe we
can put it on the board uh queen takes
a7 queen takes b2
b2 and then we invade rook to c7 how is
that where are you hiding your bishop
that's the problem maybe the bishop is
next it can go to a a8 right
or ca or c8 yes
yeah and this is the question whether i
have any sort of tricks immediate tricks
if i don't have any media tricks then
your position is perfectly fine exactly
wow um okay well we we are about second
life yeah after all yeah
okay a quick look also at the ladies
elimination this was a strange game it
wasn't
an open sicilian this is the katarina
was white against
and
but it transposed into a kind of an open
sicilian where whites queen
on a2 tucked away on the a2 square makes
a
a a strange impression usually these
positions i i'm used to seeing a white
queen for example on the f2 square or
the e2 square anywhere about eight a2 is
not is not usual and the doubling of the
rooks on the d file
as both players a little bit perplexed
and challenged it's a
it's not a clear cut
position for either player to play it
feels like both sides
have their pluses white does have a good
structure in the sense that b2 and c2
are okay e4 is defended
you can argue a6 as a weakness but on
the other hand black's very active
exactly has the open files has the
potential breaks in the center which is
huge d5 and g5 are both available
yeah i i'm a sicilian player so i like
playing these positions with black right
i have the suspicion this is close to
equal absolutely i would call it
dynamic equality as well let's jump to
the championship section
and again catch up with oops this is not
ray's
army this is not
you
uh rook you said the rook came to b2
right it went oh yes rook to b2 and that
pawn is back to f4
rock to b2 yes and then he played knight
a5 then he sorry h6 first h6 and f4 and
i think we had a very similar position
in the analysis
exactly we went at a5 and
we expect rook f2 i would at least
expect rook f2 absolutely
but we see that fabiano is just blitzing
his moves and now until finally yes he's
taking his first thing exactly
where to put the rook if you want to go
to d2 then probably that's going to be
attacked via c4 by the knight coming to
c4 you don't want that so it does feel
like the natural choice at this point is
to swing the rook all the way to f you
also don't play f4 to play rogue d2
right
but you could have played your play
for a reason of uh
making a big
big uh
wind-up on the king's side rook f2 and
preparing bishop b2 and so forth so how
does this continue let's say i go rook
f2 yes i guess
bit bishop c4
knights looks
reasonable i don't want to trade that no
i definitely don't want to trade that
bishop to b1 yeah and then
and now and now what and now
uh
do i have any
okay can i miss
this combubalate your your
your pieces somewhat sure let's go queen
f3 i feel like you're actually helping
me well this was my question can i
sacrifice my queen on c1 and i think it
i i think
it's not much of a sacrifice right i
mean no i get a rook a bishop and
another bishop no no no you play rook
africa
yeah
the bishop
fortunately and finally the rook has uh
reached
his natural spot on f1 very nicely done
uh
yeah okay a little speculative queen
sacrifice they're going on but we can
see what fabby is doing is student body
right like just bring all of the forces
over to the king site and land a big
blow
against uh
sam's where is the big blow gonna come
through like for example let's say i go
bishop c4 bishop b1 and i i pass i'm
just gonna ask you like a beautiful move
like b5 yeah beautiful movement secure
the
your domination of the c4 square sure
okay and here it comes boom boom boom
boom right so you do go e4 and this was
my question because the moment you go e4
now i have a target on
the d4 square right i can start with the
move knight b3 maybe i can go cd4
immediately
okay cd4 immediately
looks right somehow i don't feel like i
should play e4 right it doesn't feel
that i play f4 and e4 you get them both
in right if you get both of them in and
you don't have any problems that's great
but d4 is so weak i can start playing
knight b3 here right well my dream of
course is that i want going to go e5
queen c2 for some weaknesses on the uh
king side
uh okay here your green v6 guess what b5
actually came in
great movie awesome great move yasser
very handy but hold on i mean here's the
big blow i wan i've i
i i'm producing after all is said and
done but i can still take on d4 oh no
please tell me you can't take on d4 you
can i can because of 92 checks 92 check
and nobody's defending the knight on e2
at the end let's show that variation now
it takes like a second
yeah
one takes seven
two
you take with the knight no no but i
think with the queen that's the thing no
no if you take with the queen i also
have an eight and a half years three
three pieces yeah this is the this is
the most principle is
bishop d4 yeah but bishop before bishop
d1 i'm not you're not happy i'm not
unhappy gotcha
and it's not if i think with the queen
knight takes d4 takes takes it does feel
very speculative yeah take with the
queen take with the bishop you have to
take with the knight
the rooks or
oh yeah
and now if you go bishop e5 then you
take only absolutely give me the tactics
muzzle rush time bishop e5 c2 nice
knight takes d4 is a it was a blow
because unfortunately it's not like my
queen has a great
choice of squares either and of course
we're going down these lines and this is
very speculative it's very far from the
position what we're trying to do is
trying to understand the position yeah
what are the dynamics what can i get
away with can i play e4 what will be the
black counter chances so even though
this line will never happen in a million
years you're starting to wonder how
exactly both players are poising for the
future what are the breaks that we want
what are the tactics in the position do
they work do they not work and this is
more or less how we learn about these
situations because i've never seen rook
a2 rook f2 in this structure no and i'm
wondering what what squares is it
undefending what squares can i take
advantage of and i'm still not entirely
clear about white's plan because e4
leaves d4 undefended and the moment you
play f5 i play e5 and laugh
right this is terrible you don't play f5
in this position ever no i don't want to
play f5 unless i have some knight h5
business business very very quickly very
concrete yeah exactly uh again i i mean
i feel like i i want to play e4 e5 d5
the other thing is this knight is really
a great defender right uh
does it
make sense to just get
traded off
in this case f and rook f3 is an idea
but also f5 f6
now f5 f6 right a lot more sense yeah
yeah
now they're knight on a5 it's not
blockaded and the knight on 85 is off
off uh
off sides
i can see the danger for both sides here
but what scares me is the
speed with which fabi played rook a2 to
b2 and f4
i've got a feeling that this is part of
some really deep preparation that maybe
you know you always have this feeling
that you know your opponent has prepared
something not necessarily for you right
but you're the one who is being
victimized you walk right into i mean
speaking of the speaking of favi it
reminded me of a game that he played
against jeffrey chong in one of the us
championships okay if i played d4 and
it just happened that
jeffrey had learned this uh neo tarash
with uh taking on d5 quickly with the
knight right in the queen's gambit yes
um
and he had never played it before ever
oh but
it just happened that a couple of weeks
before the tournament favi
woke up one day and said why should i
just study why don't i just study this
and you spend a week studying that with
rooster
until they basically came up with like a
million different strong ideas he just
played one of them jeffrey got crushed i
mean just absolutely
straight out of preparation but it
wasn't for him it was general prep
exactly
good work pays off what do you have
first christian well reminding me of
those type of situations where it just
feels like you fell into a trap this is
exactly what i'm seeing in this game
this big battle between aronian and
dominguez because we see dominguez
playing uh the petrov we know that he's
not generally a petrov player so who
knows whether he understands the nuances
of the patrol office yet in his career
and he played the move d5 knight to g5 i
remember i saw not only fabiano but also
lev uh
starting this type of very aggressive
attacks on the king side with the move
knight to g5 and after a 25 minute thing
by linear with black pieces he played
the move h6 now this obviously looks
like the most natural response right you
want this knight out from g5 what
black's idea in this type of positions
uh is is to try to destabilize the
bishop on d3 this is the most aggressive
piece in white's position up to this
point so the way you do that is you go
c5 followed by c4 the problem is if the
knight on a g5 is unchallenged when i
play the move uh c5 white is simply
going to respond with the move c4 and if
you try to take i'm going to simply be
able to take back with the bishop and
you don't have the idea and the option
of capturing the knight on a g5 this is
going to be tremendous pressure for
white on the square f7 which leads to
devastating consequences so you cannot
do that you cannot play c5 first you
have to start with h6 put some pressure
build up this pressure against the
knight on g5 the problem with the move
h6 is obviously whenever you move uh
pawns in front of your castle you're
creating hooks in the position so what i
can do is just simply retreat my knight
at some point follow it with f3 g4 and
then g5 if i manage to get there and you
don't do much on the queen side you
don't create a lot of pressure on the
queen side then you're just going to get
checkmate
as black so let's see what happened
after h6 immediately lev responded with
f3 he is still within his preparation
can you take no absolutely not you don't
want to do this because after knight to
d7 i'm going to go g4 and now we see
this idea of f3 g4 clearing up the
second rank i'm going to follow it up
with the move queen to h2 and checkmate
is going to follow very swiftly so you
cannot do that of course you he did not
take on g5 you played the move c5 now
again this uh the problem with c4 is
that i can simply take take on d2 and
then take on g5 so you have to find a
different way to build up your attack
and
right now it seems like finally lev is
thinking
about his options
g4 is one of them allowing the move uh b
c4 and then just simply dropping back
with the bishops on e2 now you have to
be very careful whenever you're playing
this move c4 because you're also giving
up white a strategical trump big
strategical trump and that is the square
d4 i'm going to be able to plant the
bishop there and that's going to open up
a lot of new and exciting possibilities
for my attack this is going to be a very
very exciting matchup right now it seems
like lev is ready to take some chances
he knows what he's doing and let's see
if uh lanier is going to be able to fend
off the attack and it's interesting
because linear dominguez yes he's not a
petrov player but he actually plays this
variation with the white side one of the
very shocking games that i saw in this
particular variation was linear
dominguez perez with the white pieces
against wesley so tata steel 2014. if
you haven't seen that game it's a
masterpiece wesley resigned in 21 moves
which is not something he does very
often and he resigned because he was
made in three okay so you can understand
that dominguez knows these positions
inside and out great attacker great
defender
this is going to be a wild one i love
seeing this kind of clashes lavon deep
in thought not afraid of taking risks
but
lanier plays this very well me too i
love these uh battle of ideas these
games where the players are castled on
opposite flanks
and it it's all about who gets their
firstest with the mostest uh getting
there first is uh
wesley so as uh when we left it it was
two knights versus a rook and things
have not gotten better for jeffrey
whatsoever in fact wesley's got a past
f-pawn and he's pushing it pushing it
for all it's worth it's already now on
the f6 square
and it's about to go to the f7 square
once this pawn gets to f7 there will be
a threat of f8 equals queen and knight
g6 check forking the king and the rook
this was over before it started yeah
this is unfortunate it's very
uncharacteristic of jeffrey right uh to
just straight up loose even in the games
that he had a losing position against
fabiano yesterday he was fighting he was
fighting but this one is not a fight
this is just a clear material
disadvantage where if you resigned when
the two knights were already in the
center that that's perfectly acceptable
resignation exactly and uh we do have
rook f1 on the board again this was this
is the first
uh
rapid chess game that jeffrey will be
fighting for his life
uh in the next game he will likely have
to win on demand with the white pieces
and we're just expecting
f7 knight g5
uh
yeah f7 looks killer right exactly
something also to be said for knight g5
too
i mean because it's not knight g5
blunders the oh
that is the one movement i'm dreaming
you know what i'm dreaming yeah g6 jack
and f7 check that don't blunder might
pass down blunder you're pushing them
yeah f7
get it out the board and i think that
will be all she wrote
in so f7 king to g7
knight to g5 let's just put it on the
board so f7 knight
king to g7 to sidestep the threat of
knight g6 jack
f7 king g7 knight to g5 now with a new
uh
all-purpose threat of knight e6 check
and then followed by queen so we assume
rook drops back to f6 king goes up
push
knight goes to
check the king and after takes
you can push but i get there first so
let's try to go back yep yep yep guys
why are we trying it i mean the mf7 i
think black resizes we have so many
other games to look at
guy's dead and everybody's like oh how
do we kick him man it's not completely
over okay okay you see what is this i go
king of faye
king where here sure yeah and i check
check i understand that king g7 and
you take my ring but how is
how is that endgame because up at night
the night is very bad against uh the
martian age run yeah i know but it's
still a night
i understand that yeah it's completely
lost
it should be no no no no no it should be
that's my understanding of just you
right you're pissed off
win win that game win that game yeah we
win no i i get it it's okay you're
winning but show me
oh really
uh
okay
let's go king is seven
and let's go
you wanna go that way okay you allow me
to go king f6
okay i'm not gonna go king of six you're
gonna
yeah that was the question i was
wondering if your intent was just and
i'm going to go h4 right right right and
so
i don't know why you're pushing your
phones but whatever it's kind of nice
you don't need to right you got at some
point here you're going to have to
calculate and they're just going to take
us another fight but no because i've got
the knight as a tempo whenever i
whenever we're in opposition i get to
move that's fine but you don't win this
right you don't win this with a tempo
king d7 king e7 i just stay i'm just
waiting for you
he's just hanging yeah
yeah stop moving your paws
just take your pawn on h4 first and then
go back
put my knight on h4 first take the stage
a6 okay now we're talking
asics
what am i am i like asleep here what's
going on oh you're gonna put your king
b6 is a draw
b6 is a drop but b takes a6 is money
okay b6 is a draw because i go i guess
king king
don't i checkmate you with my king and
knight no you're not in time what get
out of here why don't i checkmate you
well because i'm giving up my h-pawn
whenever you go king
wait how is it
so king d7
and you made me with king c8 i think you
can see it is made right
though this version is made i think yeah
i think you have to give up the pawn
first with h3 no no you cannot do that
and then you're lost completely thank
you then even this is losing why are we
looking at this there are so many
interesting games going on let me
refresh the board sorry everybody we
just got off on a tangent
it's not that easy it's super easy guys
it's super easy man by the way we do
have king e4 on the board there was no
uh
after f7 jeffrey did not play king g7 he
invited the ending that you've been
looking at uh christian with knight g6
fa check
and um
first came the move knight g5 knight to
g5 we have rook f5 and king e4 on the
board and rook f1
played already
played very quickly in fact yes i'm
wondering no but now you can go with
just 96. i think 96 is the easiest and
the idea is on an h3 i actually go no no
just about knight e6 knight edgar six
yeah h3 is kind of clever because if you
go f8 i don't i can't catch the ball
they just go the knight f3 is
right
that's on the board all right we're just
expecting a handshake we've been
expecting a handshake for a while
there's a there's a couple of games that
are still interesting yes here is the
hand great i'm glad we didn't have to
show that an extra night an opponent
game is winning
allow me to demonstrate why two extra
pieces is a win
all right okay uh let's take a look at
the ana game because remember some of
these players are fighting for survival
today uh we are on the first of two
rapid games 25 plus 10 to determine who
stays in their elimination bracket let's
take a look at the game between anna
satonski and star roulette
uh both players are down to two minutes
so let's jump straight into it it's a
very complex position let's count the
pieces
it's
well there's somehow the bishop landed
on d8 and
i don't move bishop d.a by the way
bishop d8 this feels like it was a
king's indian except it wasn't
doesn't it it definitely definitely
feels like a king
so what is th what is the situation
black is up two pawns right now
although white will regain b4 pretty
soon right then black will be up one
pawn but
what's going on in the position
bishop b5 play the queen's hanging
normally speaking here it's all about
breaking through with bishop takes h3
but somehow the bishop is on the wrong
diagonal right
that being said
black looks very sketchy on the
diagonals
but somehow solid i don't see how white
creates too many threats
i'm wondering doesn't that move not
encourage uh knight f6 there
is it not references
six you still have one square for the
queen it seems like but
a7
oh
or even queen f7 check in that case too
yeah okay on both ways wow oops that
clears the cup maybe that's why you
should play
queen g6 first i think queen g6 to cover
f7 f7 let me just show everybody what i
have just missed by the way knight f6
looks really attractive you would you
attack the rook with a discovered attack
against the queen but then when you see
the move rook f7 checked it's like i
stopped
whoops
my bad so you go queen g6 i think i
think you i don't think there's another
move but then i go rook c1 so my idea is
to try to you don't take the bit the
pawn on b4 with the bishop i thought
this was the idea too
rude okay just like we know i like six
which is similar but different
because there's no knight f6 right
that's a strange move actually you put
the queen on the desired square of the
knight queen f6 we have sex played okay
so again what what is the time uh
situation remember they're below two
minutes both a minute 22 for anna a
minute 50 for starula they're
in very severe time pressure both of
them are time pressure addict right and
they only get an extra uh 10 seconds per
move okay and the move as suggested c1
makes a lot more sense here c1
covering a lot of squares on the open
file now knight c5 now something that
i've noticed for stavroula yeah she's
fearless even when she has almost no
time yeah if she calculates she's just i
believe in my move and that's it because
knight c5 i would be terrified to play
that rook c5 is an idea a rookie seven
sign idea right that you're opening the
seventh rank exactly but if if she
doesn't see a problem she just plays it
so you have to start with the rook that
she said one rook takes g7 i'm assuming
she wants to recapture with the king and
then you hide on it yeah
to get out of what appears to be uh lots
of uh nasty threats
on this diagonal you your your king
escapes a queen g8 check i need to
involve that bishop on a5 into the
attack somehow but
yeah i think she missed a beat by not
taking on b4 g7 with the queen jesus
whoa wow without a thought too by the
way yes that's what
you just came back quickly queen takes
g7 bishop takes b4 as you said yeah uh
christian you want to involve everybody
send everybody an invitation to the
party bishop takes and d6
it's definitely white for choice here
right kingpin g7 was key whoa
bishop c6 oh tactics
queen c6 rook takes b4 is the idea but
trade off
that nasty bishop on b4 excuse me but
does queen take c5 work
boo queen c5 does work
takes and you're made it
and because the bishop owns she misses
she missed it she missed it queen c5 was
winning dc5 bishop c5 check queen e7
only move no knight d6 no but 96 i take
and i take on c6 that's three pieces
three pieces that's way too much your
king is also exposed and she's taking
the advantage of queen c4 taking but now
it's winning for black right because out
of nowhere queen a7
check guys queen a7 is coming oh my
goodness oh my goodness that was what
the whole setup was all about queen a7
who knew that
you can go queen a3 right now queen a3
defends both the rook and a7
you have to make that
with the queen on g7 but but
force very easy for this but the end
game is
oh no the head shake queen c4 was a
blunder she had a queen and that that is
a mate that is a mate that we see
already that's a very nice
the puzzle rush that usually gets me
like three points on a puzzle rush i'm
always annoyed but i can pre-move all of
it so it doesn't take too much time off
the talk yeah
what a crazy game that was near the end
let's go back let's show this queen c5
move that anna missed that was
absolutely key missing this chance
change the game
huge swing there here we saw the move
bishop takes b4 bishop c6 this was all
black's combination right when she had
played the move queen g7 she had
foreseen queen a7 what she had missed
was the move that christians said can
you take on c5 sharp christian yeah not
just the way he dresses but the tactics
as well
look at this one
and the whole point is this bishop
covers this diagonal so that after any
captures
bishop captures and suddenly this bishop
is hanging after a queen e7 bishop takes
and rook takes e6 it does actually rook
takes e6 uh
yes this is completely winning yes sorry
but if you do go knight to d6 i was
looking through the engine right now it
seems like it's not that clear okay
really yeah white is still much better
but it's not that clear because you
don't have actually this rook takes c6
that we were mentioning because once
again ah this check comes on the board
followed by queen to a1 this is going to
be a check made right so what you have
to do is actually after take the bishop
take c6 you have to take the rook
specifically to cover a7 right now you
don't have queen to a7 but i do have
queen to b7 still the position is not as
clear because
i have a lot of you do have a lot of
pieces but i do have some checks and you
really have a weak king on g1 right of
course if you start taking my pawn on e5
maybe you can even lose one of your
pieces and take all the pawns and still
be in a better situation
it would have been uh a battle right but
after queen to c4 that was just a double
um question a double question mark and
this is just completely game over after
rook takes before it just finishes the
match
with the sacrifice wow what a roller
coaster game and it's one last chance
for international master many time us
women's champion anna satonski she will
need to win with the black pieces on
demand against avrula and
who would have thought the second seed
of the event is already in danger of
being knocked out from the tournament
especially after winning a clean
strategical game on her round one
against tatev she's now lost four games
in a row
whoa she has to bounce back and win to
stay in the elimination bracket what a
situation guys what else do we have in
our rapid games i think that's good
let's go to race race yeah yeah we need
to go there immediately i was very
impressed and they repeating this is a
draw as we kind of expected more or less
but in the catharina nem sova riyan yan
game it feels like a very one-sided
match you can just count the pawns it's
two extra pawns for black the 15 year
old youngster and rush actually not sure
she's 14 or 15 one of those and very
very strong play here and she's off two
pawns completely winning position it's
great yeah nothing to say that is uh in
indeed the case i don't exactly
see how katja managed to
lose how is the time situation 16
seconds for katarina and 45
for riyang rook to be one chest check
very quickly played all right not a lot
of choices here
king f2
but we do have arbiters we have got
about the time yeah where's our
where's our arbiters
arbiters
arbiters arbiters mr bird mr bird mr
vert
calling chris bird
what
what happens if she like leaves if she
loses if she gets checkmated in one ah
there we go yeah yeah yeah yeah she
finally made it away your clock is down
all right but the position was
completely hopeless anyway it's not like
you changed anything three wins in the
elimination bracket wow
that means that already three people are
in their next game which will start at 3
30 central time in a must-win situation
or they are knocked out of the
tournament right that is huge absolutely
and let's go back to the championship
bracket and this game uh
between lavon aronian and lanier
dominguez great fight
going on
after the move c5 did lavon go into a
bit of a tank i think he didn't go into
a huge tank he was 20 minutes
but considering the time controller
that's pretty big he's gone for the move
bishop b5 a little bit
from
weird yeah yeah well he's sidestepping
uh the move c5 c4 he said he's basically
saying okay my bishop really isn't that
great if it goes if i go g4 and bishop
f5 maybe it's not something i want to do
g4 c4 the bishop goes back he was
worried that maybe the bishop became a
would become a little bit too passive so
he played bishop b5
after a 20-minute thing but it's a
strange move not only because i have the
reply bishop d7 which is very normal
sensible but even against the move rook
f8 in this position which is awkward
but it does ask the question well you're
busy why did you put your issues in yeah
and
and i think c4 is a very serious threat
uh so much so that it would probably
encourage me at this point to just like
say okay okay but i did get your
your you i did get you to slide your
rook back to f8 sometimes i know it's a
great achievement something which i
never know as an achievement or not
because right your rook is defending f7
exactly yeah exactly um intriguing a
game but as we get prepared for our
first break before we go uh on our break
we just want to say that we've got some
very nice uh roll-up vinyl chess boards
i have in front of me
with the red and blue we'll see it uh
that's pretty i think we're going to get
some of the players to sign these boards
especially before the eliminated players
we better get our boards all signed here
folks and uh they're available at q
boutique q boutique stl.com you have the
website there on screen uh please join
us we have all kinds of cool merchandise
for you guys it is really cool it's a
great store i'm wearing a tie from there
right now they have all kinds of stuff i
encourage you to go and support the club
cubical.com and
guys we will be back right now but it
feels that
we're taking our third or fourth break
because we already have so many great
results we're gonna take our first break
we've uh got done with the first part of
the elimination bracket we're gonna come
back into the champions bracket
follow-up at 3 30. we'll be starting
with the second game of the elimination
bracket don't go anywhere we'll be right
back
[Music]
founded in 1839 the university of
missouri is steeped in tradition the
recently founded mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the university of
missouri and the st louis chess club
collegiate chess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of excellence
mizzou has always strived for the best
mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
discovery and excellence to the
chessboard
[Music]
where's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry him so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us and you guys
know i can't play this right
st lou is always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back in the third day of the
american cup we have two brackets now
the champions bracket and the
elimination bracket where players are
fighting for survival remember in the
elimination bracket they are playing
today as four players will be saying
bye-bye to the tournament and let's see
the results so far of the day they are
playing 25 plus 10 games in which we had
a crazy start arasatonsky lost with the
white pieces in an absolute melee
against i am international master
stavroula sola kiru who now only needs a
draw with the white pieces to remain
alive in this tournament meanwhile also
in the women's section we had katarina
nem sova not finding her stride here in
this event losing with the white pieces
against bed game in the classical and
now losing with the white pieces against
riyan in the first match here in the
elimination bracket she is now
absolutely forced to try to play for a
win with black or she will be returning
home meanwhile in the open section an
absolute shocker as jeffrey sharm simply
forgot his theory mixed up his openings
who knows what happened but he basically
gifted a full point to wesley so now
jeffrey has to win with the white piece
as a tough tall order but i'm sure that
he will try and in the other game sam
shanklin tried with the white pieces had
a humongous time advantage but was
inaccurate and did not put enough
pressure on ray robson to cause serious
problems that game ended in a draw
meanwhile bracketology let's take a look
in the open section this is the
champions bracket we currently have
underway irene and dominguez are playing
a sharp petrov while sevien and karwana
are fighting it off in a fascinating
nimzo indian with very very cool
strategical ideas in uh the women's
section
we have sorry this is the elimination
section as you're seeing uh robson is
going to be facing shankland they have
split the point as we said and we as we
said jeffrey is in an absolute must win
game against wesley meanwhile in the
women's section it is irena crush that
cruise through ring yang yan and uh
tokyo that through namsa they're
fighting each other right now in a ninja
indian meanwhile alice lee and tatif
abrahamian in their classical first game
they are fighting it off in some kind of
weird queen's gambit decline how to put
a name on it but still interesting game
and as we mentioned this is the
elimination bracket where two of these
ladies will be going home tonight anna
zatonski losing four in a row it could
go back to her match with tata yesterday
where she lost three after being in pole
position and she's such a brilliant
player how many times has she won the
u.s women's champion how many times has
she played board one for the u.s women's
olympics she's been a 25 30 player right
it just shows you the talent that is
cropping up all throughout america
exactly christian jump right in uh with
the championship bracket absolutely uh i
was looking of course at this game
between aronian and dominguez because i
spent most of my time trying to explain
how this bishop on d3 is probably one of
the most dangerous pieces for white and
you want to preserve is as it is at
least try to coax back to attack it with
the move c4 so that it creates this
weakness uh on the square d4 instead of
that left played the move bishop b5
which puzzled all of us rook to f8 was
an option it doesn't look very natural
of course seems to me that bishop to d7
is a must played move and he played the
move bishop to d7 bishop takes d7 queen
takes d7 and once again without the
light square bishops now i'm starting to
attack uh the knight on g5 because after
let's say you play a move such as king
to b1 maybe i can even consider taking
taking and then knight to h7
that's uh on tap as well i can get ready
for it maybe with the move queen to f5
maybe queen to b5 as well i have a lot
of options even rook to d8 with the idea
to displace this bishop from e3 with the
move d4 is an option as well instead of
that
he decided to go knight to h3 and now we
have the move roof to d8 a very
interesting idea that i was browsing
through this position was d4 c takes d4
and now just play the move c4 with the
strategical idea to get this knight to
d5 and that's going to create immense
pressure on your castle on the queen
side because i'm threatening immediately
the move c3 after that so for example if
you try to go g4 i go knight to d5 your
attack is not really coming uh my way
because for example if you go g5 boom
c3 arrives on the board of course if you
if you take on c3 opening up your king
like this you're gonna get checkmated in
three moves bishop to a3 queen to b5
queen to b2 and that is all she wrote so
you cannot allow the move c3 the problem
is if you do play c3 yourself with white
that creates once again a hook in the
position i have a couple of options one
of them is to just simply take on e3
follow it up with a bishop takes h4 or
even bishop to g5 winning the queen and
that's going to give black the advantage
this is the variation i'm talking about
bishop to g5 pinning the queen also it's
a double attack you're not going to be
able to do both you cannot take on e8
because that's pinned you have to take
on g5 and of course we know this is game
over right this is game over of course
he's not going to allow that to happen
because he did not play this move d4
followed by c for a very difficult
practical decision rook to d8 looks much
more natural you're just
putting your rooks on the central files
and at some point you're going to
threaten this move d4 you're trying to
create pressure in the center let's see
what happens if white goes g4 boom
d4 immediately take and now queen to d5
taking advantage of the fact that with a
move g4 you actually weakened the pawn
f3 i'm going to
create a double attack queen to a2 you
cannot allow me to take on a2 because
that's just going to allow my queen to
invade next to the king create mating
attracts
mating threats and that's going to be a
huge problem and you're not going to be
able to answer it you have to go king to
b1 and now after queen to f3 we can
easily see that black is the one in
control i just simply have the better
placement of my pieces i have more
activity you don't have an attack this
knight if you're going to try to attack
it with g5 going to go to e4 it's all
she wrote but let's see how lev is going
to try to respond to all of this because
of uh the variations you're pointing out
i suspect the move king b1 just to cover
that a2 pawn
and to get well to sidestep some of
those nasty
[ __ ] ideas that you were mentioning
with queen d5 as well as d4 c4 knight d5
king b1
okay and just
leaving
g4 for uh for the moment it just doesn't
feel like you have your attack pending
on this side because as soon as you play
g4 i have these ideas of targeting the
pawn on f3 so i can anticipate that with
a move such as queen to c6 for example i
like that movie queen
yeah it's a very cagey move because of
course i have d4 also opening up the
rook now uh i'm uh watching this
potential opening open file with the
rook in front and that's might create
some problems against the queen on d2 so
after queen to c6 it just feels like
black has an easier play and it doesn't
seem like white has done much on the
king side in the last few moves thank
you christian and we have a board full
of pieces in the game between arena
crush
and begum as uh
isolated queen pawn and i love these
games these isolated queen pond
positions for both sides actually
black has this beautiful knight on e4 as
a
compensation for the pawn
and
white has a super solid uh
basically one of the best kinds of very
positions that you could want
against the isolated pawn knight is on
f3 knight will come to f4 and the rook
is on the c file now having said all of
that the strategy the strategic weakness
of the isolated queen pond is the fact
that it's isolated and in this
particular case uh nobody's attacking it
so this gives black the possibility of
just playing moves quiet little moves
like queen e7 bishop d7 rook d8 which
eventually carry a very big punch you
always have to be
mindful of ideas of knight takes f2 and
queen takes e3
in
the position
how do you like the position i i mean it
it's strategically it's wonderful
uh kind of position but which side i
should have said do you prefer well
it comes to the specifics of the
position in my opinion oh i have played
the isolator well i think every
grandmaster
has played the isolated pawn with both
both sides right right uh it's just part
of your upbringing you gotta you gotta
learn them exactly you gotta learn them
but in this particular position i think
i i'd rather prefer white by a very
significant margin and the reason is
that i feel this knight on f6 is wrong
it's wrong yeah because the e4 knight is
great night yes it's a great night
beauty but you can only have one knight
on e4 you can't have two knights on e4
right this knight on f6 is not going
anywhere right and i feel that
in positions where i go knight f4 yes
you don't you cannot take on f4 you just
no i don't want to give up this
beautiful bishop that is for sure you're
just too weak on the dark squares and if
i can start pressuring your pawn on d5
in the next couple of moves which i
normally can't right normally you have
to blockade this pawn before you even
consider doing that but if i don't have
to establish any anything on d4 i can
directly attack it with knight f4 bishop
b1 and start asking questions
then
i would like white okay
interesting how about you uh christian
and your experience of isolated queen
pawns first of all do you like playing
against them or you like having them i
love playing against them i used to like
playing with the isolated pawn when i
was younger and a bit more aggressive
and my opponents were also a bit weaker
so they didn't know how to defend of
course but
nowadays unfortunately i do like to play
against the isolated pawn as you were
mentioning yasser in this position it
all comes down to who will find the
correct plan and i really like what
alejandro was mentioning this idea of
knight to f4 and targeting the pawn on
d5 knight to f4 bishop to b1 attacking
this pawn on d5 of course
black is going to probably respond with
a defense of that pawn on d5 bishop to
uh d7 bishop to c6 but are you going to
assign a defensive role to your pieces
with the isolated pawn that's probably
not
going to spell the right things and
unfortunately i don't really see a very
easy plan for black to try to create any
sort of attack against the king because
we know this is what you're going to try
to do and this knight on f4 beautifully
controls this uh diagonal you almost
never want to give up the bishop for the
pawn because despite yeah this this is
just looking ugly right with this
monster uh unchallenged on the long
diagonal controlling the square e5 this
knight is going to jump to e5 i'm going
to be able to go f2 to f3 to attack and
challenge the knight on e4
it just doesn't seem like black species
are going anywhere in this position and
the engine actually agrees uh 1.5
advantage for white you cannot take on
f4 but of course
are you going to go knight to f4 or are
you going to be tempted to place that
knight in the center that's another
question that irena will have to answer
in the coming minutes
it's all about who chooses the right
plan at this point if irena goes
straight and plays the move such as
knight to d4 well it does look beautiful
tonight but where is it going after that
right now i'm going to go bishop to d7
rook to d8 i have the easier moves now
if you go knight to f4 if you find the
right plan then you're probably as white
going to have the easier move i do like
fighting this position i feel it's the
same problem this knight on d4 as we
were talking about the night on e4
because again how many beautiful knights
can you have one one
superfluous knight
was mentioning these terms superfluous
knights yeah i always liked uh the
hippopotamus game uh michael tall so
michael tall is playing against the
isolated queen pawnee as those like
knight on f2
knight is hitting f7 there's a knight on
h5 hitting g7 there's a bishop hitting
the h6 pawn
and he has to make a combination he's
going to sacrifice at night on f7 and
knight on g7 a bishop on h6
and he thinks for 40 minutes but during
this 40-minute thing he's thinking about
a poem where a hippopotamus is stuck in
the swamp
how do you get it out how do you get how
do you get this hippopotamus out of the
swamp i mean you need a crane and this
goes on in his mind and he looks up and
his clock is down to a few minutes and
then the frenzy starts sacrificing
nights and he said the next day i had
the pleasure of reading in the
the pravda sports pages that michael
tall after a well-calculated combination
that's what a brilliant game in the
soviet championship and all he was
thinking about was a stupid hippopotamus
and how do you get the hippopotamus out
of the swamp and irina did find the move
nightwing nightly that's the key key
move there for her she's so particularly
strong in this type of positions if i
had to think
one player that i do not want to face in
this kind of positions from the women's
section irena is so strong every time
she gets this isolated pawn she's done
it over and over again to win so many
u.s women's championships she gets this
positionally annoying positions right
where your opponent has to actually find
ideas find ways but you already have a
long-term
uh idea you're forcing your opponent to
play precisely and it's difficult for
them to do so and irina has won so many
games against the iqp yeah there are
certain positions that uh players just
have
an instinct for right and the isolated
queen pawn happens to be uh
for arena
bishop dc knight f4 as we were
mentioning on the board just wanted to
check in with lavonne
lavonne by the way did not play uh
king b1 and just
you know
tucking his king in to protect the pawn
on a2 no he said
it's about the tempe i've got to bring
my knight on h3 to f4 which we all
understand as it is prepping g4 and g5
the knight on h3 was definitely
um
not well placed so i like that move
except for all of these tactics that uh
christian had been mentioning before
there's so many ideas d4 is an idea
queen a force an idea bishop d6 as an
idea exactly
bishop d6
um opens up the rook so that i can't
take
e3
but christian back over to you in that
fabi uh game did fabby get to play his
rook to f2 that is such a fascinating
game and we were looking during the
break at some of the lines let's see
what happened i think we left it some uh
somewhere along uh this move knight to
a5 came on the board and we saw the move
e4 played uh almost instantaneously by
fabiano take on d4 take on d4 queen to
d7 trying to create some pressure on
this pawn on d4 and this is the big
moment right now for white white has to
play the move e5 if he wants to preserve
his initiative now the problem is the
lines that you're starting to calculate
after this move e5 at least to my eyes
was rook to c1 right this was the move
that i i had to understand what happens
after this move rook takes c1 queen
takes c1 queen to d4 of course you would
love to play the move queen to e3
unfortunately that just loses the rook
on b2 undefended unprotected and you're
going to resign the game so you're going
to have to go king to h1 only move
knight to g4 is very threatening looks
very threatening you're going to go
knight to f2 and here uh h3 was one of
the first moves that we considered
unfortunately after knight to f2 well
that's almost a family fork that's uh
20.4 uh knight to d3 and that just wins
the game of course so knight to f2
knight to d3 critical idea and in this
position instead of f uh h3 white has
one defense with the move knight to e4
strengthening the control over the
square f2 and if you try to go bishop to
b7
now you have to calculate this move rook
to d2 knight to f2 rook takes f2 bishop
takes e4 and finally the move of the
round
rook to f1 of course you have to find
this move
i'm joking you don't have to find this
move rook to f1 your position is still
better but black does have some
compensation if you do find this move
rook to f1 with the idea to challenge uh
black species blacks major pieces on the
d5 with the move rook to d1 well you're
almost completely winning as white
fabiano has a lot to calculate after
this challenging move queen to d7 e5
if it comes on the board then sam is
going to be looking for alternatives to
queen to d4 or rook to c1 and probably
the movie is going to be knight to h7
unfortunately for black it seems like
after d5 this pawn sacrifice
this is looking good because i closed up
the d file
you set up all your forces
with the idea to blast open
get the queen to d4 exchange the queens
get to an end game have a beautiful
structure and uh destroy my attack
unfortunately with this move t5 a
typical sacrifice i'm going to clog this
d file with the pawn on d5 and that's
going to work in my favor because this
bishop on b1 tremendous attacker this
rook is going to come to f2 this knight
is going to come to h5 followed by the
queen coming into the attack
something has to give at this point and
is not going to uh spell very good
things for a black right now if he finds
this move e5 followed by the pawn
sacrifice with d5 fabiano is in a long
thing right now actually
what
happened one minute 22 seconds and after
queen to d7 he's already 1 minute 22
minutes 1 hour 22 minutes and right now
he only has 55 minutes left on the clock
what were you mentioning we were
mentioning that after e5 knight to d5
knight h7 yeah uh okay the
i'm thinking that we want to play queen
g4 and now g5 knight to h5 you can start
with knight to h5 uh-huh and either way
and white is just fast it is very fast
it's knight on a5 is sore thumb yeah
it's i mean look the best move in the
position right now according to the
engines is g6 nobody plays g6 no i have
no but nobody plays g6 that's the best
you see bishop d5 and you stop
calculating you don't want to open up
the position of the king with g takes h5
i'm going to go bishop to f3 but also
after g6
check this move out i like this this is
very fine
[Laughter]
i want to check maybe yeah
forget about knights forget about pieces
i want to check mate bishop take my h6
queen takes h5 take on h6 yeah this one
is completely busted i'm going to be
able to invade first of all also this
rook potentially or this rook is going
to go f to f3 g3 who knows i'm going to
be able to bring all my forces into the
attack maybe i don't even need them
because this one is all she wrote but i
do like completely losing i do like this
pawn sacrifice you mentioned very much
e5 knight h5 this is like a dream
consecutive
takes and i've seen the [ __ ]
knight to c4 has to be played right uh
knight you you cannot take the pawn on
d5 because that's just going to open up
so many possibilities for us i just
wanted to say bishop b1 was too
sophisticated for me i was thinking f5
and you know like like knight age seven
all right
rook of two winning
you see knight d5 but unfortunately it
looks like a good night but where is
your attack on my opponent or not yeah
that's the issue right non-existence i
guess that's the issue and you in order
to get that attack going you have to go
with the knight to c3
and first for all of these reasons
yes i think my instinct as a jail would
be to put the knight on e8 instead of h7
it makes a lot of sense because
different jesus
makes a lot of sense and the same thing
comes on the board e5
yeah look fabiano we know analyzed this
type of product yeah he's seen this
sacrifice maybe not in this particular
line but in other lines he has seen he
knows the sacrifice right now he's just
trying to understand the nuances the
tactical nuances in my opinion after
rook takes c1 that seems to be at least
from a human's perspective the critical
move after e5 yeah you want to be able
to see 94 by the way uh put that move uh
rook c1 and queen d4 on the board
because i wanted to share with the
audience by the way the engine hates
this rook c1 exactly this is the only
thing i would calculate
during the break queen takes d4 we we
had a funny moment between uh christian
and i we went knight g494
and in this whole variation christian
bishop
rook d2 knight f2 rook takes bishop
takes rook f1
it's important to note that the rook on
f1 is not
the king's rook it went rook b1 rook v2
to d2 to f2 to f1 and we really like
that pathway
it was very very nice
and it was very nice that it's he did
not play the movie e5 he played
very long thing
by the way on those very old classical
sets uh the king's knight
and the king's rook have a stamp on them
uh a red stamp just on the on the very
tops of the pieces because a lot of the
uh notation was descriptive and they
would say king's rook
to
queen eight and you have that extra
stamp to give you the idea that it's
your king's night that's going to g5 and
not the queen's night important stuff
important stuff i actually i actually
learned chess on descriptive notation oh
yeah
i'm a viewer
don't worry guys
it took you years to overcome uh your
handicap uh learning descriptiveness
description notification too it's just a
handicap i mean it's just terrible it's
a terrible system yeah no one came up
with it
exactly all right let's jump i just
wanted to mention that in the game of
alice lee tatev tatev as black
is more than equalized she's just kind
of went past the equal and i think she's
starting you start thinking for an
advantage here exactly i i start
thinking that
tata is going to start winding up
something on the on the king side
maybe for example if the queen we're
just to retreat let's just put something
there's not another move right yeah you
start to immediately thinking about as
jennifer shahadi would say a rover bring
your rook up and over rook to d5 rook to
g5 you start looking a bishop takes h3
and saying hey
my turn to attack let's go
well it's not even like my turn what
does white's counterplay
true
[Laughter]
i don't know exactly how alice misplayed
it to give tata such an easy play yeah
it's not that we're saying that alice's
position is really that bad it's
probably still quite holdable probably
black's a little bit better
but it's easier but it's easier to play
it's practically really easy to play for
black and really hard to play for white
the plus side for alice she has doubled
the time of her opponent she has an hour
and two minutes left for tatif time
pressure addict 33 minutes uh
for this is really not an acceptable
amount of time to have been used on 18
moves
always uh just like ray robson never
cured herself of these uh time troubles
see i see it in a lot of her games yeah
tata from ana satonski the ruler from
this tournament oh you've got another
one did you
i got don't worry don't worry i mean
there's a line there's a line christian
already filled out his application
i mean
we're getting the whole the whole gang
together exactly it's terrible it's
terrible watching us as a coach right
but this one looks pretty simple uh rook
d5 is of course an idea but you could
also go queen e5 queen g5 the main thing
not queen effect between c5 queen g5
to g5 yeah and one of the things that
worries me about this position for tatif
is that she has so many options
yeah sometimes you fall in love with
your position you're just looking at it
looking looking and looking so nice
sometimes you even overestimate your
position and you think you see one line
it's equal one line it's equal and you
want to force the position and sometimes
that doesn't work so this is the
psychological dangers of a position like
this where black has pretty much
everything but it's not crashing through
you still have to be patient you still
have to play logical moves
it's hard to really assess one against
another just choose one and go for it
exactly in this case i would definitely
be playing rook
to d5
oh this is stylistic right like you're
looking at rook d5 i'm more of a comp
player i i really like prophylactic
thinking and just keeping your options
open keeping my options open i like
knight d5
night david yeah because the way i see
it is that you really want to play
knight c3 this is your next developing
move absolutely no question about it but
maybe if i play 9593 queen e5 you'll
have you'll have a second thought about
that right that is an uncomfortable pin
exactly unless there's a way that i
could maybe turn the tables yeah
exploited against you but i understand
what you're saying that
that you look at all of the options and
also
you're trying to guess
what your opponent wants to do and let
me stymie you yeah i don't want you
doing what you like to do tigran
petrosian was the great master as was
anatoly karpov
at stopping you from implementing your
idea so 95
uh there's more to think of and that's
unfortunate that's unfortunate
you just don't want to give up
we have a couple of tweets remember you
can join the conversation the
conversation here with us send us the
tweets at
the american cup or hashtag u.s chess
champs we're checking both of them
international master costa kavutski who
is running the recaps and is running our
twitter will be having his eye out on
the best questions and we're told we
have not won but two let's go
let it i see
when did yasser play his last official
tournament game i think it was barcelona
2012 13 14 i'm not sure what was in
barcelona there was the maestro
the
i played with kevin spraggett and uh
uh
just kevin sprague you you didn't know
this is
i think it was that uh look it up it
will be in your
database 2014 let's go with that yeah
and the grand master from argentina who
no
get out of here
you're terrible
uh 20 20 2014 i think so take a look
and i think on the twitter those hashtag
thursday vibes but it's friday so good
morning st dave good morning st louis
good morning sailors guys we got we do
have another one we do have another
tweet uh dennis dennis boris grand
master dennis burrows it's good to see a
whole new generation showing great chess
when are we going to see the likes of
sevi and nationally robson enjoying the
singing field cup field
well
we did no didn't we didn't play the sing
film i don't think he did actually not
in the sixth field
jeffrey played this thing phil and it
was daryush actually yes uh dariush and
jeffrey played the single field but i
think savion is b-lining
knocking on the door right absolutely uh
nishnik is an interesting one nishnick
is extremely high rated i think he's
above 26.90 right now wow yeah 26.95
from being told
knocking on the door
there used to be a timer being a
grandmaster it was a pretty cool thing
in st louis now being 26.50 everybody's
hey
it's incredible the amount of talent
that we have here i don't know when
they're gonna get invited in the sing
field cup
i remember us going to lunch with susan
pogar and her son tom and as we left the
restaurant a van pulled up and everybody
got out and it turned out to be
the slough students and we were all
going to the chess club
and as we're walking tom looks around
and he says
i'm the only non-grand master everybody
else who's a jet's grandmaster he's like
a
grand masters galore that's why we got
to keep our eye out on the 40 player
blitz tournament that we mentioned
earlier christian get in your your
what you're showing us uh in the game
between levon and
uh yeah so i i've been trying to
understand how any of the sides can
improve their position make any sort of
progress uh after knight to f4 bishop to
d6 was played and finally this
prophylactic move king to b1 potentially
defending the queen side specifically
this pawn on a2 which likely will be
attacked now queen to a4 to me it makes
a very artificial impression i don't
like this queen to a4 i just played the
move king to b1 why would you go queen
to a4 of course you have an immediate
threat and that is to take on e3 for
example if i just play a move such as
rook to e1 you take on e3 you i take
back on e3 with anything and then you're
going to capture the knight on f4 with a
tremendous
advantage for black but of course i
don't have to do that
i can just simply defend my position
with the move g3 not only that it
defends the knight on f4 but also i have
ideas of queen to f2 queen to g2 later
on improving my position a little bit
slowly slowly and it seems like maybe
the best move for black would be queen
to c6 d4 is very difficult to calculate
it doesn't seem practical this trend
with the move queen to a4 doesn't seem
practical so to me to my eyes queen to
c6 looks much more compact much easier
to play from black's perspective of
course
would you like to take on d5 absolutely
not you don't have a defender on the
bishop on e3 and it's very simple to
calculate that after knight takes d5
queen takes d5 we exchange everything
and i take a piece of three piece on e3
so how do you prepare this idea of
knight d5
maybe with rook to e1 now it seems like
knight d5 is finally a threat but is it
and this is the question that black will
probably have to uh ask himself and
answer because you can immediately start
your own attack on the queen side with
the move b5 this is uh the whole concept
in the position you want to open up the
position and try to checkmate the white
king can you take on d5 well it does
look like you can right because right
now if you take i take back and then it
seems like i have a quite a nice
position right it seems like i'm a pawn
up and you don't have a good way to make
use of the pin on the e file
but
after queen to d5 i have this beautiful
move
queen to b6 now the question is what if
i just simply go queen to f5
well i can go bishop to g3 rook takes d8
and now queen takes d8 and we see that
not only that i'm uh keeping my uh
attack on the bishop on e3 but also i'm
creating this attack on d1 so for
example if you go rook to e2 i have
queen to d1 coming down the board with
devastating consequences this is game
over so if he sees this idea of b5 and
then shielding the queen with queen to
b6 well it seems to me that black is in
a great situation right now and he's the
only one that has a clear way of
improving his position that is queen c6
b5 b4 open up
the position and try to checkmate the
white king
thank you for that uh christian uh
i i i love those subtleties i really
really do
yeah yeah that's just crazy but
one lady is not being settled
tata is making a
naked aggression i would say when is she
subtle uh she just went for it she just
played the move rook d5 that's an
absolute post up rook up and over
she's eyeballing uh the
white king
rook g5 bishop takes h3 is on a black's
agenda i like what you were saying
keeping your options open being flexible
knight d5 none of that business
i would plant the flag rook d5 and alice
is under pressure all right this is
one thing i love about alice least play
okay fast practical very fast very
practical look she's this is clearly not
theory but she's only spent 30 minutes
in this game
wow and she's under severe attack rook
d5 came on the board and she calmly
plays rook d1 like let's go like let's
go
and what is the situation after rook g5
uh i presume king f1 or king h1 to
sidestep yeah bishop takes h3 is
necessary absolutely i let's go with
king h1 just to put a move in okay and
uh and then well naked aggression
yeah but this is something let's go
let's have some fun and like i take i'm
not sure how much fun you're gonna have
here i don't know i'll get i'll get in
the spike check i'm going to go down
the blaze of glory oh i want to see
where your spike check is i got king h2
okay king h2
queen
f5 green gift me the ball i'll try not
to gift you that particular
all right let's say i go rook f1 i think
your idea would be queen g6 or what is
your idea
okay knight g
i was hoping for bishop f1 by the way i
just had to i did yes of course i i had
a different idea for you that in case
you had bishop f1 on your agenda i had
knight g4 on mine
and the idea was i was going to
checkmate you on g1 and or h5 that's not
very nice of you no it's not bad
it wasn't but you had rook effort
yeah
okay
all dressed up it's it's a nice party
but isn't it g6 or you mentioned queen
g6 yeah but queen g6 actually has no
threat rook g2 wasn't
yeah he feels a little slow right i can
go knight a3 just to move a knight out
of the first rank uh-huh so that i have
the ability to play rogue g1
against queen g5 yeah rook h6 ah you
tricked me that way yes yes yes
i had a dual idea of rook h6 and queen
g5 again naked aggression depression
yeah uh but
hey uh i unfortunately i
i i was in the same generation of larry
christensen that guy
that guy was sacrificing
left right and center i mean he came at
you with bare fists it was terrible so
you had to end up
calculating these sacrifices because
larry
put him on the board and said
i'm coming after you with with
everything i've got so rook g5 by the
way tatev has not like immediately
answered this is the big problem with
with tata of you know she has had an
idea but i mean she played rook g rook
d5 with purpose but having said a say b
say b let's go
rook g5
um
that's the misuse mismanagement of the
clock by the way talking about one
player
who kept the flexibility for everything
was fabi that we did not go for those d5
and f5 type of variations that we were
looking at after takes we were looking
at after queen d7
e5 we thought that was the most
purposeful move rook d2 was fabby's
choice and after bishop b3 he just
calmly captured and played bishop b2
prepping d5 and bishop takes f6 queen a4
is on the board we've caught up with the
players
and why does winding winding winding
is he ready for d5
or not well it is playable in this
particular position i don't know if it
really brings any kind of advantage
though exactly i don't want to know i
wanted to keep the queens in fact that
was now right right
let's take a look at queen bee one i
think this is queen boy one one of the
ideas right there
knight b3 this is the big issue right
you attack the knight sorry attack the
rook here's the point uh
black can not allow this d5 bishop takes
f6 idea so he's got to be
lickety-split with his answer which is
knight b3 and then i'm assuming
i assume d3 knight takes d4
and now we're here another question is
is this pin down the d file actually
dangerous for example if i play rook
edie one exactly i'm not threatening the
knight immediately but
how do you get out of it exactly exactly
um
not so easy right not so easy not so
easy this might be very unpleasant
unless tactically i'm missing something
but i don't think so i hate walking into
these uh pins right
wow uh well
these are the types of variations that
the players are going to be calculating
and what are the
times of the two players alejandro uh in
the game between five karana who has 50
minutes and sam savion who has 34 not
exactly even but
not too bad i think for sam considering
how surprised he was out of the opening
absolutely this rookie one rook b2
uh that fabi brought a very innovative
idea and uh i liked it uh
over to you uh christian what do you
have for us guys what i'm worried about
in this position for uh tatev and you
guys are pointing out is that she only
has 22 minutes on the clock and so many
options in fact rook takes d1 seems to
be the best move in the position
do we think tatev is going to play rook
takes no
no
she will think for another five minutes
and play rook g5 right
g5 has to be played i mean it's such an
obvious move but unfortunately it does
seem like after king to h1
she will speak she will spend another
five minutes and then sacrifice on h3
also sacrificing on h3 is not an easy
decision because
you're burning your bridges the bishop
is coming to f1 if you allow me to get
the bishop on g2 and create this uh
cocoon for the king followed by rook to
g1 well this is going to be all she
wrote so how does this go it does seem
like queen e6 bishop to f1 queen to f5
we got
defending the f3 square you don't want
to go bishop to g2 because after rook
takes g2 actually
sorry not rook to g3 of course rook
takes g2 queen to f3 yeah it does seem
like black is breaking through you're
just simply going to take the rook pawn
up a devastating attack this is
completely all she wrote so we're not
going to get this right queen to e2 does
seem to make a lot of sense you cannot
defend that f3 square with knight to d2
because f2 is going to fall so queen to
e2 and now
this is the critical moment this is the
critical moment it seems like white has
defended
but you have this very beautiful move
knight to g4 not easy to see from afar
and i'm worried that she's going to
spend all her time on this bishop takes
h3 try to make it work and not spot this
move knight to g4 knight to g4 i still
go rook to d2 and now knight to e5
you're not even giving a checkmate but
rather you're improving the position
slowly now of course
bishop to g2 is a problem because of
knight f3 you have to go f4 e takes f3
and now we get this position which is a
mess i'm going to go queen to d1 queen
to f2 i have a lot of options black also
has a lot of options and i'm afraid that
it's just actually going to be a slower
game it's going to develop into a slower
game later on you don't have clear paths
of checkmating the white king in this
position
this is going to go down to the wire and
what i like from alice lee is that she
plays super quick just like super quick
just like that plays rook d1 makes her
decisions so fast that shows once again
a lot of experience and
let's see what lanier did
finally the pawn sacrifice that we were
looking at
many many moves ago finally came on the
board queen to b5 king to b1 oh sorry
excuse me
queen to uh king to b1 queen to b5 came
on the board we were considering queen
to c6 it felt like the more natural
choice followed by b5 and b4 try to open
the position like that he decided to go
with queen to b5
queen to c1 immediately played by
leveroni and very similar to what uh
alice lee is doing he's playing his move
very quickly as well and immediately
came d4 24 minutes for dominguez 59
minutes for lev aronian take on d4 c4 we
have this position on the board
c3 potentially coming on the board it
does seem like black
knight d5 burning some bridges right now
yeah with the spawn sacrifice but
i love it it seems to be working
wow what a great concept what was
fascinating for me was in that whole
analysis that christian was making of
the tatav game seemed like some
swashbuckling tactics and then he goes
and then it's going to calm down to some
technical game where you know the clock
is going to be the decisi deciding
factor i was like what want
you went through this great sword fight
all the way to this um uh chess clock
being the site of decisive factor and
it's right it's a mismanagement diamonds
management is very big and sometimes you
need some self-awareness of where you
stand like for example if you spend
another five minutes of static in this
position and you go down to 13 and you
start thinking rook g5 clear just take
on d1 right take on d1 develop your
bishop develop the other rook make a
draw
and go home yeah play with white in the
the the following the following game
right exactly i'm afraid that she's
going to burn her clock to like 13
minutes play rook g5 be in an extremely
complex position and blunt or something
agreed by the way if you would go back
uh christian for a moment to that game
of linear because i just wanted to say
that
i'm really not interested in the chess
engines uh version but for me
if you would play the move g4 for a
moment yes i will
take on f4 put a knight on d5 and i'm
thinking to myself whether i'm right or
wrong like i've just got this beautiful
knight i'm going to play c4 c3 why do
you have a great compensation you want
to go knight to c3 exactly and rook e2
hey man i i actually have more than
enough compensation here
i just love this looks amazing for a
while right exactly why i can't move
exactly and uh
for those people who play the king's
indian they often make these types of
sacrifices where they get a dark squared
yeah yeah
right right right yeah and here we're
seeing it i usually get these types of
positions from a karo khan not from a
petrov that's right yeah and we get this
knight on d5 also it doesn't feel like
these are the positions aronian enjoys
playing right i mean you
guys enjoy this position
who's enjoying this
no but this this feels like something
went really wrong i love the sacrifice i
do too and it's one of those positions
where even if the engine says 0.00 right
that's what i mean there's no grand
master that will take white no grand
master ever will take
exactly you just sort of say i'm not
interested in the computer's valuation i
just know that as a human player
uh you're stan you're you're staring at
us yes
pawn grabber
and i'm a pawn grubber but i do
appreciate dynamic uh
play and the knight on d5 the rook on e2
the pawn on c4 by the way can really be
an incredibly disruptive
uh pawn for for black i like the attack
yes sir yes sarah is a palm grover but
first he is a grand man there you go i
mean let's let's start with that fabby's
uh game uh
some some moves have been played it was
that no no he has not played after queen
oh i'm sorry
i thought oh look at these moves
beautiful queen b1 i was going to praise
you get out of here
no they're still on queen a4 uh favi
deciding whether he wants to really i
don't think there's any choice between
anything else it's d5 immediately or
queen b1 i don't really see anything
else i don't like the variations with
the queen on e2 because when the knight
comes to b3 attacks by rook and then
takes on d4 it comes with it with the
tempo
so these are
lesser versions for white exactly that's
why i wanted to put the queen on b1 so
it's really those options right well
there is just this one moment though
okay it is queenie to knight b3 i do
have this move e5
which
i'm thinking is going to provoke you to
go knight to e8
i don't know if you want to play knight
dd5 and deal with
what rook is still hanging excuse me
sorry what rook the rook on d2
i was thinking if you take the rook i
take the knight i was also wondering if
i could start with knight d4
knight david iv yeah
my gosh that threw me backwards um
okay can we just see it rook takes i'm
assuming it takes pawn tags
you have to go queen g4 uh yes and i
assume g6
and rook e6 might get made my gun made
it but i'm not sure yeah the queen d1
will uh is good enough they're good
enough right enough also i could just
take on b2
correct it's in not such a clear
position huh
gosh it looks threatening but there are
counter threats too right rogue d1 is
coming i'm clear
maybe it's just very good for black
wow uh
cool stuff and he has decided he has
made a choice he decided to play the
move d5 immediately allowing the queen
trade but he thought this moves knight
b3 were just too annoying to deal with
exactly immediately allows the trait of
queen so let's take a look at a couple
of variations d5 most logical is to take
the queen when you can exactly and as
black i would not
want to hesitate too long bishop takes
f6 queen g4 check might appear and that
will be no no no no so queen takes and
it also asks the question or this
particular moment which rook you want to
take with i'm assuming he's going to do
this dust drop the pawn right
knight takes pause
no tactics no puzzle rush tactics no
knight takes no e7 uh let's just show it
that d takes e6 for example rook takes
d2 rook takes d2 knight takes d2 e7
almost wins but
unfortunately i was so close so close
all right so uh
that means
in that case i have to actually stick
with the capture with the
rook on the d file rook takes d2 i am
still
threatening a very nasty bishop takes f
6.
so in case of this in case yes right and
bishop takes f6 right but if i keep my
structure like i
pass with something clever i'm not
really sure just
let's make a move let's make a move just
because i want to see the threats
let's go a6 it's a dumb move i'm sure
that sure we can find b5 useful before
let's try maybe maybe
okay i want to mess up your uh structure
and i want to go knight h5 so this is
your idea you want to go night age
that's yeah that's the idea for sure i
like this what if i go then instead
something like king f8
in order to play king e7 right that's
cool
okay so i definitely like messing up
your structure as before and let's see
what happens when your king does manage
to make it all the way to e7
isn't there a way of blowing up the
position against i i am curious right
but i i think maybe you should uh
probably start with taking on e6
exchange the rooks on the d file and try
to invade on on the seventh rank without
knight h5 without knight h keep the king
that's a good idea right the king on f8
i like that take on e6 is very
instructive take on e6 you force you
must
force yeah and even here maybe even also
e7 check was interesting
to throw in seven and nine f5 no but
this one also looks very good right this
still looks like play on one goal for
white white and we already have the
moves queen takes d1 immediately favi
took with the d-rook which is what we
were expecting exactly and yeah i'm
warming up to the fact that bishop f6 is
a serious threat king f8 by the way i
love that e7 chat chat it's got a knight
five
excitement uh so let's try to solve so
what if you take on d5 yeah this has to
be there why don't you just take on d5
right okay so let's take on absolutely
stopped ourselves though we didn't find
a really good answer we have
rook d6 maybe
and rook d5 rook takes d5 and again
knight takes f6 as the inter meso move
but i'm actually not even going to throw
it in i think it's stronger to just take
directly on the bottom you have a
password half a passer because you still
can't prevent knight f6 next move and
there is this nasty rook e8 checker uh
it feels like this is just too good this
is too good for you right back for a
second so instead of rook d6 let's go
rook c6
c6
sorry knight h5 first rook drops back to
c6
um
boy i don't i don't like this at all for
you uh christian or in this case i don't
like it at all for sam savion so i would
take that that's
so bad right it's like you're getting
close to creating some sort of a mating
yeah that's what i'm afraid as well i
gotta go check on f5
h7 and f5 cafe is coming correct
or
rookie yeah
am i in time though because i do go
knight to c4 right now so okay
you have rookie seven that's a big
rookie seven is an issue right because
you can both play 95 knight takes f6 or
95 i could just consider to take on a7
that is the problem yeah you just take
on a seven and you're a corner whatever
and the training is
so i haven't learned
i'm sorry osmosis
you just soak it right up so
i see that
after a long think
13 minutes i called exactly 13 minutes
oh wow has played the move rook g5 yeah
yeah yeah she did she did and right now
it seems like uh alice lee is pondering
her options king to f1 or king to h1 you
have to get the king off the g file
that's
the first step king to h1 seems to be
the right one just so that you keep that
f1 square for the bishop and we see
tatev she's not getting away from the
board she's trying to calculate right
now because she knows she's under
tremendous time pressure and look at her
she goes king again
let me explain what tatev is doing wrong
here okay please when you play the move
rook g5 it's a relatively easy move to
play rogue g5 indeed and then white has
a bunch of choices king f1 king h2 and
king h1 exactly play rook g5 immediately
and then let your opponent make a
decision and then you can calculate
exactly based on what she's done right
then spend your time exactly so what do
you do now
after king how do you sacrifice i mean
if i was startups coach i'd say give a
check king ji won queen
and then repeat the position no you you
give a check i go to h1
oh he doesn't want to draw anymore no no
i cannot go to g1 because you take on h3
that's what i'm saying so you have to go
to h1 and how do you continue how do you
build up your attack because if you
don't find something well i'm going to
go knight d2 or knight a3 knight c4 get
my rookie involved in play and all your
pieces are on the king's side drifted
yeah but nothing is happening on the
king's side if you don't find the right
sacrifice right i think it's time to
develop your pieces
i mean i think at some point you need to
develop your pieces right
get get get more of the guys over there
right it is how chess works you want to
have everybody play everybody be part of
the party super unhappy with the fact
that she has 12 minutes left all right
alejandra how how how long will she
think for for this one uh she'll go
under 10 she'll then she'll realize oh
my god i'm under 10 and she'll make them
panic move panic move yes h6 h5 bishop
is six something but that's the problem
with the position she can play any move
yeah uh big problem that's a big problem
by the way as we'll we keep our eye on
that i just wanted to turn once again to
our all olympia
olympian matchup between lavon and
lanier
levon for me played a move i never even
considered i don't know if you guys if i
give you the position after blacks move
c5 c4
and i say give me your three favorite
moves i think one of them might include
the move rook
uh
uh h1 to e1
uh
another one might include the move d4 d5
to say okay i don't want you to have a
knight on d4
would your radar pick up the move g3
no
g3 what is g3 doing what it is
help me
help me ah so when the row comes to e2
it doesn't it doesn't attack them i
don't care
maybe rook to h2 to defend the second
rank like that like like favi
it it makes no sense i don't get this
move g3 i'm good i'm glad i'm glad i i
just thought my gosh i just uh but it's
a move
and lanier has 16 minutes ah that's the
other point you've got to make and
it's not a terrible movement
it holds the position it's a terrible
move oh it is it's a horrendous move
wow it's almost loose
it almost loses on the spot wow wow okay
where we're going what are we going the
only thing
that's considered g3 no but the only
thing you need to understand right now
guys is that i'm going to put the kibosh
on you right with
then i'm going to exchange this bishop
for the knight
and then i'm going to plant the knight
on d5 right and after that i can do
whatever i want right once you play the
move b3 i'm going to have a lot of time
to go a5 a4 open up the a file and check
well allowing the move c3 definitely
looks very suspicious we're going to
have to let you don't have any counter
play you don't have any counter play i
love the nearest position let's let him
think we have uh we have to take a bit
of a break because the moment that we
come back
elimination
no not only time travel elimination
bracket starts exactly so we're gonna
come back right before 3 30 when our uh
games start we'll take a small break
check this out with the engines and
we'll return in a few minutes guys
[Music]
we're back in st louis overboard chess
is back as well how does it feel for
everything to be coming back to normal
yeah i feel it feels really good i also
had the same similar feeling that this
is the first time that i
come to play again and
things feel
very close to what they were uh before
the pandemic
and
and it's great i hope that we can
continue on this trend and that uh
this is
a good start of the chess season in
saint louis oh i'm just really happy to
be back playing over the board chess
it's been pretty much two and a half
years of playing online bullets bullet
rapid and
starting to play over the board just
almost feels foreign to me you know
after playing all these woods games
online
yeah i'm really happy to be back in st
louis i mean i'm happy that things are
getting back more to normal you know we
don't have any mask requirements anymore
um yeah it just feels pretty normal and
i'm looking forward to playing yeah it's
going to be different right no masks
finally
just seeing each other seeing
expressions everybody has to come back
to poker face
because every like gesture is very
visible when you don't have the mask but
i look forward to it i think we are all
excited to to play this tournament this
format is like absolutely fabulous
obviously
it's much nicer to be in person and
especially to be playing in such a
prestigious tournament with all the best
players in the world well i'm very
excited you know first for quite some
time we're going to have some audience
next to us watching the games
and
i think we're all ready to put up a show
yeah it's pretty exciting yeah it's been
a while since i played the tournament
and this is the second time i play in
saint louis
and it seems like a really cool event so
i'm glad to be invited i am very happy
actually first time when i played here i
had to wear a mask so this time is going
to be my first time without wearing a
mask and it's gonna be totally normal
and i'm very excited about that
yeah it's great i mean i was not playing
chess for a couple of years and even
after the us championship i didn't
really play for a while
um until i played the spring classic
recently so it's nice to kind of play
two tournaments within
less than six months apart
so hopefully i'll be in you know a
little bit better of a groove going to
this tournament and uh yeah hopefully it
will show my play but mostly it's just
fun to be
be back on the board i'm thrilled to be
playing my first saint louis event of
2022 obviously you know i can't remember
the last time i've played a tournament
in the u.s that wasn't in st louis i
mean this is clearly the place for uh
for american chess you know i've always
loved knockout tournaments you know
being playing able to play a really
strong elite knockout event with some of
the best players from all over the world
is really great oh it's awesome to be
playing again i haven't played this is
my first tournament of the year so i'm
really looking forward to it and it's
just kind of nice to have some normalcy
again i really hope i really hope it's
back to normal and we will continue
playing chess and playing without masks
and enjoying chess game and enjoying
like social chess life
like doing some chess camps which i'm
missing i usually teach in a lot of
chess camps so
i hope everything will come back
now okay we can see everyone's beautiful
faces again and uh
yeah i think
it's really nice sign i'm hoping that
things remain this way
and yeah tournaments are coming back so
it's just really nice
usgs is only getting stronger and
stronger i'm very excited because i'm
actually trying to focus on over the
board this year
so this is my first term and after this
two tournaments in granchester and then
norway so
i'm gonna be playing just for two months
basically but it's a good start yeah it
feels pretty much back to normal now
uh
i mean we played the us championship
last year so that was already i guess we
were starting to get in gear of over the
board tournaments coming back
and and this this is really nice to
to be back here again and uh playing it
feels sort of like a u.s championship
again but with such a unique format
that not not quite us championship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody it is day three of the
american cup a double elimination
tournament and because it's double
elimination some of the players have two
lives remaining and some of them just
won
exactly we're gonna see
say goodbye to a number of those players
as we look at our brackets and right now
it is the last opportunity for some of
these players ray robson is playing
against sam shanley they split the point
in the first game of their elimination
bracket game so right now robson will
try with the white pieces meanwhile
jeffrey's showing in an absolutely must
win game against
wesley saw and he must win because he
just completely blundered out of the
opening exactly he was lost uh within
the first five minutes as we sat down
and we got that news from uh
christian we couldn't believe it jeffrey
was lost out of the opening lost the
game needs to win to stay in the
competition
in the women's elimination we have a
very similar scenario for katerina
nemtsov who with the white pieces
against ryan yan without too much of a
fight to be honest right and katarina
needs a win to stay in the event but she
will play be playing with the black
pieces as does anna zatonski as does
anna satoshi who also lost with white in
a chaotic game against a ruler told but
it was the greek player student of st
louis university that was able to make
the last trick and of course that one is
the one that counts right
needs only a draw with the white pieces
are of course expecting these games to
be super sharp super interesting but the
championship bracket is still going on
and still has very fascinating games
particularly this game of aronian and
dominguez is catching our eye there was
a transmission error because uh g3 which
was a very surprisingly for my eyes i
just could not have guessed it we were
expecting the move c4 c3 hasn't been
played according to our transmission but
you said you went upstairs you saw it on
the board
a lot of things happen we have to catch
up because our board is not working
right let us go i assume it was c3 i saw
it was b3 c4 as c3
i assumed something like queen a5
i assume it was queen a5
there's a bishop on a yeah
rookie
iii queen d1
the other rook the other the other
excuse me so that
yeah so we don't get our queen bishop a3
queen d1 yes rook d6 bishop f2
okay
and this is the position we have on the
board after rook takes e1 now we guessed
the way here but we're pretty sure right
and this is our current situation now
the question is
how are we doing here because if i take
with the rook and i go bishop b2 with
the thread of queen takes away
yeah it's a pretty good pretty good
thread
it's a really good thread it's a really
good thing you i basically have only one
move and help me out if there's an
alternative to a4 but if i go slowly
like
this it's over uh
do i have an alternative day you might
you might have to take with the bishop
i'll tell you the alternative guys
recite queen to e2 what
oh
[Music]
what is the clowns
[Laughter]
no you can take with a rook you bishop
to b2 is coming on the board there's
absolutely no defense even if you don't
take and you go something like first of
all after a4
all the time it comes before queen to a3
but in this particular case i can also
just simply take oh
it's completely over but check this out
it seems like if what the moves that we
made are the correct ones
at this point bishop to c1 apparently is
equal still also it would be strange not
to play bishop c1 whenever
after rook 286 it does seem like black
still has the advantage right right well
wait a minute because i get to recapture
on you you have to take take with 91 oh
i was thinking knight d3 oh but then you
take i take with the knight then you
drop yes so you have to play queen e1
yes so your idea with knight d5 yes
sorry knight to d3 to defend the bishop
and probably
you have to defend b2 and i'll quit
right so i have to keep you honest and
eyeball the e3 pawn with queen e1
because it is a check it is a check not
only that but whenever uh you're going
to take one c1 i have to meet that with
king c1 and try to run away which is a
good move queen e1 right it allows me to
flee exactly so queenie not queen on e2
because i i want to flee on e2 with the
king exactly you got to get on your
running shoes don't want to impede the
king but guys this is over
this is over but bishop one is it's over
by not playing bishop c1 levon signed
his own
death certificate yeah i mean after
queen to e1 sure i can still go knight
to f6 and now you have to harass my
queen try to exchange the queens
otherwise you get checkmated
queen to e5 but i can continue covering
that queen with the move a b5 and yeah i
mean it's very difficult to play these
type of positions with the white piece
try to defend this like this queen to e3
what if i just simply take yeah sure
you're going to take allow me to take on
a2 this is almost impossible to play
from a practical perspective i see ideas
such as
queen to a1 now you meet uh this uh idea
with king to d2 because i have queen to
see
nice impossible to see from a human's
perspective it's impossible to see
you're going to provoke b5 so that you
open up the diagonal c8 a6 and now you
have king d2 queen takes h1 queen to c8
good luck finding this yeah over the
board he did not he played the move um
bishop bishop to f2 and after rook to e1
i'm not sure if he's thinking i'm not
sure if he's resigning we're going to
have to wait and see because bishop to
b2 rook to a6 is coming on the board
lanier knows it lev knows it and there's
absolutely no way to stop it wow
um alejandro the second elimination
match games are about to begin and it's
a big one they have actually started as
you see them on the board three players
that are facing a lot facing elimination
they must win
katnina nem sova and jeffrey schong all
in a must win game two of them with the
black pieces which makes it even more
interesting meanwhile while wesley only
needs a draw with black we know that he
had difficulties finding a way to try to
win with black against evian but drawing
with black is certainly a wesley
specialty absolutely no when wesley gets
uh in the driver's seat uh leading a
tournament he
is generally one of the very very best
players uh in terms of roping in a
victory from a position of strength now
where he really showed
i mean it was a fizzle it was a real bad
fizzle uh with black against sam savion
when he needed to win he didn't generate
anything
and he was actually kind of lucky just
to get out with the draw uh in the game
of jeffrey zhang uh this is
again the joko piano has become well
yeah
it actually is sorry i saw the bishop on
ce5 i thought it was a joke or piano but
it wasn't it was in berlin
and we're looking the players are
playing quite a theoretical game this is
not uh fabi versus sam savion we were
looking at jeffrey
facing elimination uh against wesley so
queen e7 has just been played again the
same kind of
nonchalant kind of queen d1
moved around got to e2 with a spin
yeah
and
dropped
his button with the pinky but also
wesley so has 26 minutes on the clock
right now dropping 25 minutes more than
he started off with right i just know
it's because it's 25. it's so difficult
to outplay wesley in these positions
wow and jeffrey only 21 minutes so
he might be aware of where to
place his pieces but he doesn't really
know how to exactly do that we were
talking about arena crush and her
mastery of isolated queen pond positions
she loves playing against the isolated
queen pond i think for wesley so these
e4 e5
positions he just plays fantastic which
is absolutely fantastic wow wow
uh queen e2 there is a pause as uh
wesley is considering bishop g4
uh maybe a little pureet with his knight
98 knight
uh
e6 ideas after knight d8 also includes
c6 trying to embarrass the bishop on b5
but let's also jump and not forget that
we do have a classical games going on
guys uh yes please but i i do want to go
to that aronian game because i feel with
the camera i think we're going to the
camera we shouldn't see resign soon i
think we're going to see a handshake
anytime soon bishop to b2 is on the
board queen takes a2 is a clear threat
beautiful checkmating threat and there's
no way to stop it
queen takes a2 followed by it's over a6
and rook a1 it's over we're going to see
a hamstring by the way losing with white
this way
not just losing with white
i mean he just got crushed
it's move 26. yeah this move g3 just
very very perplexing i didn't think it
was a horrendous
uh a horrendous mistake but it actually
turned out to be as he followed up with
bishop f2 remain reminding everybody
they do play two classical uh games and
levone will have to win with black black
against dominguez probably one of the
most solid players in the top 20 i mean
exactly i i i've seen him go like plus
one and
draw 10 in the us championship i think
he beat shanklin in one of these
tournaments i think it was
yeah i think it was the same shank
winner he said i felt like an idiot
because i had the only loss against
dominguez in the whole tournament to
being a very very very solid player i
mean beating any of these top players on
demand is tough beating them with black
doubly so as levon is in there going oh
my gosh
what have i done where did it all go
wrong
because it's
it's it just didn't feel like he was
understanding those positions he didn't
feel those people he didn't feel the
attack
yeah the knight
he played everything fast knight g5 h4
everything correctly according to the
engine but he did not know the follow-up
okay this is uh this is a tough way of
starting the second round for lavone
roni and i'm just going to look at the
other classical games um
looks like fabi is enjoying a plus
against um
and we're being told that
sacrificed a bishop as expected in
probably the worst version
i could have imagined no it's not that
bad
but like why did you not do it when
before
i developed all pieces yeah i understand
that
uh it can't be the worst person anyway
bishop takes h3 it's a pretty bad
version it's just dead lost yeah
no no no it's not completely wait a
minute queen ca yeah bishop f1 bishop f1
queen f5 is going to pop up and then
bishop g2 but then i'm going to
sacrifice and plant my queen on h3 and
hopefully
i'm running i'm running yes sir you're
running running to the center right
let's put that on the analysis board
bishop okay so queen c8 is on the board
we're expecting bishop f1 and alejandro
and i were just debating the the merits
versus the demerits
yeah oh wait a minute hold on wait no no
no no no no no
what queen f2 rogue d2 looks crushing oh
so you're saying that i i'm welcome to
snack on this pawn yes but after queen
f2 rook d2
uh hardy hand clasp yeah okay fair
enough well the problem is that you're
also losing the e4
because i'm going to be able to take
with the queen as well
this is a whole rook
i've chased you this is over
to
the rook right
[Laughter]
what's a rook amongst friends i mean
come on
guys uh look at this horrible king
nobody believes he leaves you nobody
believes you oh man
yeah i'm i'm losing i'm losing my
my great supporters here but hey it
wasn't me who sacrificed uh the bishop
uh we do have queen c8 we are expecting
uh alice to play the move bishop f1 so i
think this is important to point out uh
queen no no no you are on the correct
position okay after bishop g2
queen takes f2
oops excuse me
rook d2
queen takes f2 rook d2 yes
h4 for example it does seem like you're
continuing your attack right i mean i
i've got some heavies uh covered in the
case some heavy's coming if you manage
to get maybe queen g3 maybe even g3 but
i think queen h4 is uh better just to
explain the idea all right because after
queen h4 i simply take on e4
really yeah okay and if you take
gryffindor knight i'm going to take with
the queen
ah
reminding me of the back ranked mate not
on the other e8 but on c8 but on c8
because the it's
so queen h4 covers d8 but i have two
rooks ready to uh
bounce on the eighth rank right so
not
rook d8 but rook c8 and it will be a
back rank mate yep very good
and that's a problem that's a huge
problem if you lose the e4 pawn then
there's no attack
wow
i don't see anything
i'm thinking
there's not much to think about it is
looking for but it's that move queen
takes e4 that comes with such
ferocity
wow
yeah what can i say i mean
meanwhile let's take a look at levon's
body language he hasn't resigned just
yet but wow not a very happy man now
i know exactly what levon is thinking is
not looking at any move
what he's doing and what we all do is
internally we regress and we're thinking
about where and he's looking at the
score sheet i think he's got an eye
towards the scoresheet where did it all
go wrong right i did this i did this i
did this i did that i did that oh by the
way i resigned yeah right
sorry for wasting your time as well as
my own but uh there's nothing to say
here queen takes a2
rook a6 is simply checkmate no like they
teach us in
books yeah yeah
oh my goodness
so yeah
now
normally if this was a very very well
attended u.s championship there would be
about 12
players right
to rub it in and to look at your
demise
uh but this is what we're seeing who is
this
a2
nasty threat there's nothing to do about
it nope
but boy i must say it was a a a
confusing movement that whole g2 g3 it's
like he didn't sense the danger no
okay guys right all right let's just
what what let's have some fun
all right what if i tried to survive no
not survive forget about that one right
there's no survival there's no surviving
b4
b3
b4 that's good position just because you
know what else
queen takes whether it works or not
queen takes a2 can you take c2
check
check or b5 or b5 no but it does king b3
and rook to a6
so let's go b5 no but this loses right
how does it lose king bb
and you survive
i don't think actually you're not
surviving i think i win i think i just
win that position no no no because i
ah maybe you are winning yeah because
the end game is pretty bad right queen
a1 bishop takes a1 knight d3 yeah and
three and uh
yeah maybe uh the wheels have completely
fallen off of that attack and things
that will never happen for a thousand
yeah but b3 before i take on b4 the game
is over yeah exactly queen takes b4 is
also
pretty brutal
yeah it's it's so over
wow yeah
and uh once again uh in the elimination
bracket it's jeffrey has to win
is white against wesley slow uh to force
a playoff reminding everybody it's a
25-minute game
that these two are playing
it just feels like a very normal
position sorry and it's a five second
uh five yes twenty five plus five i
think it's ten sorry
it is it's right three five plus ten
twenty five plus ten sorry to miss
lead you
all right by the way alice lee is making
all the right moves she played bishop f1
queen to f5 bishop g2 is on the board
wow and then rescience is coming soon
that's not ellis lee and this is
against
exactly
which by the way katarina here needs to
needs to win but also she's taken on f2
which we didn't really see an
alternative and we're thinking rook d
right
rook t2 almost finishes the game right
now five minutes and 45 seconds only for
today 37 minutes such a huge time
difference
it doesn't matter you're down a piece
but the other thing that's the problem
she psyches herself out
thought that she had a brilliant
position you can do anything no i
thought that she came out of the opening
actually with the edge with the edge
right right she had space and easy
development and rook d2 unfortunately
for tata f she's actually forced her
opponent
to find the find all the good moves i
mean you have no choice you can resign
or find a really good move i'll find a
really good move
there's been a narrow path for alice but
she's navigated it very well and she is
now
on the version of winning yeah
12 years old that's impressing herself
very impressive first american cup that
is the future of uh that's making
hurricanes
isn't it it really is
i mean i remember so many years ago when
bobby fischer became a grand master at
the age of 15 and i thought oh nobody
will ever ever ever touch his record
break his record alice lee the winner of
the american cup at 12 years old nobody
will ever ever ever break her man
even i made it younger than fisher
i mean you have like a list of people in
my
know i stopped talking about youngest
grandmasters long long long long time
ago but that was very funny uh
alice lee twelve years she's a feed a
master passing and she has her own show
oh she's just i know she just got her
she just got her first i am norm wow
so she's already starting to accumulate
her i am norms for her i am titled dang
yeah dang and of course she on the chess
kit she has alice palace
alice's palace alice's palace i think
yeah great and she's inspiring
um children all over the world but just
look at that she's focused she
she is very impressive i don't see her
get off the board
almost never she's always there
good sits flash as uh we would say
ray robinson let me just check in on ray
robson sam they drew their first game
uh ray now with the white pieces looks
like he snapped off a pawn good for him
[Laughter]
knight takes you yeah look at ray go
that's all theory yeah is it yeah yeah i
don't know
oh this is from berlin right long long
berlin all theory wow
uh let's see if we can get yasser's
board up and queen e2 you said is new
what was it well i think it's queen f3
but i forgot why i don't actually play
this line i prepared it for somebody
um
and i remember it's queen f3 i just
don't know why we need two seems to be
sam but sam strangely not in prep he's
sorry it's ray of course that's not in
preps i'm of course in prep sam has 27
minutes 27 minutes he knows exactly
where he is yeah right he's not a pawn
down no he's not a pawn down he knows
exactly what's going on and i think i
think the move maybe is queen f4 right
queen fort
the desirable rookie eight obviously
doesn't work it doesn't work because of
the knight so the move queen f4 is
designed with a very specific idea to
tickle the knight
also
to land with a rook on d2 i like that
little queen for it looks very
uh pleasant
queen f4 i might even start to think
that i should just give my pawn back
right away and then play 95 and then we
will have a playoff remember that if
they tie
these 25 plus 10 games they will be
playing again later today at 6 p.m
perhaps a little earlier if the
classical games are done earlier to two
games of 10 plus five gotcha and if they
tie those that's
armageddon of yesterday still left us so
enthralled what do you have first
christian well one player that is seems
to be making a comeback in her match is
nemtsova against rue yang yen she lost
the first game with the white pieces it
doesn't it didn't seem like she did
anything uh right in that game but in
this one she's taking the bull by the
horns knight to h5 bishop to b3 king to
h8 ready to blast open the king side
with the move f5 knight to h2 f5 and we
have this position right now
d4 allowing the move e4 that's not right
d5 knight to e5 this is the current
position we have on the board and i'm
just looking at black species and
black's plan and i just see after knight
takes e5 bishop takes e5 i see a queen
coming to g6 i see a rook going to g8
and i don't see any defenders around
your king and exactly i don't see any
way in which you can bring any defenders
around your king look at this bishop
why did you play the move d5 why did you
play the move d4 first i have the
perfect piece placement and all your
pieces are away from your defense this
is going to go uh down in flames for
white knight to e5 20 minutes for her 13
minutes and counting for rueyang yan i
think she's going to bounce back in this
one that'll be incredible winning with
black
she's i i think she's um
how do you say she does she need to
reacquaint herself with the pieces
because the first match
it was not impressive uh the first date
the first game today
katya has not been impressive but now
wow you can see the kashka that we're
used to exactly yeah yeah she's
aggressive she's a formidable player
she's of course a very busy player she's
not a professional chess player she is a
phd student at arizona university she's
studying communications definitely a
demanding uh career off the board for
her but it's good to see her play good
chess because we're used to her
representing the country in olympia it's
in world teams and she does amazing she
really does i remember her
playing in baku i was loving it when
she's in the lineup guys why is levon
still playing lavon yeah he actually
made a move right did he really yeah he
played d3 and instantly
linear beat play b5 no no rook a6 queen
takes a6 b5 you cannot take my rook no
touching that
aha so just for everybody uh the big
threat of course is queen takes a to
check and um followed up by mating the
white king okay so there's a rook a6 no
the funny thing is that b4 doesn't work
now
what's that before the same reason
well christian showed us that no more
before no more before more b4 yeah no
more king d3 and he's played a4 a4 has
to be played but i think queen before
comes immediately immediately so you you
will have one check queen to b4 queen
takes b5
queen to a3 and now you give a spiked
check exactly and queen 28 or b quickly
then i just simply go king to h7 yeah
all right
ah there is a check on e8 there's a
check on f5 there's a couple of spike
checks there's three yes nice nice
if it was three check you'd be crying
yes there
uh of three checks which by the way
letter to otis uh our product on our
production team is very good at very
good at he trains for it he played a
world championship match it's amazing
he's amazing right i mean so much talent
he he told me that he lost the match
because he got out prepared and i was
like what
you got out prepared in three checks
yeah what is this yes
you don't know what you're missing until
you try it yourself uh three check a
very nice variant queen a5 i think
that's it uh
lavon uh
certainly stretch but there's nothing
else to be said queen a3 queen a1 on
black's agenda
and there's quite frankly nothing to be
done
meanwhile it seems that ray and sam are
heading quickly to their ten plus five
games
which will break their tie because this
one well just seems completely that
drawn three against three on the king
side two against two on the queen side
heavy pieces for both i think it's time
to find a way
to make a repetition make a repetition
and there you go levon has resigned our
number one seed our number one seed must
be disgusted with this game linear
taking full advantage of the situation
winning a crushing game
and he will be very smooth and he'll be
a clear favorite coming in tomorrow as
he will only need a draw with the white
pieces against levon aronian and that is
going to be a super exciting game for me
a game that has fallen through the
cracks is our number one seed in the
women's championship
uh
arena crush uh had been playing against
this isolated queen pawn way back here
let's just try to quickly catch up with
the players after h7 h6 it seems like
there was a lot of tooing and throwing
a lot of gnashing of teeth but nothing
dramatic really
happened so far in this game
knight to g4 knight to c3 and we've
caught up with the players i think
begging has done an excellent job of
exploiting small weaknesses in white
scams she keeps using the weakness that
b3 left puts a bishop there controls the
c file puts the knight on c3 the other
knights coming to e4 it feels like she's
getting good counter play for her
isolated pawn i think she's done a
brilliant job at handling this position
i'm very impressed with the way that
she's doing this okay concretely uh if
we continue the line knight takes f6
takes f6
now that i've put this knight in a pin i
just need to move the queen to an
effective square so queen g4 looks like
a tempo
the rook has to go somewhere i'm not a
hundred percent sure let's just go rook
d8 or normal
and because this knight is in the pin
can i
do anything you can try
i do oh knight f4 is clever because i
don't have 92 in this position let's put
that for the audience i need to check
the night
because
isn't that amazing right it's a
discovery but you get counter discover
knight takes c2 queen takes a1 and this
is annoying bishop h7 check freeze the
rook on you want to take my queen if you
haven't lost your queen like this at
least 10 times you have not a
grandmaster
these uh discovered checks to pick up
the queen every chess grandmaster has
now fallen for it once twice or thrice
uh a dozen times
uh but so knight f4 let's try to break
that pin with the move d4 yeah d4 seems
necessary d4
that's
that's clever i mean we're heading
towards that line because she played the
move queen to g4 yeah he's on the board
okay it's on the board so d5 d4
temporarily breaking this pin
and if i take you can't take one and now
the question is how much compensation do
i have off tonight pretty good pretty
good two bishops the bishop on a1 is
buried exactly i
i would say that the
very attractive yeah very full for will
i go bishop d6 in the next move attack
the knight yeah i think it's full comp
but perhaps i can even go
queen takes d4 right or even a rook
takes e4
right yeah
because e8 no no i cannot do because a
bishop takes c3
rookie eight uh is protected there is no
back rank made
okay we'll keep our eye on this one how
is sam cevion doing
that one seems to be heading to a drug
christian what do you have yeah
absolutely this one seems to be i i
think we misunderstood uh black's ideas
in this position because you guys were
analyzing the position after bishop
takes up g takes f6 and you were saying
white is crushing after knight very
enthusiastic actually the problem with
knight h5 is that i'm going to go d4 i'm
going to allow you to take on f6 this
knight is going to be out of play and i
have a huge weapon the d-pawn i'm going
to roll that down the board i'm going to
defend it with the knight and then i'm
just going to start picking up your
pawns you don't have enough compensation
and enough activity with this central
pawns so unfortunately after knight to
h5 you are in trouble after d4 this is
the move that we did not consider if you
cannot play the move knight to h5 well
then you have to take on d5 which he did
in the game but this allows me to take
back take back
and pick up the f5
yeah i saw a position where i got a pawn
on f5 and a knight on h5 and no more
big difference right huge difference
huge difference and let's see how they
played check king h7 rook to e7 now i go
behind your pawn i allow you to take
the pawn on f7 even the pawn on a7 but
i'm going to eliminate this guy this is
the one that i'm after
and it seems like
we are in this position right now
everything is equal i do have let's say
structural disadvantage as black but it
doesn't really matter i have enough uh
compensation
through the activity of my rook and this
one is over a draw between robson and
shanklin and we're headed
for a an armageddon at 6 00 pm 6 p.m and
they do a
flipping of the coins excuse me not an
armageddon we're actually they're going
to they don't play them they play at two
games of ten plus five they'll reverse
colors right so ray will start with the
white pieces brilliant got it
um
again uh we're seeing great prep by sam
shanklin yeah easy draw right very
professional he had 27 minutes and
already 20 moves on the board
they didn't need to think unfazed uh
impressive impressive by the way um
katya
how's she doing she's just he's just
killing uh
lovely yeah
f2 f4 was
um the last move yeah but what are you
doing
g6
i'm
wondering
ambassador too also right yeah every
move every movie yeah the more you look
at it the more you're like every move
yeah but queen g6 uh you're first yeah
this is very direct
looks really really really powerful
wow yeah okay that looks overwhelming
apart here exactly now ana zatonski
needs a win
to stay in the competition well the good
side the good thing for ana fans she is
currently up a pawn and i think that is
the end of the good news
i really don't like your position
one of those catalans where white gets
an enormous amount of free play for the
pawn right
uh and like you say the end of the good
news because that's a ferocious attack
coming over on the game
e4 is coming h5 yeah i mean
it's a pawn but it's suffering as well
yeah knight g4 i think kind of plays
itself right right knight is coming to
e5 it's coming you're allowing e4 knight
h6 is coming h5 is coming yeah the
really far played yeah the really good
news for white is that h5 when it lands
uh you needed to defend it you needed to
to play h5 you needed to defend the
knight but once you do get an h5
boy
there's a weak
very very weak king side that anna has
to
figure out how she wants to repair yeah
i love the opening choice here for
starula
not afraid to give up upon
you know that's the problem when you're
white and all you need is a draw
sometimes you play it's so timid so
passively that you're going to talk
about like very young exactly you you
end up
uh not playing your game right yeah yeah
this is what i told starbulla in the
break that we had i got to see her for a
couple of minutes after she be done on
the first game i told her the most
important thing that you do with white
play a normal game don't think that you
need to draw if there's a fourth draw
take it obviously right but if it's not
forced play your move exactly exactly
and we have to move f6 and here it's
where it gets crazy right because you i
think white hat kind of has to go e4 but
i mean
e4 is a very logical move
e4 i would i would bang you for you
because where's the night go
uh
we were just talking about coaching and
i can't remember
uh all the players but i believe it was
a
doveretsky story where he had a player
on his team that just loved sacrificing
there's just no he
he just had the sacrifice he wasn't
himself and all the team needed was a
draw
all the team needed was you know uh a
two-two tie and
everybody's happy and he's got this
player
so doveretsky just threw the dice he
said if you don't sacrifice at night uh
you're not gonna have dinner tonight
i get to sacrifice and i
crushed it
he crushed us
it was a beautiful
understanding the psychology of the
moment yeah it's a big deal you i don't
play for a draw play for the momentum
right and it was very nice you must
sacrifice a knight or you don't get to
eat
rough rough
nice
uh f6 why were you attracted like that
instantly to the movie e2 e4 help us
understand
uh mainly because i hate this knight on
d5 it's plugging things up on the d5 i
just want to get rid of it before i do
anything else okay like even if
because fg just destroys your own
position right
no yeah i don't want to yeah fg
e takes and boy i put that and yeah i'm
yum yum the knight has to go that has to
go back and then i can figure out what
to do
what am i going to do next based on
where the knight on d5 goes okay exactly
and here i don't know i'll play
something like knight f3 or maybe
i'll see i don't think knight h6 ever
works but perhaps i'll throw it in he
sacrifices oh does e5 work that's what
my question was uh
fg hg and then knight f6
whoa
okay okay
we're not forcing her to sacrifice that
guy
not my student
but guess what we have the man of the
hour
with christian thank you yasser we are
indeed with linear dominguez after a
tremendous victory against the number
one favorite levon aronian linear first
of all big congratulations a win with
the black pieces against such a strong
opponent did he surprise you in the
opening with this move e4 and how did
you approach this game
yeah thank you um well i
i it wasn't really a surprise i mean
that one plays
both e4 and d4 so i
i wasn't really surprised by his by his
choice but i do think that he played the
opening uh
in a dubious way
and uh
after the move bishop b5 bishop d7 it
it feels that black is somehow already
better because all my pieces are coming
to the center with tempo and
and then uh it it it looks very ugly for
for white from from that point maybe
it's it's uh not lost but
certainly a very nice position just
right from the opening perhaps we can
see that opposition on the board right
now we were surprised by this move
bishop to b5 as well also we were
surprised that he was playing so fast
did you guys discuss the opening at all
after the game did he tell you where he
missed his preparation yeah i think he
uh probably confused the lines and he
thought that uh
because he was thinking about the lines
where black plays c6 first and then goes
c5 and then we get some very similar
positions
and and then i think he thought that he
was just the temple down or something
like that and that's why he went bishop
bishop b5 but uh i mean after a move
like bishop b5 it's clear that something
went uh seriously wrong for white i
think g4 is the move that is consistent
with what white is doing but then c4
yeah and bishop f1 i wasn't sure bishop
e2 allows bishop d6 maybe and there are
some
i mean the pieces on the file are a bit
yeah 27 ideas or yeah we should d4 and
then i thought maybe
maybe i can take on g5 hd and queen
sound this is the same idea
wow who's getting mated
i think we see something
so yeah yeah he was getting you you you
you checkmated him on the dark squares
yeah this case you might he might return
the favor on on the dark squares as well
uh
something terrible
nothing
apg
oh there is a rookie five right
yes
[Laughter]
bishop b5 was also the question for us
we we were surprised by right it seemed
that it helped you i think if something
like uh like g4 has to be played and
then c4 and i don't know if bgb2 or
bishop f1 but essentially i will for
example after a month like bishop f1
i will go b5 or queen a5 and b5 maybe b5
first it's more flexible
and then
with the bishop on f1 it's not the same
white attack because
i can i mean it's a bit slow still and
this knight xf7 king f7 g5 it's probably
not working because of knight h5 and
sorry to interrupt you guys we do have a
result as we expected alice lee has
defeated tatev abrahamian very good to
take a 1-0 lead in the classical and uh
you were saying at this point knight h5
you have seen these types of variations
you were expecting
this type of game i was expecting
something like this yes crazy so after
bishop b5 however
suddenly you thought how well sweet it
is i mean everything comes to the center
as you said
is he free play
yeah it look just looks very very nice
for black i was i wasn't sure if it was
i mean
close to winner or something but
but it was certainly very pleasant and
here i saw this yeah this
bond sacrifice which i think it's good
because practically it's very hard for
white to
to play this position especially because
i get c3
the point is that c3 of course allows
queen five check and then rook takes e3
did the move g3 come as a surprise for
you um i was it on your right yeah i
thought that white has to try to do
something on the queen side and and and
try to protect i don't know uh i was
thinking bishop d2 or
or king a1 those were the moves i was
mostly considering right g3 for me was
just like completely
not
yeah it feels that black is very close
to to win here right and i don't know if
what i play is correct but uh
we felt that uh this was his last moment
yeah
bishop c1 probably has to be played yeah
and the the computer was showing some
crazy
way that white may stays in the game but
it's very very
yeah we were discussing some line uh
after the game yeah something like
bishop c1 but i'm i'm not sure if it's
uh correct in any white takes on e1 i
mean if black takes only one rookie one
yes
uh rook a6 yes then there is
uh queen d3 apparently exactly if bishop
c1 king c1 and
you try to run for the king
runs and uh yeah and if bishop b2
instead of bishop takes c1
yep then a4 uh sorry interrupt but we
also have another result in the
championship bracket asparagus and sam
savion do draw their game as we expected
only one game left there sorry guys not
at all after a4 yeah
yeah there is just uh um
you might still bring the line
queen before now it looks good yes uh
because queen a3 is a huge threat so
bishop takes b2
uh cb2 and c3 queen b3 wins but here
instead of bishop takes p2 white has
uh
knight d5 oh
that's queen a3 yes
knight takes f6 gf6 rookie 8 k7 bishop
takes h6 and white wins
oh it's gonna be amazing
but on the other side
oh my god
that's the cold shower that's pretty sad
oh that's very sad but you have seen
this no i mean we were just moving the
pieces after the game but uh guys what a
move knight d5
yeah but uh probably black has to play
rook a6 uh immediately instead of taking
on e1 and this way after rookie 898
maybe then put the knight on d6 i mean i
have no idea but essentially this bishop
c1 i think was probably the
the last chance the last chance you know
congratulations lanier uh thank you the
american cup
welcome welcome
nice yeah very smooth victory there
congratulations on here that was a great
game
wow just
smooth with black against levon wow
levana's uh a hiccuped uh in his match
with ray robson and now today and now
today wow
suddenly his back is to the wall as our
number one seed but you were saying that
fabi and our newly minted 2700 sam
savion he wants another point
establishing himself in the 2700 club as
sam savion as he draws and that means
the number two seed in the championship
bracket we only have one game left again
between irena crush and
and
we have a bunch of the rapid games left
of course that is in the elimination
bracket and we are guaranteed playoffs
later at the very least between ray
robson and sam shanklin and in that game
of arena crush by the way the players
have followed our analysis including the
pawn sacrifice d5
d4 all the way
all the way to 1961 right as uh they are
playing a very
well contested game and going for the
two bishops for the compensation they
just played the move knight takes b-1
but we have our youngest competitor in
the field with christian
we are indeed with alice lee after an
incredible victory with the white pieces
against uh the streaky tatev abrahamian
first of all congratulations alice
that's a big victory for you how did you
approach uh this match do you know
tatevoid
um
yeah um thank you so um yeah i mean i
think that her general playing style is
to like kind of attack and that's what
she did this game um so it was kind of
dangerous for me uh so the opening i
played usually is like yeah like with
knight f3 then e3
it
doesn't usually allow attacks but she
managed to like create something with
bishop takes h3
um so i think that was basically my
general approach to this game were you
surprised by her time spencer
especially after that rook to d5 and
then spending another five minutes on to
g5 and you were playing so fast how
would you feel at that point yeah i mean
um i thought that i could defend with
like kinichon and bishop f1 so i didn't
think her attack was that great which is
why i kind of blitzed out a few moves
not really blitzed but
um i think her time management probably
could have improved um but like
it's kind of hard to play when you're
trying to think about how to create an
attack
and
she tried
and when did you feel like you're
pretty much taking over and securing
that full point
um i wasn't exactly sure um well she
played the attack i mean i thought that
i could probably defend um
so
yeah um i thought that here yeah i was
winning because yeah queen takes f2 rook
d2 and then
another
of her problem is that she has some
background problems um
so like knight takes e4 as possible i
thought the knight d5 would also be okay
but
yeah after a night age by uh knight f4 i
think i should be winning um i felt that
i was better after like i was able to do
rook i see one one move before he did
the bishop sacrifice but um i didn't
think it was like that easily winning
yeah um around here rook i see one um
because my rooks control the open files
and her work on g6 is a bit misplaced if
she's like not going to go for the
attack
nicely placed rooks you're saying the
rook is off side on g if the attack
doesn't work the rook on g6 is just off
sights you're saying yeah
alice uh very impressive you held your
nerve uh in the face of a very uh fierce
attacker congratulations and uh much
success for the remaining game tomorrow
thank you
this is very often but a cold-blooded 12
year old just taking a piece defending
like it was absolutely no issue
whatsoever right and she wins a huge
game here against tatif on the verge of
qualifying to the finals of the
championship bracket is alice lee only
needs to draw tomorrow tatif with her
back against the wall and and let's be
clear about this game tata did this all
to herself yes yes and it was what we
might call a self-inflicted wound right
yes but nonetheless i mean alice you
know hey look it's it's easy to see the
ghost when you know you
when the the pieces are flying against
your king i love this about her she
doesn't believe in ghosts she just
doesn't see it and she plays it she
doesn't think they're 30 minutes so what
am i missing what is my strong opponent
planning
she analyzes and she believes right
it's a huge advantage very nice and as
we go to the elimination bracket i just
wanted to bring up that game of your
student yes because guess what e4 e4
and after knight b6 knight back came
back to f3 e5
check
that's intriguing why do we
need the queen i really liked your e5 by
the way i thought that was very very
very good uh yeah just uh
just a moment ago yeah because it wasn't
a piece sacrifice it was just two pieces
for an ex for a rook right you go e5 f
takes
bishop takes c6 bishop takes a8 then you
take on g5
and then you plan it and then you plan
something
probably a night and it's uh yeah it's
it's not a material deficit actually not
at all right this looks like a
tremendous attacking
uh
she missed that moment she dropped the
knight back and allowed on a e6 e5 and
as we catch up with the players this
feels
night
like like struva allowed and what is the
tempo tempo
night night three minutes and 40 seconds
for starula and seven minutes for
satonski by the way the knight came to
c4 with temper the knight is coming to
be through the tempo but what does this
queen be three queen e3 queens uh
mistakes
training is not paying off
looks like a few mistakes here by
by white and anna
needing a win on demand
well it might be mighty this is a great
position right boy you got the extra
pawn yeah you got the knights dancing
the iron h6 looks
out of play actually the knight on h6
looks trapped
let's jump you have to go h5
oh sorry uh white probably right try to
do something do something and try to
create something
you have to sacrifice and if you're
going to respond after g5 after h5 with
g5 maybe i can go g4 after that and at
least my knight is coming back into the
play yeah at the same time it does feel
quite dicey for white uh i don't see a
lot of avenues for her attack to be
successful now a big moment in this game
between uh crush
and tokyo nova because we were going
down the path that we were discussing
but there was a slight difference and
that is the rook is on c6 this was a big
moment where to put the rook you're
going to put either on d8 or c6 she
decided to go on c6 and now we have this
forced line that the ladies are
following knight takes b1 if you do take
back the knight on b1 after rook to c2
it does feel like we're getting a
version of what we discussed but a much
better version for black because the
rukon c2 is beautifully placed and ready
for the attack instead of that irena
found this move d5 opening up the bishop
and attacking the rook and now we're
yes we're going straight into this
variation bishop takes c6
but that's another thing
that is a nasty pin and you can
immediately take advantage of it with
the move queen to f5
i'm going to take a pawn and now you're
going to have to take
my knight with either the queen or the
rook probably with the rook if you take
with the queen actually i think after
queen to d2 it does feel like black has
a lot of compensation active queen
bishop dropping back to c5 creating a
big threat on f2 this knight is kind of
out in the open i'm going to be able to
attack it and harass it with my bishop
it does feel like black has enough
compensation but what if
she takes with a rook on b1 now how is
this position i'm looking at it and i'm
trying to find ways for black to
continue bishop to d7 obviously is a
tribe
queen to e4 bishop to c6 queen to d3
what if i try to keep
my queen connected to uh to the rook
then you can go bishop to c5
complicated position complicated
position and with the ladies getting
down to their last five minutes and
seven minutes respectively for irena
crush this one is going to be a barn
burner keep an eye on that by the way
jeffrey in a force uh winning
he must win to stay in the competition
has an advantage against wesley so it's
one of those bishops of opposite colors
and in those bishops of opposite color
middle game endings it's about the
initiative and whose king is a little
bit more exposed
jeffrey got a nice rook on b6 the knight
on d4 is beautiful
and h6 is hanging h6 is hanging f3 if we
can ever coordinate
the you know put the bishop on e5 put
the rook on h6 and i'll show you what a
dark square
attack and
look at the time eight minutes for
jeffrey and wesley is hitting a minute
30. that is not a lot of time there i'm
in a 20 actually wow wesley so certainly
feeling the pressure in this position
jeffrey giving himself a real fighting
chances absolutely no question about it
and uh
well uh h6h5 on the board we'll keep an
eye on that as we have a special guest
in studio alejandro yes uh fabiano
carrana is with christian
thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with fabiano caruana first of all fabi
how did you approach this game it seems
like your opening choice was just wild
yeah well it was an interesting line
um it was a bit of a gamble
uh but i felt like it went well of
course i'm it's not a bad line for white
but it's very double edged especially
this idea with rook to b1 rook to b2
tell us a little bit about that yeah
when i found this i was very attracted
to it because i i like these sort of
weird
ideas um
it's basically the the point of the
position is that neither side can do
very much let's say after
after rook to b2
it explains his move h6 because if he
ever plays knight a5 then he has to
contend with e4
and if he ever plays e5 then d5 is very
good
so he he can't clearly improve his
position but also white can't
clearly
improve his position
so that's why i played h6 and i can also
play h3 but
um
i knew that this f4 idea was extremely
dangerous and i decided to to go for it
um
although i
i don't know if what i did was correct
after but yeah queen d7 i think was a
really good move because i was more
considering queen c3
rook d2
and queen a1
it looks a bit strange but he does
paralyze all my pieces
and then i thought maybe d5 is very
interesting and very dangerous for him
um but this was also difficult to
understand because
uh my pieces are kind of hanging um
you know i always have these ideas of
bishop b2 and some attack on the king
side but if he plays like bishop c4 here
i didn't see
um
how i was better so i was mostly
considering b2 you just simply take on
d1 instead of yeah take on d1 i think
he's even getting better there i was
going to tag on c4 rook d3 and some sort
of
complete mess which i
i was trying to figure out while he was
thinking and then he surprised me with
queen d7
at first i thought this can't be a very
good move
but
i thought a long time here i was mostly
considering uh e5 yeah
that was our focus as well yeah it's
very risky of course because i give away
all my squares but also very dangerous i
just
you know i'm going all all in for the
attack uh i think knight d5 is forced
rook c1 doesn't work out although it's
very tempting and here i was thinking
rook f2 is interesting
because i the immediate like trying to
attack doesn't work out if i play
let's say knight to h5 instead of rook
f2
then he has a very strong move i think
g6
uh
bishop d5 gh5 and
and i think this was the critical moment
the engine was proposing after g6 g6f5
yeah i considered it but i couldn't make
it work
um
sorry to interrupt katarina actually won
her game and bounced for something a
playoff second playoff of the day we'll
have it later today
okay and after f5 you said you were
doubtful i i didn't think it worked i
was calculating something here involving
gh5 but
i don't remember what it was
because we were looking at these
positions with bishop h6 and queen h5 we
thought it was good for you actually
strangely enough yeah
um i don't know it could have been i
really thought this was critical but
after thinking for like 40 minutes
spending all my time on e5
i couldn't quite make it work um and i
thought the end game would be a bit
better for me but
once we got there
uh it looked like absolutely nothing and
then i started to outplay myself
he defended very very well yeah
absolutely i think his his moves are um
i mean he was very confident here his
moves are
uh are pretty much forced he has to take
this pawn
and like d6 instead of rookie a was the
most critical move but after d6 rook d4
knight f5 rook d2 visually it looks nice
you get your knight to f5 but the rook
on d2 is so strong and that his knight
comes in my d-pawn is
is more weakness than the strength so
he's he's not at all worse here perhaps
even knight b7 after d6 yeah very often
he has knight b7 just grabbing
but after d6 knight b7 i thought rookie
8 and 94 was strong
um
yes kind of rookie king h794
i thought it was strong but maybe it's
also a draw
fabby thank you for joining us we've got
some games that are about to end and uh
good luck tomorrow uh in the match thank
you for joining us absolutely and of
course the game that has to have our
attention is the one between jeffrey
shang and wesley so let's go straight
into it
as this one is of course an important
game and it is jeffrey strong that's up
a pawn
it is an opposite color bishop end game
which gives wesley some hope for a
defending this one but
it is a very good pawn on a5 and it's a
very good font on f3 that's going to
keep rolling down the board also the
activity difference between the rooks is
very significant
i love getting
yeah i would love setting up just rook
b6 trying to keep uh
the pieces and then black is bringing in
bring the king and as you say
rock and roll with the f pawn
and remember jeffrey must win this game
he lost the first one he needs to tie
the series and then
take his chances in the playoff the move
king f7 played he's deciding where the
rook goes time situation is currently
four minutes and 25 seconds for jeffrey
xiong only a minute seven
for wesley you can see it right there
not a lot of pressure on wesley uh you
mentioned the the difference between the
rooks especially
if i'm in wesley's shoes i want to play
the move bishop c4 and rook b8 i like to
play both of those moves so that i can
activate my rook a question that's very
common in this kind of end games
if we trade rooks
is this a draw yes are you sure no
but it's my only chance right black i
would like to if you if you propose to
me right here right now let's try it
right that's right you could earn a
trade rook so i said okay i'll go for it
i think it's an easy win i think it's an
easy win the pawns are too far apart
right it's important that the h-pawn is
a good part it's a good pawn it's a dark
square pawn for the bishop remember that
the bishop also has an excellent square
on d2 where it defends a potential f4
pawn it defends the a5 pawn and it
blocks the d-pawn when you have a bishop
that does all of those
yeah you're in a good shape yeah
add up all of the pros of your position
they're pretty darn good now he's just
played not rook d6 not rook b6 but he's
played the move rook h6 going after the
pawn and
this is good
well this is the opportunity that uh
wesley was looking for get some activity
for his pieces he played bishop c4 very
quickly
and uh i'm expecting rook to be eight
rook b6 this one's definitely winning
right no rook is on sorry sorry sorry he
already took on h5 yeah yeah he played
rook takes h5
i meant you give just bishop c5 that's
that's he has done it yeah he's done it
rook b bishop c5
you don't have a clear way as black to
improve your position actually yes you
get the rook to b1 but what after but
but i don't i i'm not
i i i disagree that i i do get to
improve my position i would love to put
my rook on b2 okay i put my rook on a2
so my rook is better on a2 than it was
on a8
and the cost of a pawn at the cost of a
second pawn yes but at the same time uh
your king could potentially come under
fire mr president of the palm graves
assistant exactly there's two extra
funds two extra extra bars this looks a
great winning chance this year
i'm not sure i needed to move king g6 i
don't see how that improved but i do
like the idea of rook to b2
well
check i think which makes no sense to me
that is a weird check forcing the king
to f2 well he he's going to play rook a1
and and and put the question to the
bishop where's the bishop going to go
i'll put it on b6
and then can i play no no no you can't
play d4 because the roomba defends the
pawn on a5 good point good point
good point
h4 is coming
wait a minute with the current time time
situation i feel this one is hopeless
hopeless right but it feels hopeless one
way or another king g3 is widespread
moose comes so easily
h4 is an automatic move against most
things exactly
okay i think that uh the the extra pawns
is too much now yeah very good yeah
meanwhile anna satonski also forcing a
playoff wow
what's up
uh forced victory for anna to to uh keep
in the event and she
does it with the black pieces king f6
crazy
two on-demand wins
remarkable
in the women's section they both won wow
and we might see a third one right now
and we might see a third one right now
rook e1
and as you say you know push him get the
pawn to h4 rookie one has a very nice
threat and that is rook a1
yeah that's a nice threat actually
because if i exchange the rooks
with three past pawns i should be
winning
yes uh no argument for me on that
he's he's hoping
that his d-pawn d4 d3
will give him something but rook a1 wow
bless you thank you
kazoo tight as we said 24 seconds i
don't see where the 34 seconds right now
oh i see the h pawn wait wait i see
where the h is wait wait wait wait
rookie four how how do you deal with
that uh you're saying e4
is very stressful
think rookie ford just finishes the game
and he spotted his as well uh
oh look at that look at that move wait a
minute we didn't see that we've got a
check and some kind of perpetual right
if you take on d4 rook g2 king h4 rook
h2 is the weirdest perpetual hour but
it's a little but i will start with
rook to f4 check correct okay
and then i will play king g5 yeah that
doesn't help wait this bishop f1 wow
wesley what a resource
what is going on
is he gonna save this how do you
continue here
that's actually a very good question oh
my goodness bishop f1
uh
with counter play against white's king
and that has caused has
real stopped there for jeffrey we missed
this too a full stop for g okay so i
give a check on f4 first king g5 and
then i give another check on g4 and i
take one h5 and then i take on d4 and
finally i have king of four to give you
a check
so check f4
check on f4 king g5 check on g4 king
back to f5 that's a good move
and keeping your king in that perpetual
zone that's a problem
but i'm also not entirely sure that the
other end game is winning king takes h5
might be because remember it's the wrong
pawn now right on on the a file
no it's the wrong pawn yeah you just
bring the king all the way to the other
side i'm not sure i'm on time but oh
you're in time for sure okay
but i think from a practical point of
view a king f5 is so much easier
and wesley sensing that his opportunity
magically appeared
grabbed it what a concept bishop d4
rookie for bishop f1 who suggested
rookie four terrible moves everybody
everybody not me i didn't see it i was i
just i just jumped in the bandwagon
i just i was thinking rook a1 and get
your rook behind the pass pass apon
was the way to go
how do you get out of this this is so
ridiculous this is ridiculous perhaps
bishop c7
but then allowing that d-pawn to uh roam
down the board i mean that's not
there is a bishop d a check but then i
take on h5
exactly and you gave up the attack that
you went and he's done it but this is a
completely different scenario it's only
two pawns the rook on these on f6
threading a
six maybe maybe he's trying to set up
his own uh mating net king f4 and some
attack again but this wax king this
should be a theoretical draw by this
point right i did take a very
and by the way that uh d pond is still
on the board the d4 pawn could really
give uh wow
nice
remember jeffrey doesn't have the option
of drawing this game he needs a win or
he will go back home to dallas
dallas cowboys
crap peace be upon them
that's not nice yeah sir
no i'm a dallas cowboys fan and i always
have problems
like this yeah yeah
but where
what what what what does this move do
what what what is there some checkmate
okay am i finding thinking
[Music]
is screaming to be played right with d2
next move exactly rook a2 d2 and also
that i can give my
check a check on a4 right and he's yeah
he's done it
no way is wesley wiggling himself out of
this one i tell you they just need that
little window of opportunity and they'll
crawl right through and save the game
that's incredible so what if i go behind
pawn rook to d6
i think that's a very good move for you
for jeffrey to make actually but
i i could go
t2 right you can go d to king e3 and now
rook a3 yeah
[Music]
trying to make a draw trading off the f3
pawn at this point
what jeffrey should strive for is a rook
and bishop versus rook endgame oh man
that's a sad thing to strive for
considering the position he had but he
has to but at this time i really feel
like if you gave fabi for example these
top players fabby wesley that ending
they'll draw it
it's not that easy i know it's not
impractical to and i've i've won it
myself on numerous occasions in fact but
it really is a draw and if you know what
you're doing uh it's not a difficult one
right
yeah it's a surprisingly easy draw when
you know it but it feels that everybody
that gets into it doesn't know
like somehow they i actually wasn't
sasha's
grishak somebody in one of the rapid
events lost it
very recently and it was a good player
and remember when wesley had a minute
against
like an infinity amount of time no more
for the first time uh
jeffrey has fallen behind there's no
there's no way these moves help what
white's calling us
no way f7 and thank you for letting the
king back right
exactly where's he going
these are not useful moves for uh
for jeffrey
i'm sure he has some deep ideas but they
by the way again this kind of la
challans
uh
yeah very easy okay so he wants to uh
but i don't i don't get it what do you
think she has bishop e2 you should be
doing e3 e d2
king takes bishop d1 and
you take and i you get skewered and now
gets cured king d1 and
we're going right into it
too if i started wesley definitely saw
it like
you don't play bishop e2 without seeing
that right exactly
d2 and he's reaching for it yeah he's
reaching for it he's done it
and give him
the queen
give me the queen
oh
wow
jeffrey unfortunately is going to be
returning to dallas because this is an
easy easy draw he's not actually
returning to dallas because there is a
blitz store that's right
that is very true
all the participants that are getting
eliminated in this event are going to be
playing in that one welcome to stay
around and play in the blitz i think
mandated not welcome
i think they're contracting well if he's
going to be around i'm going to say
jeffrey come and join us on the show i
mean he's a
great insider also part of the contract
i you put the king on d5 he put the king
on c6 you give the rook for the f-pawn i
understand i was a little bit surprised
by the move king e6 i thought he would
just play rook a4 and not allow white's
king to go anywhere
no but you just go king d5 here again
and you're saying make a make a
they're just going to give up the rook
it's a wrong color pawn right true
i guess it doesn't really matter
the pun doesn't make progress
and yeah i think jeffrey's just going to
give up well guess not
king g6 f4 rook a4 i mean every move
right yes every legal move in this
position is equal is equal
that's one of them
oh man this is disappointing for jeffrey
i mean he clearly had this game won he
did the hard part and it feels that out
of nowhere
one mistake rook e4 allowing magical
counter play with bishop f1 a sudden
perpetual out of nowhere heartbreaking a
hard break this is a real heartbreak and
then you combine that with yesterday
with yesterday and uh from a dead
winning position
with just
an extra second or two on his clock
he would be
in the champions bracket
what a heartbreak here but wesley's got
this under control kudos to wesley what
a resource he just
finds things out of nowhere
that fighting spirit to claw his way
back down from that position i i've seen
this tenacity i mean it's almost like
the honey badger and he just finds
as does hikaru nakamura time and time
again whenever i think hikaru is really
really on the edge
he comes up with uh with stuff that uh
you thought no way no way wait a minute
uh look at this he's wrong-footed wesley
but rook before
probably there were other drawing
options too but rook b4 is certainly a
good one you're not probably every move
that's not rook f4 and rick
exactly
exactly
all right we're just waiting here for
the handshake this game should finish
pretty much at any moment
exactly king f6 bishop c3 check king g6
and you're not making progress
nope
it's time a factor by the way what is
the clock situation i mean leslie has a
minute a minute versus three three
not not an issue at all for players of
this caliber no
bishop b1 king f6
and i think that's a threefold on bishop
you won
and
yep
draw agreed between jeffrey shaw and
wesley so will not agree they had a
threefold
wow what a heartbreak for the youngster
i mean completely winning position right
he had done all the hard work several
pawns up
and and we will analyze that but of
course we have an important game in the
championship bracket they're playing on
increment now it is irena crush against
begging tokyonova a strange position
where black has the pair of bishops
against the rook and the knight
passport two passports i would almost
always take blackout oh no question
about it what do you wow
uh
two bishops and two pawns versus rook
and knight that pin on the eighth rank
though that's that's what
that is what's keeping irina alive uh
because this bishop gets to d6 i don't
think you hold the position no not at
all of course not
but how do you untangle uh king h7 g6 g6
or queen these six to start off
six makes sense king
i'm thinking i hate being in this pin
come on guys king h7 g6 bishop g7 solve
that issue
then
you're just going to win with these two
connected past pawns this knight is very
useless
truly right right i know i mean it needs
it needs an anchor like f5 or it has
zero anchors
and she's going for the king yeah i like
this movie king h7 followed by g6
good training coach
yeah i don't know about that but i don't
know
take the compliment king h7 g6 bishop g7
solve
the pin
you said put the bishop on d6 i say put
the bishop on e5 and let's not forget
because we're switching between time
controls so often they're actually
getting 30 seconds every move because
they are playing classical chess they
are in the
champions bracket so they have a bit
more of a leeway to get down to their
last few seconds and then gain
additional time knight to d3 where is
that knight headed
well it was doing if you feel good on f4
on on e5 it will at least be
attacking the bishop on c6 and that's a
good move that is a good move
that feels like a grand master
now you have to kind of hide that king
right because 95
is going to come with the threat of
queen d3 it feels like and also just
taking the bishop right
g6
so knight e5 is the best way
for
arena to
disrupt her opponent from getting this
bishop on g7 and eventually uh pushing
the a pawn so knight e5
bishop
d5 right yes bishop d5 i assume bishop
d5 here
yeah instantly played
funny yeah
it's funny i i don't know why i had the
blockade
i think it's tiredness but bishop e8 i
thought was the idea
you know you're gonna go bishop to e8
you're going to go bishop to g7 and then
you know you move the bishop but bishop
d5 is course but much more active square
and things are uncomfortable the thing
about this position if you analyze with
an engine if you are one of our fans and
we love all of you that also analyze
with an engine it might not say it's
that bad for white
the thing is that practically speaking
it's so hard it's really hard to play
this with white your bishops are always
threatening something you never create
threats with the knight alone the knight
is always getting kicked around and if
that wasn't enough the pawns on the
queen side are always threatening to
advance precisely so f2 f4 which is a
middle decision very committal she
needed to anchor the knight
and make sure that it it stayed
active right
bishop g7
that's automatic automatic
and again uh
although they are getting 30 seconds uh
a move yeah 42 seconds for irina cruz
and a minute 11 for begging
[Music]
okay the automatic please yeah
let's go
not too much to think about here
all right
make your coach happy and don't spend
two minutes on this one
and funnily enough this is really not a
a
move to spend any time time because
bishop g7 is just
so
picture perfect can you have this baby
g7 come on begging
we are all expecting you no
what
wait what what is that move no that just
looks ugly
i don't even know if it's a good or bad
move it just looks ugly it i agree
wholeheartedly with the with the ugly
look it might not be a bad move though
how how do it's confusing it's a
confusing booth because
honestly white king is weaker than
blacks the kingdom h7 will never be
reached so i will not trade queens
exactly i'm thinking bishop g7 and queen
d6 and you start start pushing yeah
what she wants to go to c8
that makes sense
that actually makes sense
i could definitely get behind that move
but okay you are
inviting the the move bishop e6 which i
think
everybody would
jump on
bishop e6
stopping queen c8
gaining a tempo against the queen uh
yeah i don't see anything carrying
bishop g7 no real tactics there right
well the one thing that maybe queen a3
does have going for her
is she is thinking that maybe she put
her bishop on d6
yeah so that
first of all we are lined up on that
diagonal
and there is the potential that the king
on g7 could actually
be be better placed on g7 that's how i
get made it i know but evidently six the
queen lands somewhere in the eighth rank
why did i do that but bishop d6 here
there is yes exactly at this moment
there is maybe some something to be said
about it right yeah yeah
it's not completely
um yeah that's how you usually get
checkmated exactly exactly that i i
would have put the bishop on g7 agency
right i like queen b4 just create an
immediate threat
win d6 she really wants to exchange
those screens but
she believes in the endgame power of the
two bishops bishops yeah
although
if i take immediately
no i don't want to take this on d6 right
this is a very awkward time to take
yeah right the bishop comes with a tempo
g5 comes from the tempo yeah only queen
f3 is the most natural choice right
queen f3
yeah
or queen v1 maybe queen queen b1 hits
the pawn on b7 i can get behind that
does it there's bishop d5
but queen b1 queen d4 might be a problem
now with the centralized queen as we
were mentioning it's just so easy to
play with black because black every move
that we don't consider it's still an
okay move whereas white is so close to
blundering in every position i think
bishop g7
i think she's going to play queen b4
because i mean
it's a natural follow-up to what she's
been doing which is
trying to force the trade of queens
makes a lot of queen before dust forces
yeah but queen before this particular
position takes takes rook b8 right and
then you have some issues bishop d5
there should be five knight of seven
that's a good time to sacrifice the
night when uh my pieces are all hanging
hanging yeah
and then you have to calculate a five
eighth and then we then we fight right
then and then here we go here's the
final stage
very happy because this is his grundfeld
ending yeah yeah with the pawns right he
gets the exchange down but he gets these
two connected past forms but i think
we're gonna go through something like
this because otherwise you just lose
your queen side
again uh the f4 pawn is now hanging
there's nothing to think about here for
irena she has no choice she she cannot
move her queen to e8 and allow queen for
check again a practical mistake easy to
make as a grandmaster there's only one
move but you spend all your time on it
you should not do this three seconds
what what
she just missed queen takes f4 that
would have been resigned what the spot
on the spot on the spot on the bottom
unbelievable
what a turn of events and i thought she
played queen before recognizing there
was no
way to avoid the queen trait because of
queen f4 but she played king g7 like
i this is what it's all about guys
why do d3 played with three seconds on
the clock and now the queen is dropping
back to d6 to keep no e7 come on you've
been hunting that
just go to
no
e7
should play these six
no no you're right no it's a student uh
i can i cannot believe they both missed
queen r4 we didn't have one
but it was just resigns right like you
immediately respond on the spot on the
spot oh my goodness
and arena definitely well okay now in
this second
time
we know how this goes but you still got
queen e8 you're not going to exchange
the queens because we know irena doesn't
believe in the end game absolutely she
does not and that's why she's been
avoiding it is funny how stubborn both
of these players are on this remarkable
[Laughter]
but sometimes it happens it happens
right that one player and there you go
it's trying to achieve something and it
convinces the opponent
that they're right that they're right
yes even though they might not be
especially at the moment of queen before
right because at that precise moment
what black species were hanging and rock
band immediately wins upon exactly by
the way bishop to d7 here
if you go queen to d8 then i can go
bishop to b5 and
that i would force the things she's
going for it i think she's going for it
bishop d7 on the board
it is
remarkable remarkable
the way they handle this position is
remarkable oh dear oh dear
missing is queen f4 this is not a
euphemism it's not they haven't handled
this badly except for you know missing
queen of four but it is just funny how
they're so convinced about whether they
should or should not go into the end
game
right and again
at least she's playing fast she's up to
two minutes and 24 seconds that is very
good very very good but that queen is
seven king g7
goodness that was great this is this is
how coach coaches die early i'm gonna
have a field day with her tonight
how can you play king g7 so quickly
because she had been thinking about
almost every move with a few seconds
queen before queen you play queen b4
you're hunting that queen for a specific
reason and that is because you're also
attacking the f4 pawn right i mean that
was insane
still crush is under a lot of pressure
she's very unhappy with her position you
can take a look at it
her face expression says everything and
and honestly it's still a terrible
position for white
uh because this version of the end game
looks pretty nice it does indeed you've
been hunting the queen just take it
train i don't take it
queen takes d8 do not get mated with
bishop e7 that will uh
that would be
be terrible so queen takes d8 rook takes
dea a5 do we immediately set
yeah i think i think we start running
right
because the bishop on five is doing a
great job of defending d7
and how
okay we've done that with unlock but do
we do b5 do we do a the thing is b5 rook
a8 immediately loses a pawn right
good point good point so i think you
have to start
with a5 so that on rook beta have bishop
e4
i don't know how solid i am with those
spawns because the rook can still
try to harass so i i'm wondering should
i put my bishop on c5 as a way of
prepping b6 and a5
uh should i be thinking about g5 also
well she's gonna chase the rook away
first i'm not a huge fan of this move
simply because i think the rook pretty
much anywhere else is better than on d8
because the bishop on f5 is defending d7
but at the same time i'm thinking that
the bishop
is pretty much better anywhere else than
f8
that is true though that is true that
was why i was thinking about bishop c5
bishop v4
even like i said i was considering
should i be playing for g5
yeah maybe
maybe the bishop belongs well you
mentioned that the bishop is actually
pretty decently defending d7
and so
maybe
and
i think that's that's how we fight
that's where we're going
okay so bishop to e4 rook c8 bishop to
d6
how do you like them
i mean black is definitely about trying
to win oh how often do you think black
wins this i think most of the time i
think most of the time i
i mean
just that reminder that we do have
playoffs later today coming up
at six yes uh probably not before but
maybe
and
by the way for those of you uh on
twitter you can join our conversation
ask
your favorite commentators any kind of
question that you would like
we're all knowing but we don't share
everything okay
you have to go bishop before right now
yes what is she thinking about
now we have to play bishop e4 because b5
is going to exist
for some strange reason the way she was
holding the bishop wasn't intuitive to
me that that wasn't the move of bishop
e4
you know some some players sometimes you
know guide
there was almost like well i don't know
i've noticed that some players play with
both hands i i can't do that no i don't
i i can only play with my right hand but
some players actually use their left and
sometimes it looks a bit awkward exactly
i always had this impression that
really really fine
players of a very high
grand mastership
they have this beautiful flow with their
hands uh
and
what you're saying is we have beautiful
hats then
i played vasily smislov
for the first
time and he was rumbling stumbling and
bumbling
making a mockery of
of how to move the pieces knight
z4 what happens on b5 here
you have to be careful yeah there is a
rookie that's a rookie
yeah yeah
so you have to get that bishop off e7 it
seems like maybe c5 or b
d
five shot to d5 just tickle the knight
and by the way bishop d6 is on my agenda
if i can ever hit the rook on b8 and the
pawn on f4 is like
yeah baby well the problem with bishop
d5 what if i
okay this is very counterintuitive but
what if i go knight a5
i want to play bishop d6 and now rook to
d8 and then i want to take that pawn
gear
g3 and bishop c7 right rook takes d5
defense a5 russia takes c5 oh my
bishop's on d5 why did you put it on you
put it somebody put it on you just
played
okay so that's one way we don't win
but bishop d5 knight a5 okay you force
me i'll play b5 but it's very important
to take the bishops off at least one of
well one of the bishops off the e file
and she's going for that bishop d5 but
by the way when you put your knight on
a5 which is a terrible and she's done it
she's done it quickly i i play b5 that
knight is into sushi i get it but rook
b6
[Music]
no wait a minute no no no no
b5 rook b6
bishop c3 rook a6 b4
the knight's not going anywhere but but
you're losing your bishops yeah
hold on i don't want to do this i want
to
i want to get the pawn
on f4 how do i do that
how do i get the pawn on f4
maybe you have to go for this line yes
sir the one that you were mentioning
with the with the sacrificing the a pawn
and she's going for it she's going for
it rook to b6 okay so how does the line
go
rook to
bishop c5 right
correct rook a6 b4 exactly right the
rook's somewhat controlled here actually
not somewhat controlled no it's totally
totally dominated why the knight is
dominant it's like a cosplaying puzzle
yeah and the king is dominated because
the king can't go to g1 or f3 bishop c5
is a big move
rook a6 b4
you can't move and but can black's king
join the frame yeah glorious charge
but you know you could you could start
with b4 right it's the same well then
you have knight c6 ideas
oh
but then i can go bishop c5 after yeah
you can start with b4 as well yeah
at least it feels like it but in any
case rook takes a6 bishop c5 yeah that's
the key right
once you take on a6 bishop c5
controlling b6 square
what happens if directly b3 here rook b6
bishop d8
maybe rook b5 b2
i take it and i fork your rooks of your
bishops yeah oh my goodness oh you take
on b2 bishop takes a5 rook b5 hits the
bishop d5 hits the bishop on a5 with the
knight is right now very good point we
had that nice tactic in um i think it
was alice's game
where the rook comes to d2 and hits the
both yes
yeah she's gonna go for b3 but this one
seems like it's just
actually yeah this looks like a draw
after the b6 right but bishop to c5
you really see the magnificence of these
two bishops in an open board marcus
needed yeah controlling the rook on a6
as well as the knight
and rook b6
well i i tell you arena didn't have to
be asked twice she almost is playing as
if like yeah this was always a draw
i don't think she really had an
awareness of how dangerous the position
was for her bishop c5 yeah bishop c5
would have been a huge move but this one
seems to be fizzling out by the way what
is the current status of two bishops
three pawns versus rook and three pawns
that was magnus against karjakin right
world championship matches she has to go
bishop d8 right now i mean
okay and she goes for it with four
seconds on the clock i was about to say
did i say magnus crossing
magnus karjakin yeah
uh okay so
why was bishop i mean you can even just
go rook b3 here and call it a day
yes
that is the simplest way of doing it
rook b5
yeah b2 and then no but b2 rook takes b2
and take on b2 and you get the same
position and then i i win the f4 pawn
you win therefore
probably should be an easy draw that's
very easy right yes especially if you
take g2
but but it's only white who plays for a
win even in that position
it's a it feels like uh
if this
classical game somehow became a rabbit
yeah yeah it feels like one of the other
templars right i mean
i
lost the classical feeling a moment ago
there
uh
when she didn't play the move bishop c5
by the way i was shocking that she
didn't
play bishop c5 because looking paralyzed
paralyzes quite completely
it is beautiful this concept right where
the bishops just crisscross control the
board
if arena had any kind of sensing of the
danger she would have played rook b3
and said let's get out of here you know
rip me through it but
there's only one pawn left she might be
thinking how do you try now that i'm up
on exchange exactly uh good point well
she is a professional she understands
the chances whenever she sees them and
she sees one right now no no no
let's get out of here let's get out of
here rook takes b3
and there is no other move but bishop b3
because why would you ever suffer after
bishop
goodbye that doesn't make sense right
if we see bishop c7 somebody yeah
somebody needs a
christian was just going to go upstairs
yeah
okay and this is a drug and this is a
draw what a fight what a fight here
between christian and tokyo nova this
was a long one i i think wow kirsch is
going to be saying how lucky she was on
this one truly
as we expect g3 and eventually the
players will discover a way of making a
three-fold repetition again just to
remind everybody
in this american cup there are no draw
offers oh the players have to play the
king versus king 50 move rule three time
repetition or a stalemate and you were
saying we never see stalemates
one day one day we will one day
uh and just to remind everybody we have
two victories in the um uh champions
bracket but in the elimination bracket
we'll be having how many playoffs we
have uh at least we have we'll have
three playoffs
came back against rio yangyan yes she
did and satoshi came back against the
rulator akiru and
in the guys we have ray robson playing
against sam sam shanklin
and wesley won his game so jeffrey says
goodbye he is actually the first player
wesley drew his game sorry wesley drew
his game jeffrey's actually the first
player eliminated from the tournament
he is indeed yeah
and
once again considering how close he was
to going on in the chat that's just so
it's unfair like chess is unfair chess
is cruel
and then you die there you go i learned
i learned
i mean but you have to experience the
cruelty
to realize the truthfulness
the thing is sometimes we forget yeah
and then we play and it's like oh yeah
oh yeah right now
how painful this is when i uh when i
blunder i mean from hero to eliminated
just like that right
no king to f3 okay
and we are working with the players
right now to determine the exact time
for the playoffs we might start a little
bit earlier since we had we were
expecting a six yeah we were expecting a
six o'clock but by the way g4 down
that's the move
that you've got really fast
very good right very good
you pre-move bishop takes g3 yes
and they cannot
clock after bishop g3 it must be a
disappointing result for uh tokyo nova
because she actually refused a
repetition earlier in the game as we
will see and then she went on to get a
winning position just to blow it in the
last minute i mean queen not seeing
queen ago is going to sting yes that is
going to sting yeah
ouch
a missed chance there for begging irina
can definitely consider herself lucky
surviving this one but kudos to her she
fought and she fought and she fought yes
and she managed to salvage this
important draw that means that tomorrow
she gives herself a little bit of a
breathing room a draw will still be okay
for her as well she'll be playing with
the black pieces of course and what what
a game here we had between these two
players and what a round overall we have
so many players come back in uh in the
elimination brackets
situations wow and three playoffs guys
we're all about excitement here at the
st louis chess club we're definitely
going to see at least one armageddon
today
this is going to be cool
it'd be wonderful you think so i don't
think we're going to see any arm again
no no no i'm going to go with uh the
typical zero for the typical zero now
we're gonna see one and it's going to be
i'm going to say ray robson and sam
shankland are going to be one of the two
one of the uh armageddons they just
can't seem to find any opening against
each other i tell you for for the
opponent when you're playing against sam
shanklin and you're thinking to yourself
okay
how do i get him into a position where
he's uncomfortable
that's challenge number one and
so far nobody's really getting those
positions against him and yeah
and it is
uh
the the time and he's such a studious
player because i i remember when i
played him in the 2013 us championship i
played knight f3 e3 b3 and i beat him
because he didn't really know the
structures and he just worked and worked
and worked like that will not happen
again and he's done that for like every
opening like every single opening at
this point you look at shanklin and
you're like
how do i even try right and that's a big
problem facing him yeah
true
and after match discussion it is still
going to be 6 p.m that we start the
playoffs so
we will be starting in just about 54
minutes
ray robson will be playing against gm
sam shanklin they have drawn all of
their games to get to this point a very
even battlefield between these two uh
meanwhile uh ring yang yan will be
playing against catherine demsova both
of them winning with the black pieces
quite impressive very one-sided games i
have to say this was not a fight in
either one of them uh in the other
playoff in the ladies section
stabilizato and anna satonski they
played a wild game on the first one they
played a wild game on the second and
starula just cannot seem to get a normal
position everything has been blown up
against alice lee
now against anna we'll see what this
matchup uh
waits for us this is gonna be really
exciting uh the results that on the
championship section today two decisive
games huge things the first one right
there grand master levon aronian he said
well i'm gonna try this petrov business
with white and lanier said dude i've
been analyzing this with the best of the
best of the best let me show you what i
know about the petrov one a
scintillating game just
killed levon right brutal attack on the
queen side and dominguez will only need
a draw tomorrow to continue his journey
in the championship bracket meanwhile
fabiano karana drew his game against
sam7 some interesting ideas some
fireworks but a very well played game
there for both that just kind of fizzled
unfortunately as it happened so often by
the way i was more impressed by sam and
the sense that fabi actually had rook v1
would be 2 rook d2 as an idea and he
said let me go and gamble with it and
sam said well i'm looking at this for
the first time and this is how i'm going
to defend any defendant very well very
very well and in the ladies section we
have alice lee just blowing tatev
abrahamian off the board perhaps the
opening was not a huge success for the
white player here but after that it was
cruise control yeah it was the hesitant
play of tata that got her into first
time trouble and then trouble on the
board so congratulations to alice i mean
while this marathon dude just finished
between irina crush and uh beg him tokyo
jonah this was a fight definitely beg
him is going to feel the sting from this
one she had the win on hand she just had
to take a couple of seconds to realize
queen takes f4 check was legal and that
would have finished the game but cruz
survives yet another day tomorrow she
will have the black pieces but a draw
will just center two playoffs instead of
eliminating and how are we feeling about
our picks not great after today's round
that's for sure because erroneous fell
under the sharp sword of lane
you guys like your chances
you guys like your chances what can i
say and understand the ladies understand
what you got to say and the ladies
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes yes yes
but for uh arenas fans that was like
yeah that was close that was a very
close one i'm glad we're
let's
let's do some predictions guys uh for uh
these matchups in the playoffs let's
start with robson versus shanklin who do
you guys have in that one i'm going to
go for it sure i'll i'll take shanklin
man the thing is that ray is such a
troubled addict that when you get him to
10 plus 5 it's like he's just at home
i'm gonna go with ray just because it's
a rapid game
i like ray because
you can't get into time trouble you're
already starting in time trouble you
only have uh 10 minutes but i do think
it's going to come to a
armageddon and i do think black is going
to win the armageddon a lot of
predictions who's going to be black yes
that's what i'm doing i got to see the
flip of the coin
so lockheed uh versus zatonski you don't
have to ask me right wow
yeah yeah uh
anna wow
anna's just she's all over the map at
the moment um
one guy lost four in a row and came back
on one with black on demand on demand
i'm gonna go with anna just because i
like the veteran and what can i say i'll
have to go with the slew students so
lucky though he does feel like she has
the sharper openings and she's getting
an advantage almost every single game
and the shorter the time gets the more
important that will be yeah but in
honest
this is another thing
when you are a time trouble addict
and then you realize hey man i already
started in time trouble it's a three
minute game
i mean then it's easier to play then you
just play
the position so
i christian face time shine clinton i
did picture sam shanklin the producer i
went with ray you went uh with ray and i
think alejandro went with ray as
for me this one is a complete coin flip
wow right i'm gonna go with rujen
i'm gonna go with the experience on this
one i'm gonna go with kacha kashkabi
just because
she just won her last game right
wins behind the sales yeah yeah i'm
gonna go with kashka yeah me too me too
because it it feels to i i mean i've
been in these playoffs a lot myself it
feels terrible yeah when you're in the
driver's seat you've got the win all you
need is a draw yeah and you let it slip
you're filled with one much worse than
your opponent
it's one one but but psychologically
i totally understand and we're being
told that
var akovian has picked shankland
starula and and themselves
interesting picks actually a unique
picks actually nobody picked like that
all right guys uh we're gonna come back
we will take a break we will come back
at 5 50 10 minutes before the playoffs
start we'll see you there we'll take a
35 minute break and join us then we'll
have fast action chess and you can't
miss it you just can't miss it
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome everybody we are here in day
number three of the american cup i am
grand master alejandro ramirez bringing
you all of the action of the legend
himself grandmaster yasser sarawan and
with grand master christian carrillo and
we are in playoff mode right now it is
the battle of survival for six players
right now they will be playing two games
against their opponents of ten plus five
yes and in case those games are drawn
then the armageddon armageddon but
within an hour and a bit we will know
who's going home and who is remaining in
this tournament let's take a look at
these matches that we have for you in
the championship section we have ray
robson against sam shackling still
fighting for draw so far exactly i draw
so far they're still fighting for their
lives meanwhile wesley saw has already
advanced jeffrey scharring is the first
player of the event to be eliminated he
will be joining us for the blitz on
april 29th but he is now eliminated from
the american cup 2022 a big surprise for
me because jeffrey what a great player
he is yeah we kind of expected him to go
deeper in this competition and then the
ladies in the latest it is the comeback
at four black victories today really
absolutely remarkable but riyan yan tied
against katria and nem sova in the rapid
games one two one both of them as i said
winning with the black pieces and
stavrou that solaquido
a matchup that we certainly didn't
expect in the elimination bracket so
early this is our seats two and three
facing each other but one of them goes
home absolutely
and our format very simple they play
against each other twice it is two
playoff games of ten minutes with a five
second increment and if they are tied
two draws or each one wins a game a
piece then we will have an armageddon
five minutes for the white side four
minutes for black and if black wins it
ends in a draw now importantly there is
an increment
starting on move 61
which jeffrey shum was so close to
making yesterday he actually did not
complete his 60th move the 60th move
would still not have given him those two
seconds he would have to wait until the
61st but he was basically two moves away
from eliminating fabiano caruana
are sending him actually to the
elimination bracket and actually jeffrey
is eliminated from the tournament
himself exactly that was where we were
saying my chest is so cruel it was
literally a second or two
longer if jeffrey had that extra second
or two he would be in the championship
bracket yeah absolutely and we had our
predictions before we went on um
break in the ring
against nem silva we have three for
kachika and we have christian one wise
guy one wise guy out there i myself out
there as usual
lonely
that being said i i will say that i
think it's a coin flip it is a point i
think and the shanklin robson we have
two players that believe that if he
starts in time pressure
he is a good player right robson but two
other players believe in the theory of
sam shanklin those are christian and var
very very nice and in the satonsky
versus solo quiru match we have three
and i'm the wise guy one wise guy
you're going with the experience on that
one yes sir i am i uh
but
again i do feel it's also closer to a
flip-up flip yeah yeah absolutely pick
them
after all they are they are seats two
and three they're super close in rating
right and
very very strong players both of them
full international masters
the advice that you gave uh your player
yeah we went up for a walk actually we
went uh down on euclid here at the
central west end and i just told sterula
that she needed to get her mental game
in because the most difficult part of
going into this playoff is that she
won first
and last second right and even though in
paper and math it just looks like a 1-1
yeah we've played playoffs we know
that's not how it feels it feels like
you lost
it feels like you're coming back from
behind and that you need to win what i
told her is don't force the first game
don't feel like you need to win the
first game because very often it feels
that if you're coming from a loss that
you need to win right but i told her
that's not true
this is a blank slate right take it easy
and we have guys
i'll try and we have starula there
making away yeah it worked because she's
laughing giggling off the storm and
she's getting ready for
a very very tense playoff game
absolutely and they're also with ri yang
yan who has had a topsy-turvy couple of
games today she really destroyed kashka
in the first game right in the second
game she showed very little
understanding of that spanish
truly
christian jump right in what are your
thoughts of these uh playoffs guys i'm
definitely having my eyes on that match
up very intense matchup between shanklin
and robson and what i've been seeing up
to this point in that match is that
shankland is simply dominating the
theoretical battle he has today he had
like 26 minutes against 10 minutes
for ray robson and we know that robson
is having some difficulties specifically
after yesterday's game against
leveronian he got completely trashed out
of the opening in their first playoff
match he lost that one
i'm seeing a repeat of yesterday because
i just see shanklin that's so dominant
both with white and the black piece in
the theoretical battle and i think
that's going to be decisive
um
christian if i can ask you in that
scotch where it really looked like sam
shanklin as you said 26 minutes he had
all of the advantages
was it one of those
uh advantages that was optical or was it
real that uh sam the first one the first
game yeah with this knight e5 when he
played knight oh it was
really nice it was definitely real let
me see if i can find that one somewhere
around here yes it was this one and i'll
just actually point out the moment the
big moment that
uh says it has so good for white first
of all this was his first thing rook
ac-1 which is such a natural move to
make of course he was just trying to
understand uh what the nuances are after
this move rook to c8 because rook to c8
and i think you are the one that was
mentioning you don't like this move
because it weakens the a7 pawn exactly
it was a bad move indeed according to
the engine as well so we know that
probably sam did not look at it during
his preparation he did play the most
natural move rook ac one and knight to
b8 i really uh have to command a ray for
finding these resources finding this
planet because if you sit on your hands
the problem is i'm going to go e3 bishop
f1 bb5
and that's going to be decisive
in fact that was the way to go right now
i know that sam knows this plan i know
that he uh he saw within his preparation
this idea of e3 bishop f1 and
transferring the bishop on the other
side he had to do it right now instead
of that he played the move knight to e5
so for example if you go e3 you're just
simply not in time and uh if i remember
correctly i think alejandro was on this
path of ideas with e3 dropping the
bishop back to f4 it does look like this
bishop could potentially get trapped but
whenever you go h6 i'm going to follow
up with h4 i'm going to stop you from
going g5 or maybe even g4 we saw that
idea in the wesley versus jeffrey sean
just making a bit of space behind on g3
and after e3 uh knight c6 bishop to f4
it's a very problematic position for
black because i have a clear plan and
that is to go bishop to f1 bishop to b5
and create this pin which is going to
force you to respond with potentially
something along the lines of a6 which is
going to weaken even more your pawn
structure you have to go something
like knight to a5 but now you're just
simply not in time to cover up all the
entry squares on the c5
rook takes c8 bishop takes c8 i just
move away with my queen and then later
on i'm going to jump with rook to c7 you
have to cover up all those ideas of b4
as well harassing your knight is not a
pleasant and fun position for um ray
robson and i have a feeling if we would
have seen
this position on the board sam would
have went on to win this game and we see
right there sam shanklin always focused
always ready
question as far as that
by the way because it was really one of
it was it it bugged me
that such a a visually attractive
position um
sam didn't do
really anything with it and ray somehow
made a very easy draw a perfunctory draw
on that that being said when you go into
the ten plus five and you're sam it
feels that you have less work to do
right that your opponent got into
trouble
you
review a little bit on what happened
there and tried to make a bigger press
but the line worked it did and then ray
has all these questions do i repeat the
line how do i improve it where is the
improvement i only have what an hour to
really look at it
it's not so easy uh of course we're
going to switch up colors yes and so ray
starts with the white pieces first his
white piece attempt was nothing he just
played a rookie one berlin didn't go
anywhere some knew everything 27 27
minutes after 20 moves of play and of
course and there are defeated of course
we'll repeat it e4 e5
that's the other thing about these top
players they are absolutely stubborn
in their opening beliefs oh they must be
they must be if you're a french defense
player you go down
on that hill you will die on that hill
and look at this are we going very
quickly this the whole line
yeah all the plates so they just played
all of this
let's see who's going to come with an
improvement it has to be ray
it has to be right it has to be ray yes
let's see where the improvement is
yeah all the same all the same as
their first game today
sorry their second game today
d5
all right
we're just waiting we're waiting
for the novelty
sam knows everything my goodness all
right
10 minutes and 51 seconds already at
least raise over 10 minutes as well
both know in this position but it seems
more or less well known are they just
they just repeat that
wow i mean the fact that the f2 pawn was
hanging and they just played g7 g6
without thinking without thinking and
just like wow
g6
interesting yeah because you could take
on f2 it is no right yeah you can take
on f2 with the bishop and with the queen
and they've both been played before well
94 was uh
the improvement let's say from the
previous game right yes bishop e3 was
played in the previous game yeah and now
we have queen e1 instantly queen f6 to
g7 just making room for the knight to go
to f6 so knight f6 rookie 8 um situation
is it stellar
it's pretty sick
it's pretty great i have to say sam's
shanklin's preparation
it really is impressive
it just knows everything and every line
very confident about uh all of these
variations
and just finds all these ideas right
queen g7
rook h4 played a very logical move here
by ray robson because it is attacking
uh h6 players
so the idea behind this movie from from
black's perspective black really wants
to play knight f6 attack the rook also
attacked the pawn on d5 so ray
anticipating that the knight is going
going to jump to f6 square let me get
rid of the arrows moves his rook in
advance so that he can actually
introduce his own threat
bishop h6
so now you have
is nothing there was a little bit of a
lull there really
the first one yes
for me that's rather instantly queenie
by has like three seconds he still he
still has more time than he started with
right he started with ten minutes and
five seconds he currently has 10 minutes
and 37. ray
not the time pressure that we saw in the
other positions now let's analyze here
white has a pair of bishops and more
space why is why not better
well
that's a very good question the problem
is that the desirable bishop h6 knight
to g7 the pawn on d5 as well as the pawn
on b2 is hanging
i don't really want to trade queens on
e5 queen takes e5 d takes e5 and i think
black's
center is rather mobile
and he's very
he has sufficient compensation for the
two bishops in that case and that is the
problem uh black has control over the e
file and if you do decide to take on e5
then which was played which was played
in d that allows black to build up that
majority with f5 potentially coming
followed by e4 and this is starting to
be uh quite destabilized as a position
and who knows who's better and i agree
and i think that's the reason we saw the
move bishop h6 i was starting to get
worried about this knight coming to dc
beautiful blockchain square that is the
much more desirable square is the d6
square knight uh
pardon me bishop h6 provoked knight g7
force knight g7
um now the other thing i start to say is
it's not just a two bishop's advantage
the strange thing is this rook is a
little bit like what are you doing
poking out on the h4 square if you want
to go rook to c4 bishop act things that
you want to go c4 at one day right yes
you do you want to use your right you
want to
utilize your majority on the queen side
with c4 and b4 i mean even even before
right away exactly even before right
away
on h4 we needed an excuse on the other
hand you are
arguably making uh
black's life a little bit easier
especially like you get an a5
or bishop d4 also not so easy to meet
bishop d4 not so easy to meet i was
just slightly slightly worried about c3
sam's still within his preparation rook
to e1 bishop d6 instantaneous
how do you beat this man i don't know i
don't know what happened after
rookie one bishop d6 yeah rookie one
bishop d6 played on the board on the
board yeah
now
robson is down to his last seven minutes
while sam shanglen 10 minutes and 49
seconds
and cruising how do you match that
at some point you have to pull the
brakes right yeah
exactly uh you you also were just
mentioning uh ali that you love to use
your uh queen side majority
uh by playing moves like c4 and b4 and
maybe on a very good day getting in c5
the thing is black is actually going to
make a very solid
blockade on the queen side and you'll
never
be able to use your majority if black
gets in moves like a5 and b6 again black
is looking to play his own f5 b4 f5 e4
majority and it feels just fine let's go
and check out the other
um playoff games this is riyang yan
against cathedral and himself we're
going to step away from the robson
shankling game just for a second it
seems to be a repeat of the spanish that
they had previously katarina winning
that convincingly but this is definitely
a better version than the previous game
for riyang she is down the pair of
bishops but she got the break d4 in yes
i wasn't necessarily convinced about
bishop takes f4 but she felt it was
necessary i always feel this knight on
f4 you take it the last possible moment
right
uh but she decided to take on maybe the
move h4 followed by g3 getting some kind
of bind on the king side
hard to say i hard to say i feel it's
about equal
yeah
one of the things
one of the
players that i've really admired over
the years shakira mamidara and he's
playing some of these e5
bishop g7 fianchetto uh positions
incredibly well i feel as as black and
he's actually
well
done great with the black pieces when he
gets his uh variations and by the way g2
g3
followed by d5 all of these moves come
with tempo but at the end of the day
this bishop on c2 says
general don't forget about me what's my
role you're going to put all the pawns
on light squares
i don't know is that bishop it's it's
strategically counter-intuitive to me
what is the long
term plan for white well white has to go
at some point c4 c5 and try to break on
the other side i i totally get that but
without a dark square with bishop how do
you it's a big problem right because h4
i was bishop h6 comes queen g7 f5 i feel
taking on f4 was a big mistake it made
black's life a lot easier yes
yes finish the sentence that's exactly
what happened now katya knows what her
plan is as we're seeing it
unfold bishop h6 queen g7 you get to
play in king's indian defense
style attacks and
white is a long way from playing c5 rook
c7 and splat
very long especially with the bishop on
h6 controlling c1 let's see what anna
zatanski has
played in her
well it doesn't matter what she played
in this game it matters how many minutes
she has she only has four minutes on the
clock while her opponent has 10 minutes
on the clock this is a huge problem
right now exactly as anna has once again
gobbled that catalan gambit pond
and
says come and attack me and your student
says
okay bishop h4 clearly an indication of
prep i'm ready
if you play g5 i am ready to sacrifice a
piece and let's go and c5 seems to be
the move that has finally got stavi out
of her preparation
stavie huh that's a nice nickname that's
what we call her at slu nice savvy stavy
and i mean it's hard for me to resist
the movie for here to be honest uh
resist the move e4 no on the contrary
whenever there's a piece that is pinned
as is the case now all you want to do
is
apply more pressure against the pin
piece and e4
prepping e5 is the way to go that would
that would be my absolutely first
instinct so after e4 you probably have
to uh take the queen away from that
diagonal with something like queen c7 is
that it the queen c7 allowing bishop
takes f6 it looks scary especially after
bishop takes pawn takes and i think i do
go e5 here
with or without queen d2 with or without
queen d2 i'm not really sure because
queen d2 is always a nice uh tempo but i
like it without because maybe maybe
queen g4 yeah especially if you take
uh
anna is really putting herself in under
incredible pressure here with the black
pieces it's
crazy and it's also this seizing the
defensive right right like come and
attack me i i believe in my defensive
pro but that's how she plays that's how
she plays the slice with black right
that she she's very
she believes in her defensive capacity
she's very provocative when she plays
chess i mean look at her repertoire
french defense petrov defense accepts
the gambit and the catalan that's how
she plays chess
yeah uh for very forceful
what do you have for us
let's get back to the ray robson versus
the game because i see ray robson with
less than three minutes on the clock
what
less than three two minutes and 59
seconds that's even the last time
wow
wow and his opponent with nine minutes
and 46. that's so crazy that is crazy
and the last few moves are a bit passive
he went from with a rook from h4 to e4
and then back to it allowing black to
gain this momentum in the center with f4
and potentially f5 and potentially e4
which comes on the board absolutely well
whenever you have a trump like a
majority you want to use it and f5 e4
and once again just boldly pointing out
the obvious white's majority on the
queen side is going nowhere
so i think that we give away we give up
on this plan right we go bishop c4 maybe
f3 we should be five volts play or
bishop somewhere and f3 i think to break
up the
break up the structure right the nice
team and i already have the two rooks on
the e file i think that ray is pretty
much telegraphing this idea of playing
f3 on the next move
okay i'm just wondering uh
but what are you doing do you want to go
to gate yeah do you want to go to dc
i was thinking actually do you know a6
bishop d7 i i wanted to ask the question
as well like okay put the question to
the bishop a6 are you going to go to d7
the thing is the bishop on e6 is very
pretty but i don't think it does
anything exactly yeah we just play
around around and so very quickly came
bishop a4 as ray does need to catch up
on time because he's really spotted a
lot now
on the clock now what you're saying is
that
white's intention is very clear he wants
to play the move f2 f3 in order to open
up the e-file i don't like being i hate
i hate being in pins
uh what can
sam do to get out of this pen let's say
b5 and rookie eight do you still want to
play f3
uh
i'm thinking that king f7 knight h5 is
on my agenda all right
i guess i'll play f3 right okay so this
is the question
now your structure do you we can't yeah
i think so
uh your structure is a little bit um
but at least i'm not facing these pawns
just barreling down the board right
for sure for sure
uh this two bishops doesn't feel like
that
big an edge uh
it doesn't feel like the the the two
bishops are flexing themselves am i the
thing is like if i'm not better maybe at
some point i just take on g7 right yes i
think at some point we need to you do
consider this you do have the parachute
right you might never get that breakdown
okay
yeah that is brutal yeah yeah yeah
okay so
we feel that sam
sam is doing
good
uh
anna played e5 what e5
i'm surprised she found this
this is wow this is some kind of prep
quincy two queens
queen c7 wait queen c7 what what can i
take on f6 yes yes and then d5 yes i can
also take on e5 that's the only way what
happens if i take with the pawn on e5
where it is through knight go probably
back to d7 but d7 bishop e7
correct i think i have to go to g4 in
this case because i don't want to see
that bishop on my doorstep bishop b7
bishop but also knight g4 might be
pretty good she does that
takes f6 i mean
how can you not want to capture yeah
that's true right
this this
uh and just destroy
the the pawn shield and she goes d5
she will oh my god but she's going to go
knight h4 f4
exactly knight h4
followed by f2 f4 and black's king is
crying
black doesn't have
even right now even if you get your
knight to b3 again it's like the bishop
on e6 very pretty very pretty what do
you do there you don't have a
continuation knight b3 not going
anywhere exactly
b5 okay that's a good move trying to
reroute that knight potentially to d6 i
like that
the knight h4 boom i like the knight b7
and f4 right you go f4 before the knight
can reroute
knight b7 on the board
kudos to ana realizing that the knight
on b3 made good
queen e2 that queen is coming to h5 i
can get behind that move too yeah
i understood it as an as a way of maybe
playing for the light square we're
playing for both play queen h5 and then
play
in any case knight d6 was
on anna's mind and she's done it and
queen h5 king to h7 okay
okay now it's f4 now if you're going to
put the queen on h5 in order to attack
the pawn on e5
follow it up f4 got to be f4 there you
go boom
now you got to defend the pawn on e5 so
i expect queen e7 exactly i don't think
guys too many glimpses
because they also have quickly not only
uh the pawn on e5 but also the square f6
because once we exchange on e5 that rook
is coming to f6 and i think that's why
you play rook f2 here with white right
rook f2 rook f1 sir please
look at fabby's games
could not be a noob could not be a noob
do not play the wrong road
rook hey two sir what a wild game crazy
stuff i love it love it love it and at
some point
find some sort of counter chances do we
have queen especially but i think 27
but you can see her counter chances
right she's going a5 b4
that's a lot of bots that is a lot of
pawns i mean it's slow but it is getting
there a5 b4 so let's go through the
motions rookway to a5
f2 now now it's a question because this
pontics seems like a very serious threat
but you could stick with a queen yeah
stick with the queen and see who's
faster before before
now i feel like but how does it work
takes and i go rook f5 oh she played
rook f2 another k2 come on
no style points queen e7
rook f 2.
okay
rook f2
well a5 is one way and it makes a lot of
sense to do that but g8 is another idea
that was also
a concern absolutely right rook g8
bishop g4
and rook jade will have to go back
probably with the queen because it is
getting trapped
and by the way just an update in the
other game sam shanklin is actually in
big trouble right we got to go there we
got to go there guys
show me show me the board show me the
board
what's going on here and these six
coming with check take on c7 this is
completely devastating let's have the 2d
board so we
we
can
catch
oven we have a good
rook takes c7 look at that it's a visual
the bishops the bishops they always
manage he didn't
put his rook on e8 to challenge the uh
file how did this rook
he played it voluntarily remember we
left it at this point b5 rook f8 he got
out of the pin good for him i was
expecting rook to come to e8 but after
f3 takes
[Music]
sam has missed rook takes i think he saw
rookie yeah yeah well he may have seen
rookie seven and then said okay but that
does nothing i'm gonna go anyway with my
knight but rook c7 clears the cobwebs so
just to explain it to our viewers if you
do take then i go rook check
a discover check by the bishop on b3
uh-huh oh that's the king has to do with
the situation and i think i take right
and then after for example move like
rook to c8
let's go in
rookie 7 paralyzing right
how do you win though
okay 7 bishop e3 bishop e3 is made
without the mate that is me mate is
coming the maid is coming for wow just a
second let me show alejandro what he
might have missed bishop e3 alejandra
oh it's your turn
good luck
good luck so
and we have by the way ana satoshi has
13 seconds but let's not switch around
and stay on this one this is a huge game
um rook t87 is still on the board a5
sam's realizing how much trouble he is
in right now well he's
desperately trying to do something to
uh throw rey off he's played the move a5
hoping that a4 will trap ray's bishop a2
a3 kind of is like a knee-jerk move but
race thinks i've got something even
better and has played i believe rook c6
is that on the board i believe he
is so ray says okay you can go a4 but
i'm gonna take your bishop and i'm gonna
take your pawn
and at the end of the day i'm gonna have
a
four versus one majority in the center
slash queen side was that the right
decision a3 looked pretty convincing too
and i like those though
it's pretty good rook c6 you you you you
wouldn't have gone with a3 here i like
i like when my work's no longer hanging
i understand i understand but it
but there was still no threat to capture
it after a3 we would have just
gone into that same variation rook c6 on
the board now
besides a4 i don't like i don't like
moving this bishop and allowing d6 with
check well you could try to go rook to
d8 right
rook to d8 maybe which was played
bishop g5 is one yes oral to e6 that's
another one or rook to e6 to really play
the move though a3 a3
it's funny if he had played a3 rook d8
rook c6 would have transposed what a
very strange way of transposing but this
does look very dangerous for the black
side i mean bishop g5 is coming
that's a very high it's going to be a
very big threat when rookie 6 was also a
huge threat i'm thinking i'm thinking i
want to unleash
this bishop right by playing
uh rook to e6 and d6 and then i'll be
threatening all kinds of checkmates
i'm supposing that sam is
hoping that bishop f4
will somehow
keep him in the game but ugh this is not
pretty
what does he play he played f takes g2
quickly king takes g2 i don't know if i
would have taken that pawn honestly
ft he took on g2 that's what i i thought
i saw a flick of the rest and the pawn
disappeared
there's no pawn on g2 and there's a king
on g2 and
i think he took the pawn
you're sharp today
thank you very much
let me just quickly she flagged in a
losing position she did flag but in a
losing position right all right third
result there okay let's jump back in
that case to the ray robson game we do
have f
three takes g2 king takes you to
wow i would have at least given her
bishop g5 and rook e6
some uh consideration but i mean ray has
22 seconds
not maybe not the time to make any
considerations you make a move right
uh and at this point
two minutes or so so
imagine
sam does play the move bishop f4 right
now he's trapping this bishop and
basically forcing its trade so bishop
you can go d6 check yes king h8
i'm assuming the bishop will trade
itself uh yeah but that looks very
dangerous also for black right oh i
and rook d7 played rook david seven yeah
he's waiting for
rook to e6 to
but what do you do against rookie six
kings f3 was played controlling that
control square i control the knight i
like it i like this move i love this
match i love this one and in fact i love
it so much that was probably why i
didn't want to see
uh it being played six on the board
six you have 98 i assume oh
yeah
yeah i think it took passive right i
know i don't know i mean it was strange
because it was the game of begum uh
against arena crush that was like bishop
d5 versus bishop e8 like i went passive
i don't know why
three seconds rook e6 knight e4 on the
board yeah and then he played h4
oops i thought he's gonna go for a
bishop before trying to exchange the
bishops but it seems like h4 was well h4
i like it it moves the pawn off pre
right of course to begin with but i also
like it just from the positional point
of view
of
restraining the majority that black has
on the on the king side maybe on a good
day uh i
look to use my uh
more active king but somehow he does
feel like sam is getting more chances
than he deserves more than we expected
more than we had
i thought it would be dead dead i mean
the main chassis has is that his
opponent has eight seconds that's a big
chance that's a big chance no matter
what your position is he's also down to
his last 40 seconds though
samus
really 30 seconds actually and those
steve and the difference is that ray
lives and thrives in this situation but
right now
yeah exactly excuse me king h8 that one
i would have never thought of he's
trying to get off this light square
diagonal he thinks that he can't
keep the blockade he can't maintain the
blockade that was why he's
he he moved his king he's anticipating
d5 d6 and hoping that his king will not
get blasted and bishop e3 on the board
before might be a threat b4 b4
a4 though never anticipated that because
it gives white a pass pawn exactly yeah
that's
that's being excessively held my bishop
is coming after the b2 pawn so you have
to be careful you can enjoy that part
i'm going to go a5
i cannot take that
no he's not going for it all right
taking him before first uh
i actually don't see the problem with a5
a5 a6 and okay b2 very nice right and a5
a6 a7 yeah let's put that pawn where it
belongs
oh by the way ray
ray went after the b
okay
i mean i'm not against it i just don't
know what this b-pan was ever going to
do
very solidly blockaded there yes
when i took d2 to eliminate at least one
bishop is on the board right now
no it is
and kind of inviting h5 by the way
okay
he doesn't want to see the move knight
d2 eliminating the bishop so i can
totally understand the move king e2
okay same amount seven is below
rate for the first time for the first
time eight seconds yeah look at this
check check
all right a six i think
wow rook cece yeah okay six oh boy
you're right yeah
sometimes i am
rook to b8 i like this counter attacking
that bishop yeah looking for that
activity
what do you do now i give a check give a
spike check that you gain time
bishop to c4 rook to b4
but then bishop e3 a bishop e3 oh my
goodness down to his last five seconds
right
tracking g7
we've got why is that king h5
nope
because it's scary that's why yeah it's
very scary but maybe they say wait
what's going on here can i take on d5
yeah
a4 d5 everything is hacking as it's all
about the clock with two seconds it's
just a challenge sam feels like he's
taking over right now well there's a lot
of pins in the position
bishops they should be fives of thread
remember the bishop c3 is a big move
right now
is it
bishop c3 you'll see three getting away
from that pin
any kind of trades and clarifying the
position check king f3
and riyan we're being told one of the
white pieces there against caterina so
we'll take a look at that game wait a
minute bishop to c4 that's a check
you're going to lose a piece but but
d2 d6 is going to be
dropping rook to e7 whoa what what what
if i take on king of seven no you can't
you
know
this is winning oh my gosh rookie song
oh rookie seven what oh he resigns
whoa rookie seven
it was
rey
is used to the time tree he's just
thriving it's not
something about a dark knight
when when ray went ahead on the clock
that was i thought that was more or less
but it wasn't the position the position
was actually quite okay i believe i
believe
take a look at yasser's board right now
yeah this is the final craziness and
that we got here here and we thought d5
is hanging
like let's start with that right d5 i
thought d5 was actually a4 is hanging
he took the pawn on a4 and after d6 king
f7
right here i was expecting this move
bishop c3 trying to trade some stuff off
yeah and still you know okay the game is
going to be decided by the clock but i
think that that would have been
safe safer much like for uh sam shanklin
sam went for check
check
and he ended up overlooking this
great shot wow what a difference wait
did he have a saving move instead of
king g7
fate was saving the game exactly
because now if you try to go rook 28 i
can cover with either rook d8 or bishop
to d8 right oh
that's heartbreaking it sure is one move
to make a fool of all of us in time
pressure and king g7 a huge blunder
exactly a huge buncher
and
well let's take a look at how anna lost
her game actually it was a mess her last
move is a blunder she's actually winning
in this position so the magic the movie
queen g5 here 10 seconds 10 seconds 10
seconds queen g5 in this position wins
but she sits there and the clock ticks
kicks and ticks and ticks it's a very
complex position you see the rook on e6
is forking her queen and the rook on d6
sorry the nine of these three seconds
three seconds oh my god my play i don't
know i know it's a replay i'm getting
stressed
actually there goes the clock
flag before she finishes to be fair fv6
is a completely losing move because fe6
check picks up the queen exactly but
what what a topsy-turvy game
crazy and wow
yeah if she so this is the point she's
got 10 seconds on a clock i agree
chaos on the board everything can go
wrong but when you see the move queen g5
first of all you get your queen out of
attack second of all you're setting up
your own ideas of queen takes f4 hello
thank you anything can happen it's a
three result game as you said after
burning her entire clock in fact losing
on time she did take and as you were
mentioning uh alejandro the very final
position uh white would be winning after
completely winning because you take on
f6 you take on c3 you take on a1 and
there's a and it's uh discovered against
the king
so uh time trouble deciding makes the
playoffs of all of us how did the other
game finish christian if you can show us
the the end of category and themselves
absolutely and i just want to point uh
this moment out after rook to e5 we were
mentioning bishop to c3 this indeed
would have saved black because it
simplifies the position it's just forces
simplification i'm pretty sure sam saw
this because i saw him reaching for the
bishop and then in the last moment
deciding go for rook a2 also another
important moment after bishop to e3 kh5
would have actually given the advantage
to sam a slight edge nevertheless with
this king coming down the board hitting
this pawn on h4 later on in the game
three connected passers well this could
spell trouble for white let's see what
happened in the game between rue yang
and nemtsova because we thought
huge mistake bishop takes f4 bishop
takes a4
huge mistake h4 was the right move and
this is a very typical idea because you
want to force this knight to move out of
f4 and the only way to do that is via g3
now the problem with g3 first is that
you're losing a pawn right so how can
you
improve on that well you first start
with h4 and then you go g3 open up this
diagonal you cannot venture with your
knight as black on h3 you're going to
lose that knight you have to go
backwards this actually the engine gives
a completely
decisive advantage for white so let's
see what happened bishop takes a four
big mistake and then it seemed like
nemtsova was building uh her advantage
the right way bishop to h6 this is the
move that you guys mentioned followed by
queen to g7 instead of that look what
she plea what she played a5 good move
still good move bishop to d3 bishop to
d7 makes a lot of sense b3 knight to c8
it doesn't feel like this is the right
direction where's she going well i don't
think he's go she's going with the
knight anywhere i think she wanted to
make some space for her queen to go back
but instead of that she should have went
back to g7
and the knight already on e7 supports
the move f5 so it's perfectly placed
let's see what happened knight to b6
what are you attacking what are you
doing here absolutely not trying to put
her knight on scene on d7 really yeah
that took a while
that took a while
as they're about to start uh
uh we'll just take a look at the results
once more yeah robson beach shanklin a
crazy crazy gang time complication uh
robson just tricked shanklin with this
move rookie seven winning a draw robson
moves on and shang clan well we'll be
eliminated
and meanwhile in
again a crazy game that was decided in
time pressure some relation to liquido
won against anna satonski same thing for
anna she's in a must-win situation or
she goes home and in the other game it's
katrina nemtsova she is yet again with
her back against the wall yet again she
needs to win to remain in the tournament
as we are about well we got started here
and zach's underway i'm taking a page of
lavon's book say all the english work to
get last time well let's try this time
right e5 c6 this has become a popular
choice
whoa e4 d5 yeah and look at these
two players they starting the latest and
greatest is the latest trend of this
line that played d5 wow
wow
h3 was well known it's a little bit of
an awkward development of the night but
you understand that long term you want
to corral this e4 pawn or force black to
give up his bishop exactly
it takes on d5 knight f4 is known
once again it's like
students are forcing you to
to
be up to date in the latest theory hey
coach look at this i saw this they they
they show me such nonsense sometimes
that i like i actively try to forget it
oh
the
the problems of being a chess coach like
alejandro you could write a whole book
oh my god you have no idea why you
should not become a university coach
bestseller
knight f4
basically uh sam says hey wait a minute
if it's my turn i'm going to play knight
takes d5 and it's going to be game over
because i'll have complete domination
ray went into a tank
after this expected knight f4 this seems
to be the how the match goes right sam
always seems to one operate right when
it comes to opening preparation
and then and then when they fight
wow uh so i'm a little bit surprised
in the tank what did you get the second
pawn on c4 if we captured i'm i'm afraid
it's 95.
knight takes queen e5 and then it's
queen e5 with or without i think
the trade i think you take first it
doesn't let's let's take first and it's
two pawns for the moment but okay and
then i don't remember so let's let's win
back one of them i think it i don't
remember at all
rook to c1 okay so what if i stop you
from getting that pawn b5
going to be greedy on this one
i like it i like the greed the greed
factor b5 bishop g2 maybe at some point
if i'm going to play
one exactly i will uh
i will
maybe queen to f4 is that an idea at all
i mean it would be if you don't blunder
your knight on d5 ah all right
bishop to g2 immediately yeah yeah which
is maybe why there was some
consideration for long castle but let's
not let's not go there
[Laughter]
not that bad of a move right it's not a
bad move right long castle
it's been a long day okay bishop g2 what
are you doing castles castles
two pawns but
clear compensation
lightweight six or knight to c6 let's go
nintendo six uh just put the knight on
the decent square
i don't know you still have to win the
pawn that's two pawns i i like the pawns
you guys are so greedy
i admire
you regardless of what everybody else
says christian b5 yeah
i i i i'm checking with the engine it is
long castle b5 a4
i'll take that as well knight to d4
maybe knight to d4 yeah i mean it's
starting to look quite good for wow
what choice does he have if you don't
take on c4
what do you do well he's gonna think
until he has like three minutes on the
clock and then and then he's gonna take
c4 but indeed if you don't take
knight takes d5 i mean if you play a
move like castles this is just
positional overkill in my view i just
think that uh black cannot play like
this
this is just dead i took it
yeah it took
this is just so
so good for white he pushes bishop on g
everything interesting
trying to remember his line plays knight
d5 it probably doesn't really matter
which knight
i think you have to take
so he after
a spell a thing
he did capture knight to d5 and again in
this case probably more precise than my
poor choice of knight c3 to d5 i am
threatening to capture this bishop so
therefore knight takes 62 it's
absolutely fine
and you said castles and i think sam is
about to agree with you
right yeah well bishop takes d2 is not
looking forward to this now
you don't want to put the queen on c5
right that's
um um i'm not sure i'm not sure i
wouldn't ah queen g5
ah that might be a problem queen chief
i don't know there might be some issues
with queen g5 by the way uh i just
heard that uh we have katja we have
christian on the on the case he'll show
us in a second
take it away christian it's katarina
nemtsova is just destroying her opponent
right now we just started the game
she hasn't thought for a second she
opened up that e file and right now
after queen to d7 knight coming on in
the center on e5 attacking the queen not
allowing black to finish his development
this one is game over the engine is
saying plus six right now wow it's like
heavyweight sluggers just landing these
uh haymakers against one another and
that means we're going to have at least
one armageddon guys well dude
don't jinx her yeah let her finish it
yeah yeah yeah yeah she has to finish
the job that is that's true but this is
so decisive it's like a local
christian's board there yeah a christian
if you just uh why is it what i'm just
simply going to do
it's white to move of course yes
lacks last move was queen to d7 now
knight to e5 makes a lot of sense you go
queen to d6 and now i can just simply
continue bringing more pieces into the
attack queen to h5 this is all shiro you
can try to go g6 but into h6 you can
never take this knight on e5 because
bishop d4 is coming or bishop to g5 the
game is over the game is over she's
thinking right now if she finds knight
t5 followed by queen to h5 this is going
to be one one and we're going to see
at least one armageddon that's crazy
knight e5 just as a move that plays
itself you attack with a gain of tempo
against the queen on d7 uh it's too easy
queen e5 you were mentioning castles in
the ray rob sim i was mentioning but we
never got to see it because raid went
for a much more passive approach putting
the queen back on the eight gifting this
pawn on e4 almost for free
and yeah queen d8 he won bishop g2
okay short castle
saying if you like my pawn you can have
it and sam said well that's a nice pawn
uh it is that's one back that's my
backhand if you if you pick up c4
somehow well d6 was played and how about
we try to go for the other one rook to
c1 i don't know if i would go
immediately because sometimes i'm
worried about bishop h3
i grasp it take it granted you have
knight f4 right no i have rook takes c4
and bishop takes h7
what a mean guy
what's better than being two pawns down
one part
[Laughter]
so just for everybody
rooksy one
christian
uh found a really nice idea you you are
about to say that you don't like the
fact that your king might get caught in
the middle of the board there alejandro
for christensen christian pardon me not
son christian said that
check check eliminate the bishop and
suddenly instead of being two pawns down
he finds himself on
a material advantage and d6 rook c1
already played
can't really defend this pawn right no
by the way if you do see rook c4 that's
like a fistful of pieces on these great
squares rook c4 knight d5 bishop e4 i
don't imagine that sam could ever want
such an advantage out of an opening this
looks great oh my god we're going to see
another armageddon oh yeah
i i actually predicted this match to go
to armageddon the only way he can is if
sam
comes back
in a must-win game but he i mean he has
the tools for it he is up
so much time on the clock i know we
sound like a broken record here yeah
right sam is up so much time on the
clock against right you're already there
you can see the four minute difference
wow but this time the position is
playing itself exactly right yeah it's
not just natural moves natural moves
sometimes we see these complex positions
where yeah it's important to have the
time advantage but here
i don't know how black plays without
dropping d6 right whereas white well
take on c4 castle c1 right those moves
are automatic maybe with an e2 e3 when
you need it and the bishop might even
just drop back to g2 because well i
don't know if it
if it needs to hang out on the e4 square
but you're right i mean white's play is
it's just
yeah easy
or
andrei is just burning time something
his position is
terribly terrible almost hopeless to be
honest because you don't have work to
place your pieces you would love to go
at least something like knight c6
followed by queen to a5 but you cannot
do that because i'm going to exchange
and then invade on the c file just it
doesn't seem like you have a clear plan
right now and if you just wait as you
guys were mentioning i'm going to go
yeah take c4
you know the sad part about the line
that christian gave i can even go rook c
rook c4 queen a597 check hello
rook c4 knight queen a5 he wanted to
play knight
with a knight on c6
there we go rook takes c4 restoring
material equality
and this massively ugly weakness on d6
by the way ana zatanski in a must-win
situation herself how is she doing very
well i mean this is a a position that
she should feel very good as white
she's got an imbalance that's favoring
herself as she's about to play the move
rook d1 i believe i like how black i
mean this is more or less what i
expected would happen but i do not know
why there's a pot on f5
i mean i looked at this position but the
bottom f7
is kind of much better right a d takes
c5 if you recapture with the knight
then b2 b4 chases the knight back
and now this may not be a real
really fearsome threat but not the
western
that takes takes and again this is a
kind of imbalance that anna is looking
to explore yeah she's got the open file
she's ignored it and i think
what did she play without uh without and
instantly surreal playing knight e5
and actually i'm warming up to black's
position because i think bishop b7 is
coming against most moves right
it does feel like you have to probably
take that pawn on b5 maybe follow it and
i think i think it was a6 is that an
idea so let's try rook to d6 now
i'm just a little worried about knight
c4 i'm not so worried about that okay so
rook d6 you say
and if bishop b7 just to just i'm asking
the question please bishop b7
good question
thank you
that's a good question
i mean they're very nice rooks but this
is a very very difficult diagonal to
defend
it isn't i don't have time to take on b5
that's a problem so if i start with
queen b3 you're just going to clock that
diagonal with knight c4 aren't you i'm
going to play c4 wait so let's go queen
to b3 queen b3 c4 c4
really i don't know about queen b3
queen b3 c4 yeah this one is looking
good for black right why just second you
are attacking this guy maybe knight d3
now oh wow knight rook d7 guys guys
especially bishop d5
what knight takes d5 uh knight takes d5
is a temperature whoa
the knight xd5 queen takes d6
the game goes on and what a mess well
we've seen chaos these ladies are
ringing the heat i mean what's going on
they have not played one normal game i
mean
every game there's like tactics
everywhere wow pieces are hanging kings
are exposed a4
of course concept
of course the natural
what what
it makes some sense because you once you
want v5
yeah an outpost on b5 anna has captured
captured and played a4 and what you were
saying is if you play b4 then the knight
goes to b5 i like it i could ignore it i
could play bishop b7
that's what i'm afraid of i'm afraid
that this knight on e5 and most
especially if those
light squared bishops get traded
um this knight on e5 is
terrifying frankly
so e4 we're expecting bishop b7 time
situation is relatively close four
minutes for
anna and
just below six minutes for starula
okay not that close
nansova burning her time right now she's
down to her last four minutes four
minutes up from uh
10 minutes
and the position still completely
winning but she needs to find did she
find knight e5 she did not uh in the
first place she played quincy two first
oh well that's a strange move oh oh oh
oh
okay
but she's still completely still very
very powerful for her right she could
play bishop f4 that's a very good move
and
uh
yeah
bishop f4 with the threat of knight g6
which would be devastating so bishop f4
queen f6 why is she thinking for so long
now she's down to her last three minutes
three minutes and 20 seconds
wow
and burning two minutes on this
particular move
she doesn't need to this is just no no
no
she needs to let her hand make them
exactly yeah exactly just believe in
yourself believe in your moves believe
in your hands believe in your instinct
you're a good player or exactly moves
right she's an olympic
champion down to his last one minute and
45 seconds and she does that
bishop before ray ross
i'm picking up some self-doubt here yeah
back over to ray ray
and we have this pawn on d6 is being
mercilessly attacked but wait a minute
but how did he get the
bishop
well ray attacked it and sam said go
ahead take it i don't care interesting i
don't think i would have given up the
bishop i'm pretty sure i would not have
but on the other hand
uh winning the pawn on uh d6 is on rey's
agenda on sap's agenda pardon me on
sam's agenda and rook takes d6 seems
like one of those things that becomes
i mean it will happen it will happen
whether it's the next move and 10 moves
in 20 it will happen at some point
exactly so the problem is if you go rook
to c8 to try to stop me from taking on
d6 i can still take on these six and i
don't even know if i would
because if you take take take and go
king is your fate
how sure are we about this
uh with material so limited never sure
i'll take it but you take it i mean it's
a practical challenge three king f2
yeah yeah i agree yeah do you take it
right the rook on d3 defending knight on
c3 is very i mean
it's tough that it's a must-win
situation but but you have to take that
and just actually play them with queen
a5 i like that even better
after b3 b3 he played queen a5 not rook
fc8 i see a much more clever move and
immediately attacks the knight forces it
to move and there are no tricks like
rook fc edward takes d6
exactly so the knight actually does have
to move
where's the knight go actually
by the way to play b3
i'm beginning to have my doubts about v3
as well i mean uh the knight on c3 was
nicely protected is
like hey guy uh
six minutes minutes 49 seconds for
ray-ray
wow
and he went for knight d5 which is a
very uh clever move in my opinion ah it
takes the twin maybe knight to e7 first
maybe 97 first right because you don't
want to get in the major
major rook ending even though
there we go 97 checking eight shade you
probably think with the fourth rook so
that you'll never get checked well never
mind
[Laughter]
you were so close on the commentator's
curse
uh pardon me 97 check
king had to go to h8 by the way putting
the king in the corner there's something
nice
about just like forcing your opponent's
king down to his last 25 seconds because
it's about rooksy one check of rooks
he's saying great make a move you got 20
seconds
thank you seven knight d5 now i'm going
to pick up that pawn on d6 yeah it's
coming
and there's a really nice interposition
of moves not only did you force the rook
off the sixth rank to unprotect the pawn
on d6 you also force the king to a
slightly worse position on h8 super
moved as 97. eight seconds for ray
he plays so calmly i know i can go
knight to f4
uh you said the slightly worse i would
have said
it just so happens that when you put
your king on h8 you'll be surprised how
many grand masters are like all always
want to bring your king you know they're
all about g5 and king g7 and getting the
king back into
in into civilization knight to d8 right
back to something like that over e4 e4
yeah
they're cementing
and e5 is a threat i believe massive
threat that's why g5 is played exactly i
like this move by ray
by the way
ray
you know
he's fighting for his life but he's
playing these moves
really well when he's forced to play he
plays great
you know you're just wondering to
yourself why do you take so long i mean
there's a reason this guy's so good at
bullet right
knight back to d3 king g7 instantly by
the way and rey's
defending yeah yeah magnificently you
need to go to e7 and defend the pawn on
d6 then you're going to have some
difficulties with everything you know
yeah we got to make choices here as
white
exactly
you could play it slow with something
like f3 king f2 i like f3 king
king f2 but at the same point uh just
what christian is saying you put black
king on e7
how are you going to break through one
day you're going to need to play f4 and
well sam said
let's do it
before the king gets to e7
it takes take not sure about this move
king to f5 i think it's time for f5
i was about right
all the way back to c8 now i don't now
knight to b
paret the knight to that dude pirated to
d5 or to c4 because i could play knight
e5 also also yeah i like knight e5 very
much
i'm also
pawn grubber right oh now i definitely
play knight e5 i think there's a mistake
i i think a5 is a i think he blundered
95 95 looks huge 35 followed by the
knight c4 that picks up something right
must make up something well 95 you're
going to have to go to a6 rook to a6 to
defend preemptively that pawn on a5 but
then i go knight c4 you go king e7 i go
a4
next move i go rook d5 stop it oh that's
just such a great beautiful right yeah
it's just gorgeous oh my goodness so
we're looking at knight e5 right here
right now taking advantage of the pin
along the default
95 attacks he has to go rook goes to a6
he has to
go f4 he's maybe slipped missing a bit
knight e5 i think he was worried about
rook to c5 but we're not using an engine
guy so it might be that knight f4 is a
better move we actually don't know but
it looked awesome
it was really crunchy knight e5 rook c5
knight c4 was what we were all about we
wanted to uh focus on this d6 pawn i
like move b5 by black getting ready to
uh
take that bishop to b7
but wait a minute hold on i can go rook
to d5
no he played knight d5
rook to d5 rook to b6 followed by bishop
b7 would be a problem i was going to go
rook to d5 and e5 but f5 takes f5
thank you by the way yes of course
very good so pardon me after
uh b5 he played knight d5 and after
knight d5 we have b4 on the board
correct um yeah cut up to
wait wait is he going to take that you
cannot right because king e7 knight h7
on the board but knight h7 f6
f6 or rook h8 right 95 back into
rook to d3 trying to go to g3 or by the
way anatoly karp off him such positions
he puts his king on f4 first and then
that says okay
next you know but just put the king on
this very nice attractive f4 square n
king to g7 now go king to e3 and drop
the other rook to g2 try to checkmate
the black king
oh
i i like i like checkmate patterns with
very few pieces on the board i like this
domination exactly and name silva has
converted her winning position we will
have at least one armageddon coming up
that is craziness every day in
armageddon
and i tell you the first armageddon from
uh the first match between
uh
pardon me fabi and jeffrey will go down
in the annals of chess
armageddon history oh yeah one second
and jeffrey was out of the champions
bracket uh king and out of the three
rook g1 rook g3 exchanging the rooks and
now bishop to b7
mark g3 exchanging the rings i don't
like that
i don't like what he did okay that was i
mean he's really confident that this
is yeah yeah he's not sure about that
but okay
but he did put his king on f4 so ana
told him would be happy like okay uh
the legend lives on it still looks
terrible it does i mean i think the next
one on b6 and just i think the next
moves are rook d4 and knight b6 which he
played rook to d4 i was about to say
rook to d4
knight to e3 and knight to c4
okay this is this is me at my best and
everything is falling apart takes d6
knight takes d6 b4 is falling the bishop
doesn't have a good square it really
doesn't a b a b
wow now that was played with confidence
like snap that pawn on as it should yeah
exactly don't think about that one i
think e5
nothing to think about yeah e5 is like
automatic
all right shaq and knight c7 oh
he spotted knight c7 simplifying the
position into a one rook and game
exactly now rook d8 is coming also
winning a four four piece it's a full
piece guys he'll resign yes rookie seven
actually i don't know it doesn't will a
full piece i take the bishop take the
pawn on b4 i'll play the two extra pawns
and i think he's about to right what is
he going for
[Applause]
f6 get out of here with your fox get out
of here get out of here
oh wait let's drop that we still have a
game left lana zatonski needs to win
this against
you know let's look at the position on
the board or a for a armageddon
armageddon but
knight b6 guarantees that the a4 pawn
will drop
because knight takes a four you don't
have rook a2 knight c3 is check
still
well it's a three three three it should
be a draw
but
it's all about the clock it's all about
nerves the nerves the clock
and the clock is in stavroula's favor
right i see we're at 20 seconds
all right there is a park hanging on e6
you don't want to trade the rooks right
away right and king f7 can be met with
rook c7 which is you still have some
slight side issues right yeah yeah it's
not an easy draw
but probably king f7 followed by king f6
if you allow me to right
should be the way to go
get the king out yeah i don't have seven
i mean yeah
yeah yeah it makes a lot of sense rook
c7 check king f6 it's a bit passive can
you have six rook c6 but but i was six
then king f7
how how about this one guys king f7 rook
f7 czech rook c7 i don't care
and now here i'm expecting roxy 7 check
king f7 was a good movie king f6 knight
f3
with the idea of e5 check
black definitely have some issues with
series i did not see that coming
anna says the knight is a little bit
wants to take this rook b6 uh idea away
exactly rook check followed by
after king f6 rook c6 so i think she
wins upon e6 right anna is still still
alive
alive to be successful
that is a move i like king e5 what
should we do
no king e5 king e5
king to f7 okay that's a pawn up can she
nurse this
uh
and finally rook be no she's destroying
knight on e5 it's going to be a nice
night take it away from there how about
you
i was wondering about the night ending
and that's why she played rook to c2
okay again she's a pawn up but
yeah yeah right before pieces are very
active
very active
white's actually paralyzed
yuck rook to b4 king to e3 is going to
be met by g4 and we've seen immediately
and this is the draw just give it a
chance
no no no no no no
you can't go that way you cannot go
there and she's done it and back but if
have goku f3 then just wreck text d4
and the draw is inevitable inevitable
draw king of a wide web
exactly
whatever
but this is just that right two versus
two
and this is all stavi needs to pass
to
the next round of the elimination
bracket
yeah this is not going anywhere
yeah we're going to and that's it it's a
draw and anna zatonski is out of the
tournament
that was a roller coaster of a match but
stability makes it through and guys we
have one
game
remaining we have an armageddon coming
up two armageddon sorry sorry sorry two
armageddons we have two armageddons and
samsung had made that huge comeback
against ray robson and so did katarina
and silva both of them winning with the
white pieces
what a situation let me see the
let's put let's put this final dagger
on the screen that
sam had
f6 it's so beautiful there are actually
a bunch of pieces for black on the
corner you can't see them but the rook
on a7 and the bishop on the a but this
one's f6
as
deadly threat of rook to d8 jack made
and there's no way you can cover that
tonight on c7 i like to start i like how
we were thinking of routine
playing games
f6 checkmate thank you very much wow
this is great good stuff i loving it
loving it there's two
uh armageddon uh matches coming up uh
games coming up and uh
well two players eliminated two players
eliminated free and
um
so let's remind the viewers the rules
for the armageddon will have a coin flip
the winner of the coin philip gets to
choose their color
and this is the this is how it works
five minutes for white
four minutes for black there is a two
second increment starting from move 61.
so the moment you make your 61st move
you get an extra two seconds on the
clock but that only kicks in on 61 and
black of course wins if it ends in the
draw they do start with the move
disadvantage as well as the minute
disadvantage as well so they get the
draw odds and what intrigued me is both
yourself and fabi
uh
said that you would like to have the
white pieces and give the draw odds to
your opponent in these armageddons
in the five versus four armageddons
because there are other armor against
six versus five five i played i played a
terrible armageddon that was like 45
minutes against 19 minutes which champs
i don't want to talk about or you were
bidding you were bidding one another
it was that was
that was not a good system let me put it
that way
i liked it and here are the pictures
because you didn't have 19 minutes
because 45 cause i was watching
and these are the pairings
is it confirmed with white yes i'm
asking the producers
it's a 50 50. it's a 50 50 we might get
it right yeah
it is not they have not lived yet they
have not flipped yet so it will be
catering
again
this is just a matchup and
shankland will be playing against ray
robson it is actually nansova that is uh
with the black pieces oh and
with the white pieces indeed okay
shanklin is black
so we got him completely backwards not
too bad and it was a 50 50 in both cases
it's like a usb drive here like i like
our producers our producers are right
there on the spot whenever it's
whenever a serious decision has to be
chosen
zero for zero man that's great they are
amazing they always get it right oh wait
we're on ourselves guys
they put me on mute
how long until they start i believe they
should be starting momentarily right
moments away from starting their
armageddon ray certainly feels that he's
gotten out prepared every
single game and in every single game
he's taking some time to try to figure
out the opening he doesn't have this
time right now
yeah and i i have to say that that game
that we just saw
uh it was sort of like it was such a
strange game because
he he played all of these moves all the
tempo he got to this position after
knight f4 he went into a tank and he got
the worst possible position he could
out of this double pawn sacrifice by
white i mean white could not have asked
for a better position this move queen d8
who plays queen d8 there when you have
this opportunity for queen e5
very very passive play by ray it was
almost like
all i need to do is draw and i'm pretty
sure i can make a draw even if i have a
worse ending yeah but this is an
atrocious engagement and sam played it
actually uh very well
uh to force this armageddon now guys
what did i say about the armageddon i i
think i said a flip it depended on who
was white right right
between rey and sam and samya so ray is
going to be white and i have a feeling
sam probably won that coin flip because
the way this mesh has been progressing
we know that sam has a clear edge in the
opening preparation and we've seen that
he can transition uh if white robson
that is decides to play e4 he knows
exactly what he's going to do
we can good luck we're not going to beat
him in the berlin perhaps we cannot
guess and ask our uh chris our arbiter
right yeah if who on the coin flips
because i am curious on how the players
decide these things everybody has
different opinions the majority opinion
i've heard is to take white no matter
what but
that being said nothing this matters not
in this match right rey's
tools against the berlin haven't really
impressed no you know and indeed in this
particular game when you see rook c7 you
go well
but up in that moment
oh what are we thinking well
i mean
it's not 50 50 right what do you mean
what do we think of ourselves now
but i think i was the odd man out when i
was picking anna satonski
i think so too
but in the ray robson match i think it
was a 2-2 yeah it's a 2-2 as uh we had
in our panel we're flanking we split me
and var were flanking you guys look you
know i've always told you guys that
you're not paying attention control the
center be in the middle this hyper
modernist i don't know anything i know
these flank attacks don't work
christian you know better
they never learn i know
all right
what is going on through ray robson's
mind i i mean it's just about what i'm
doing opening ideas it's like i play e4
he goes e5 then what do i do
you know more than that you're not going
to go either if i'm in racial ray's not
playing e4 if uh
i'm saying to myself not the opening
what kind of play what kind of game do i
want do i want to
do i want a long struggle knight f3 g3
bishop g2 castles
uh do i want a
sharp tactic
uh oh are we seeing a coin flip right
now no no no no i think there's some
discussion of the actual rules and move
61. it feels like ray maybe is not
very happy with the coin flip situation
is that the case no idea well i mean
doesn't matter
doesn't matter he's not happy about it
it is what it is you have an extra
minute on the clock you're right you
know that your opponent is probably
going to outplay you in the theoretical
battle what do you play with three you
just play like knight f3 e3 b3
something along those lines
which probably is also known from
shanklin's perspective because he
analyzes everything right
moments away here from starting they're
playing for their lives ladies and
gentlemen there is no second chance for
these players they have already used up
one of their lives robson against
aronian and shanklin against dominguez
so this is do or die if they want to
remain here in the american cup 2022 ray
robson must win and sam is okay with the
draw that will give him the pass to the
next round the same thing for riyang and
nem sova but we're going to focus on
this game and away they go away they go
and obviously at berlin
in the three this time d3 and with d6
actually very curious most people are
playing the moves bishop c5 in this
position but of course d6 is ultra solid
absolutely
very standard spanish type structure i
think this makes a lot of sense for
robson to play
long game
and where the minute can be used exactly
i'm thinking also about this dubai world
championship match where
the world champion magnus carlson he put
his pawn on h6 he put his bishop on f8
and he said to nepo do your worst yeah
and nebu didn't do too much ooh
d5 and you can see with the speed that
shankar plays yet again he has out
prepared ray robson
you don't play d5 in a vacuum you
obviously prepare this exactly
not a big surprise because you should be
three king rather quickly certainly by
race standards it
came
why did you want him to think for five
minutes yeah exactly
sad to say i've been seeing ray really
sit on his hands too but but finally we
finally we have shanklin thinking and i
think this is robson's best like you
breathe a sigh of relief that he's not
blitzing out every single move now you
have to be very careful on that diagonal
exactly that's one of the things
you don't want to do is capture two
prematurely there is this move knight g5
uh which makes black a little bit
awkward therefore h7 h6 by excuse me h6
by sam shanklin again as you say
theoretically
queenie two played quickly at this point
we don't really care if they're good
moves or bad moves please play them fast
because we know that flagging is a real
thing here exactly and bishop e6 on the
board on the board
now
expect knight f1 knight f1
comes if you were going to play e takes
d4 you would win the last move right
followed by knight c4 you would have
done it on the last move not in this
move so knight f1 played right queen d7
knight g3 all very standard spanish type
maneuvers black has a bit more space but
it's actually facing pressure in the
center
very normal position
exactly and it's also about this f5
square or kda knight h4 oftentimes
knight already on the board oh pardon me
already on the board
these guys are playing fast
and we're being told in themselves
control we won't switch to that game but
namsara is apparently in trouble already
over here but well not that serious it's
just just a blitz game knight is coming
to f5 but now black has the option of
going taking on e4 and queen to d3 try
to exchange the queens let's see if he
goes for that he took on b3 actually
exchanging the bishops first first and
then
still went with queen to d3 forcing the
queen trade he did not go for that i'm
stunned that he didn't play queen to d3
myself again i mean you all you need is
a draw yeah that's what it's all about
in this armageddon you guys how to raise
yours doing a good job of keeping his
time advantage still a 45 second
advantage that he has over sam
and then after queen he played b4 g6
bishop e3
g6 bishop e3 that's all you need to do
just keep your time advantage and then
flag him and by the way uh not just
keeping it it's it's a slightly uh
uncomfortable uh b4 b5 on white's
agenda b8 yeah well the knight on c6
wasn't any great shakes where do you
want to
you know where are you going with that
knight to d7 i took b6 knight to c4 is
that your plan sure
i mean yeah
i don't care i think it was necessary to
kind of sidestep b5 b5 yeah
and and knight has taken uh ray by
surprise he's knight to f3 retreating
with that knight that the knight did its
job which was to coax slight weakness on
the king's side the pawn on h6
c6 that's a
weird move in my opinion attacking the
pawn on e4 but now knight to d2 seems to
be the right direction which he goes for
defending
defending the pawn
for me defending against the pawn break
b5
knight
e7 and did we see knight to b3 no queen
to c4 ray offering the queen trade here
i i can support that decision
wholeheartedly uh queen takes c4 knight
takes e4 on the board knight a5
could end up
um
cramping
my god
so now bishop a7 is going to be met by
rook to a8 but he played knight a5 first
b8
i don't like what is happening to sam's
game now sam is
being tied down to a very defensive role
and yeah it's still holding it's still
holding for sam he's played c5 i like
this move yes i like that i like that
originally not c6 i liked c5 break open
this take what can you take with the
bishop you did and i think he's he's
playing hey right white still has i like
i like this with king of two i like
knight i don't like it knight f1 i think
was much better that knight on g3 is the
big problem in white's position right
now
put it on on d6 and we're talking uh
knight knight f1
you guys should lower your voices knight
f1 on the board
knight to c4 b6 let's go to d6 why not
yeah oh yes knight c4 because you take
with the
you are absolutely right
i thought uh bishop b7 wow wait the
minute is knight takes piece no knight
takes b6 is not a move
what do you do what do you do with this
knight actually
i defend it question
kind of ugly right true what is the time
situation oh it's evened out ray robson
with a minute 40 sound channel in the
middle of 33. and if i go to d6 rook c6
actually traps
[Music]
a3 b5 knight
sam completely outplayed his opponent in
the last 10 moves or so like that was a
bamboozle 91 is
strange
truly but
it it's just a bullet game now
it really is just a bullet game now now
they're playing with a minute each no
increment whatsoever
look at that take c7 knight takes c7
the rook doesn't trade
but now i can go king to e8 it's kind of
ironic that there's a black knight on a4
attacking the pawn on bbc when there was
an a5
you picked up on it right away the same
thing i was seeing
i like rook 8 because it prepares king
e8 you don't have rook a7 knight to c2
and now king or knight c5 first he wants
driving e4
1986 hold on there's a knight f4
sighting that's okay that's okay right
okay that's not a threat knight
c two back responses
he respected they respected the number
ninety three coming to d5 maybe this
knight on b1
okay and finally the knight was about to
land on c2 and b4
what's going on
wait what is it e5
that's a huge pawn and another pawn is
coming another well well well well rook
d4 still keeps the the pawn on e4 alive
knight to c2 rook c4
that's a strange move no but now rook a1
gift me
they're going to make the time control
though they're at 25
oh spicy caterpillar with the puzzle
rush tactics ray robson takes it and
what's going on here i see
uh
obscure
yeah this is something that's uh that's
a lot of time yeah that's dirty
considering that black only needs a draw
i
think someone's like okay here
my bet is katarina nemtsova and ray
robson
pull through and go into the next round
wow wow
and that is
yep that's checkmate let's check
whoa what let's go back into this
that would no one of us saw
none of us saw but ray robson puzzle
rush master
bullet master
instantly saw it let's take a look in
the 2d board
so
they were scrambling bang bang bang bang
bang bang
sam
pounded down this move knight e1
expecting knight takes e1 when he was
ready to play rook takes b2 defend and
ending upon down ray said wait a minute
check
move your king
check
and that picks up that rook
too much material and forcing
resignation oh
my goodness hands
and what is how it looks like in slow
motion look at the confidence that he
plays rook a8 with check it out he goes
king f2 and everything's still
knight which was not a good move
and ray had that one yeah this is
this is the stuff right here rook takes
recognizing that you have this fork and
landing with a rook check now i guess he
had to defend with the knight drop the
knight back no but it doesn't help does
it help it doesn't help takes c8 knight
c5 i take on b3 and the knight on e1 is
hanging as well except i go knight d3
champion
on b2
you have to take my rook first yeah you
know i did i got the rook knight c5 king
takes c4 can you say it knight b3 knight
d3 check and i take the pawn on b2 and
we play four versus three which i
probably lose no but after knight c
there must be some other kind of good
move yeah i can just take on e1 for
example with the king the problem is
knight d3 check king
e3 knight b2 king f4 you might just come
no
i i think i just take only one with the
kick rook takes d3 or it takes cirrus
two extra puns
armageddon uh very very very tough to
call as exciting as it is for us for the
players it must be nerve-wracking
nerve-wracking let's take a look at the
brackets and how we stand we have
eliminated four players from the
tournament but first let's look at the
champions bracket aronian against
dominguez they had their first game
today dominguez destroyed levon erroneon
with the black pieces he only needs to
draw tomorrow to pass and meanwhile sam
savion defended very well against the
new idea by fabiano caruana with this
move rocate to route d2 and they drew
their game there will play with the
opposite colors tomorrow meanwhile in
the elimination bracket ray robson moves
on through over sam shanklin with a
crazy armageddon really going down to
the wire and meanwhile jeffrey shong he
missed a chance to equalize there
against wesley so he really had it in
his hands but wesley defended
tenaciously came back from nowhere and
drew that game he moves on to the next
round and meanwhile he's in the ladies
section in the uh champions bracket
irena crush drew against tokyo nova
today in a lost position
certainly can find herself as the lucky
one today alex lee just completely
crushed that of abrahamian with the
white pieces started yet again with a
must-win situation and in the
elimination bracket it was the
armageddon that allowed katherine
anderson to pass over riyan yan and in
uh the playoffs uh solakiru one and a
half half over anasakowsky she moves on
satonski the second seed actually
eliminated early in the tournament
absolutely
we have a special guest with
christian
thank you uh yasser yes we are indeed
with sam shanklin sam commiserations for
the match a very difficult match you
lost the first uh match bounced back and
who picked in the armageddon tell us of
course it was ray i mean it's very
fortunate to draw white when you know
there's no incremental move 60 and
yeah i mean to know at some point when
it's this fast it it feels largely
random like of course i was totally fine
in this game but it's um
yeah what can you do ray played well
when it counted so you feel that white
has an advantage when whenever it comes
to the arm again despite the fact that
it felt like you were gaining a lot of
time every single time you guys were
playing because your theoretical
knowledge seemed to surpass use yeah i
mean i prepared them all five games of
course in rapid that's not the most
important album not by a long shot um
but uh
yeah i mean when just when like you're
losing on time is a thing one extra
minute is huge and also like i mean just
thinking about he was he got in huge
trouble with black both games uh that we
had um i sort of thought that you know
white would be really nice to have there
um but
yeah i mean i would think five versus
like three and a half or sorry five
versus four is
i don't know i i don't know how to i
don't think put much time and effort
into that i do think that
drawing white was favorable to him but
it's he did not win the match because he
drew white he won the match because he
played better than me when it counted so
yeah
yeah sir
uh no
commiserations uh great games i mean for
the
spectators for ourselves it's very very
entertaining could you
tell the spectators how nerve-wracking
it is or did you feel calm during this
armageddon i felt pretty calm i mean i
i've always had really good nerves uh
all of my intangibles i think are
fantastic it's the only way an idiot
like me can be 2700 but um
no i mean i it's just another day at the
office you know here we were playing for
you know like what six thousand dollars
more and i just didn't like notice at
all i mean just it's
but i'm glad that uh we get some
excitement for the fans uh
you know i have mixed feelings about
rapid overall but
well this excitement you can't beat
there's certainly nothing that's the the
positive draw to it
thank you sam uh
i mean sound you're so impressed with
your preparation i'm so impressed with
your professionalism on the board
it's tough to kick people out of this
tournament it's a knockout somebody has
to leave but man that was a great
performance
thank you
and there we go
wow tomorrow's schedule if you don't
mind alignment it's not over yet
tomorrow we have more games it'll be a
slower day tomorrow we don't have
elimination bracket games tomorrow but
we do have champions brackets tomorrow
as group a and group b do have two games
each we'll have dominguez playing
against aronian where arunia needs to
win with the black pieces exactly and in
the other one sevian with the white
pieces we'll be trying to push against
fabiano carrana meanwhile in the ladies
section irina crush will be facing with
the black pieces defending against
begging tokyo nova and in the other one
a must-win situation for tateva bahamian
who will be facing alice lee the
youngster that is sizzling in this
tournament and of course if any of the
matches are tied one one then they will
go into the playoffs right immediately
immediately after the classical
wow and now we have christian with the
guy who's just really happy to be here
christian thank you yes sir ray first of
all big congratulations that was just
simply a crazy match how do you feel
right now
yeah i feel i feel pretty good kind of
tired but yeah i'm relieved that i
managed to get out of this uh with the
wind somehow because all the games were
really difficult
we were seeing you on camera before the
armageddon started just bouncing back
and forth what were you thinking at that
point
a little bit about what opening
might occur but uh yeah mostly just
nervous pacing i don't think i was
really thinking about much of anything
just i was disappointed that i lost the
previous game
um and just trying to get myself ready
to you know go all out for the win in
the army kid
and it felt like it was very very
difficult for you to gain an advantage
out of the opening or at least take him
out of his preparation how did you come
up to this conclusion to play the d3 uh
berlin
well i would say in the
third game um of the match that was the
one where i was best prepared compared
to him and i think i did get some
advantage there
at least i think that was what my
preparation said and that was the game i
was able to to win and the last game
with the arm again with no increment and
very short time control my goal was just
to get
get a game so probably i didn't get any
advantage of the opening it was just
something quiet but
we kept a lot of pieces on there was
going to be a lot of maneuvering and a
tense struggle and that was that was my
goal
well you survived you have a rest day
tomorrow how are you going to spend that
rest day um
who am i playing
you don't know i think tomorrow you will
have a rest day because uh the
championship is that you don't know your
first round is still playing and which
people could i right in the bracket
in the bracket i believe
it's either fabiano or sam i think i
think so yeah okay i mean
here we go yeah i'll mostly uh
mostly just rest i think especially for
rapid i find it's most important just to
not prepare too much just to be sharp
i think my very first game of the
tournament i
wasn't able to do that as well and after
that i've just focused on being well
rested eating enough and
just being mentally prepared to to play
tough games
well congratulations on surviving this
difficult match and looking forward to
seeing your the rest of your matches
thanks quick quick a chess uh question
for you ray if you don't mind just at
the very end you your opponent has just
played knight takes e1 everybody was
expecting knight takes e1 and boom you
lowered the hammer with rook a check and
knight c5 you saw that from afar or just
at the
a half a second
before you were going to play knight
takes e1 you saw the fork no it just
happened in the
yeah
during the moment i mean we're just
going forward a similar thing happened
in the other game which i won game three
suddenly like i could have taken a piece
and i would have been up a bishop but he
had two pawns maybe i wasn't sure if it
was a draw and suddenly i had a rookie
seven check at the end and that just
ended the game which i didn't see from
afar and here of course i i saw this lie
might be happening and i'm gonna have to
play the four verse three and all of a
sudden i see the check and then i see
like he has no squares and yeah it just
happened all of a sudden i think neither
of us saw it coming thank you ray good
luck uh
in the rest of the tournament thanks
absolutely
i feel like
i mean yeah i think the the the
armageddon with abby and jeffrey put me
over the edge this is like
yeah this is really fun stuff it was
really fun stuff this was amazing
wow well christian some final thoughts
about today's games they were really
really fun
what do you think
my goodness i mean so much back and
forth between this uh
all of the players actually we saw
nemtsova come back from the death she
was uh so she was playing such a
terrible chest but then with the black
pieces managed to bounce back once then
bounce back twice force the armageddon
which she dominated of course so lucky
dude in my opinion was just today the
better prepared player i did not like
the tonski's time management that was
the big problem and her downfall in my
opinion but this sizzling match between
robson and shanklin well i'm going to
have to watch that back at home maybe
and relive this moment and i'm looking
forward to tomorrow's matches
thank you thing yeah great stuff great
great great stuff well
we're going to sign up
we're like still we're still
that was an amazing way to finish the
day two armageddon games caterina
and ray robson make it through we sadly
say goodbye to four players thank you
for participating extremely strong riyan
yan
uh jeffrey shong anna satonski and sam
shanklin certainly they could be playing
on the next rounds but somebody has to
go home in this format right and
then that's it tomorrow remember four
classical games
don't miss them we might have a long day
tomorrow because the playoffs for them
are tomorrow as well we will see who
survives and who goes down to the
elimination bracket
thank you everyone and good night see
you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the saint
louis chess club is prohibited
you